BATES IS HERE I AM GOING TO. HI
GUYS CHERRY. OKAY THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE- IS
GOING TO BEGIN IN SIXTY SECONDS
THIS IS A WARNING A HEADS UP TO
THE SENATE I. T. TEAM- THE SAID
SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- WILL COME TO
ORDER- IN ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS.
WHO GIVE A TIME.
ALL RIGHT THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. ORDER A GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE- IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
SENATORS AND SENATE STAFF WILL
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
IN IN HERE SO SOCIAL DISTANCING
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
SENATE WILL BE HOLDING
ESSENTIAL HEARINGS AND IS MADE
NECESSARY TO THE NORMAL
PROCEDURES AND PRACTICES IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE BOTH HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE PROCESS BY CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT SPEAKS TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND THE OF
THE PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES.
FROM WITH THESE ORDER WERE
PULLING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING.
IN THE CAPITAL OF WITH ONE OF
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING IN THIS
PARTICULAR HEARING A REMOTELY-
WITH THE USE OF A VIDEO
CONFERENCE SYSTEM. FOR MEMBERS
WHO WILL BE ATTENDING REMOTELY
THAT PLEASE MOVE YOUR PHONE'S
OBVIOUSLY- AND THAT OR YOUR
COMPUTERS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A SEAMLESS HONOR
INTERRUPTED PROCESS. IS A
LIMÓN A FEET AND OTHER
DISTRACTIONS. EVERY TWO. WE A-
SO JUST UP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR R. I. T. I WILL PUT. YOU
BACK ON MUTUAL YOU KNOW THAT I
THINK WE HAVE ONE PERSON
REMOTELY SO. FOLLOW THAT. TO
ALLOW THE ACCESS WE'VE HAD BEEN
MEMBERS OF THE TO HEAR ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DE
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELE SERVICE FOR THE IN
THE WHO TO TODAY FOR ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO PARTICIPATE
TOLL FREE NUMBER AN ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL ALSO DO BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SIX TWO FIVE ZERO
SEVEN THREE ZERO THEY SAY THAT
ONE MORE TIME THE PHONE NUMBER
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SIX TWO FIVE
ZERO SEVEN THREE WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR
WELL I DON'T I THE END OF. OPEN
YOUR- AND I TIME YOU DRESSED
COMMITTEE TO NOTE THAT IN ORDER
US TO HEAR YOU CLEAR. AND TWO
OF IT TWO SIX THREE BACKING
NHIÁU OF YOU'RE- BY THE
HEARING ON PRIOR GIVING. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE ONE TO THANK YOU YOUR
PART. IN PATIENTS- I WILL
MAINTAIN OBVIOUS THAT THE
DECORUM OF THE COMMITTEE-
DURING- THE HEARING AS
CUSTOMARY INDIVIDUALS WHO DON'T
I BY THE PURSUE. WILL BE WITH
APPROPRIATELY AS- TO HAPPENS
AND HOPEFULLY DOESN'T. SOLVE A
GOOD TIME TO REMIND. PROVIDING
TESTIMONY THAT IS A FRESH
COMMITTEE. SO PLEASE LET YOUR
TESTING TO THE FOR AS- OF THE
BILL WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE RE
LITIGATING- THE MERITS OF THE
POLICY. IN THIS COMMITTEE SO
PLEASE REFRAIN FROM A POLICY
DISCUSSION AND FOCUS ON. THE
FISCAL THERE'S A WHITE CASKET
SAT EXCEPT. SO WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO.
HEARING AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS
IN A CLOSED. AS AS CLOSE. TO
THE SAME MANNER AS IS BECAUSE-
THERE MAY SOME LAG TIME FOR
PART. WHO ARE ADJUSTING TO THE
USE OF THE NEW ONLINE TOOLS
CHECK. PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL
IMPATIENT AS WERE ALL. DOING
THE BEST WE CAN DURING THESE
EXTRAORDINARY. TIMES. WE HAVE
NINETY SIX ON IT. FOR A WHICH
ELEGY FOR TO PASS MOTION THE
REMAINING BILLS ARE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES WHILE MOST OF THE
AUTHORS OF THE BILL'S MEETING
THE CRITERIA FOR SPENCER SPENCE
HAVE WAY PRESENTATIONS WE
ALWAYS PROVIDE OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUBLIC. COMMENT ON ALL MEASURES
THOUGH I AGAIN ASK OUR-
PARTICIPANTS AND SPEAKERS TO BE
SUCCINCT AS THESE ARE- THIS
GONNA BE A LONG HEARING TODAY
AND- THE AUTHORS OF WAY
PRESENTATION SO USE THAT AS AN
INDICATION. AND MODEL YOUR
BEHAVIOR BASED ON THE AUTHORS-
APPROACH- BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATIONS ON THE BILL I'D
LIKE TO WORK ACT SENATOR LEYVA
WHO IS- BEEN RECENTLY APPOINTED
TO THE COMMITTEE AND THANK THE
REST OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR BEING HERE TODAY- WE- A
FULL COMMITTEE. THIS AND ONE
REMOTE. AND SO THE SAN COULD
CALL THE ROLL WILLISTON OUR
CORE. I'D LIKE TO REMIND
MEMBERS TO MAKE YOUR MICROPHONE
IS ON FOR ANNOUNCING POINT. I'M.
MISS BATES BRADFORD YOUR
PRESENT HELLO HERE PRESENT
JONES. I'M HERE LEYVA YOUR-
HERE MY COUNTY HERE. HEALTHCARE
WE HAVE A CORE. INCLUDED COPY
OF OUR BILL BY VILLAGE AND ON
THE FRONT PAGE OF THE
COMMITTEES WEB AT W. W. DOT S.
A. P. R. DOT SENATE DOT CA DOT
GOV IF ANY MEMBER THE PUBLIC
WANTS TO FOLLOW ALONG TO DO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF THE HEARING
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS. A
NEW CLEANING PROTOCOLS THE
COMMITTEE WILL IN TWO TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY.
ACCORDINGLY IT MAY BE NECESSARY
TO LIMIT. BOOK BOTH SO WE'RE
GONNA BE LIMITING BOTH
PROPONENTS AND OPPONENTS. TO A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES PER SIDE
AND I ASKEDTHE TESTIMONY BE
LIMITED TO THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS
OF THE BILL. ALL OTHERS WISHING
TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL- SO WE ARE GOING TO
GO TO OUR FIRST BILL. WHICH IS
MISTER HILL. SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE UNFLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS. FISCAL ASPECTS WE ARE
WAVING PRESENTATION WITH THAT.
FROM YOU KNOW YOU ARE CORRECT
THAT YOUR SECOND BILL THAT YOU
I GUESS THAT I'M GOING SEE THE-
WAS NOT. THERE SO THE RAPID.
SAYS SEVEN NINETY OTHER
PROPONENT. WITH LIKE TO SPEAK.
ANYBODY LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. BOOK. YEAH YEAH ALL
RIGHT SHOWS THERE NOBODY IN TWO
OH THREE YOU WANT THIS AND SO
OF THE BILL. IS THERE ANYBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. WE'LL NOW MOVE TO
MEMBERS ON THE PUBLIC WAITING
TO TESTIFY ON THE
TELECONFERENCE IS THERE ANYBODY.
BEIJING GENTLEMEN ON THE AUDIO
IF YOU WISH TO VOICE SUPPORT IN
A RESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. HELLO AND PLEASE WE
DO HAVE A COUPLE SHOWING UP
WE'RE GOING TO PROVIDE THEIR
LINE NUMBERS AND Q. THEM UP.
THE RARE DOES NOT APPEAR THAT
THERE'S ANY. FOUR FIVE. WE DO
HAVE SOME ON THE PHONE WHILE
TWENTY THE PLACE. IN I WILL GO
TO LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ONE LINE HUNDRED TWENTY
ONE YEAR LINE IS OPEN. THE
FARMER ARE FROM YOUR COUNT
REFER. THE TEXT AS- BEAR OWN
OPPOSITION HERE. SIXTY I GREW
WEAKER TO CLEAN THEIR ROLE.
EARLY AND THEN. ALSO BUT ONLY
VOTING IN THIS. THERE ARE HAS.
ADDED FOR AROUND THE RIGHT TO
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO MAN THIS
ALLOW TO BUY IF THE CALL MAY
THIS IS THE RIGHT BILL WERE ON
AS SO NINETY. SO THANK YOU.
MODERATOR PLEASE MOVE TO THE
NEXT PERSON. SELECT ONE IN Q.
IS LAW NUMBER TWO NINE LINE
NINE YOUR LINE IS A- HELLO CHEN
NUMBER OF HAVING ATTENTION THE
CARBON IN KAISER ON BEHALF OF
COMMON SENSE THE COPE ON AND
INCH ON THE OF THE BILL. THANK
THANK YOU. WELL NOW THAT LINE
NUMBER NINE. WE NINE YOUR IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS LAUREN
DOLLARS FROM RESIDENT
HUNTINGTON BEACH HELLO AND ON
THE LOOK BILL THAT YOU KNOW YOU
GREEN. WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
ONE HOW AND TWENTY ONE TWO YOUR
IS A- MR TO. VERSION HEARST
TODAY BEHALF OF THE LAST
ANGELES FOR OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN NINE THREE.
THANK YOU. GROWING ONE AND ONE
ZERO THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU TERRY MEMBERS JANICE
TO TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF OUR MEDIA IN SUPPORT OF THAT
THE SEVEN NINETY THREE THANK
YOU. OVERALL I NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX ONE TWO
SIX ONE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF
DECEMBER COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO ONE
THREE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING. ANDREW EMPLOYEE
ON BEHALF OF THE TOBACCO FREE
KIDS AND SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE YOU MAY
CONTINUE. FORTY TWO OR THREE
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION I SEE AND
THEN WE WILL GO TO. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WHO ARE OPPOSED TO SEVEN
NINETY THREE. MY SCREEN DIDN'T
CHANGE BUT SO I ASSUME NOT. AND
THEN WE WILL MOVE ON TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION VIA
TELECONFERENCE POTTERY PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO SEVEN
NINETY THREE AND LET ME KNOW
HOW MANY THERE ARE. CERTAINLY
IF YOU WISH TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION OF THE CURRENT BILL
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN IS ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE LOOKS
LIKE AT LEAST. SEVERAL HALF A
DOZEN CUTE SO FAR WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND TWO
ONE ZERO TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IT WAS CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN
WINGER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FUEL THE CONVENIENCE.
WHO OVER OF THE- TWELVE
THOUSAND GAS STATIONS THE
CONVENIENCE STORES THE STATE.
WE JUST KNOW THAT WE JUST A
WITH YOU TO TFA IS ANALYSIS ON
THE MILLION DOLLAR LAW RIDICULE.
YOU'RE A BILLION. WE ALSO
DISAGREE WITH ON. SAVING AS WE
CAN THE MID OF UNDER A YOU. GET
THEIR PRODUCTS FROM PEOPLE
TWENTY AND OVER SO THEY WILL GO.
GO ONLINE SO WE WOULD DO WITH
BOTH OF THOSE THIS NOW THANK
YOU. BOOK WITH A LINE NUMBER
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE ONE TWO
NINE LINE IS A- YEAH. THAT
COULD IN CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPOSE THE BILL BECAUSE THAT
THE TYPICAL. HAITIAN AND LACK
HEALTH YOU KNOW BRAIN CRY THAT
WHICH ABOUT REDUCED REVENUE.
AND ON TOP OF THAT YOU KNOW.
YOUR POSITION. BOOK ONLINE
NUMBER TWENTY TWO TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS KEVIN
OKAY- WHO I AM IN IRVINE
CALIFORNIA I REPRESENT FIVE
HARMS WHERE YOU LIVE COULD
MANUFACTURE THIS WILL DEVASTATE
OUR RETAILERS THIS WILL
DEVASTATE MANY MORE BUSINESSES
DUE TO- COLD IT IN CLOSING
BUSINESSES ANY OF YOU COOL
POLITICIANS IN FAVOR OF THIS.
OBVIOUSLY ARE DISCONNECTED AND
HAVEN'T DONE YOUR RESEARCH ON
THIS. TECHNOLOGY THAT THE
ABILITY OFF THAT THE LEADING
CAUSE OF PREVENTABLE DEATH
YOU'RE THE PROBLEM LEASE CAN
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME
YOUR POSITION AND THAT'S IT
THANK YOU. LITTLE. LINE NUMBER
TWENTY THREE TO THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS DONNA
RYAN CREEK OFTEN ENGAGED HELP
FOR NOW I'M IN OPPOSITION OF
BOSTON THE BILL START MIDNIGHT
THANK YOU. THE MODEL COMMON BUT
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND TEN
LINE ONE ONE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BY UPDATE RAMSEY- CARD OF
CALIFORNIA BY MOST OF MULTIPLE
WAR COMBAT DISABLED VETERANS
YOU QUIT SMOKING USING FLAVOR
LABEL PRODUCTS. BY THOSE SEVEN
NINE THREE- MATING IS ALREADY
ILLEGAL FOR KIDS THANK YOU SIR
WE- THANK YOU. PUT A LINE
NUMBER EIGHTEEN ONE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BY NAY TEAM
PLEASE CHECK YOUR LINE FOR SELF
MUTE. THAT DURING THE AUDIO
WILL MOVE ALONG TO THE NEXT ONE
WHICH IS LINE NUMBER SIXTY
THREE LINE SIX THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO YES YOUR LINE IS
OPEN SIR- MY NAME IS TRAVIS-
TRAVIS PAPER I AM IN- STUDIO
CALIFORNIA I DON'T HAVE ANY
ORGANIZATION I REPRESENT I JUST
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT I OPPOSE
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT REALLY IS
JUST GOING TO MAKE THE PEOPLE
WHO DO THAT YOU'RE DOING USED
LABOR TOBACCO PRODUCTS GO
ELSEWHERE FOR THEM. AND THANK
YOU WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR ONE FOUR
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANKS.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE TEACHER
MEMBERS IMMEDIATELY ON BEHALF
OF CBS HEALTH IN SUPPORT. A
GROWING NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY SEVEN ONE FOUR SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
JAMIE MARK ANALYSTS THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION OF
CROWDS CO SPONSORED THE BILL IN
SUPPORT. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE ONE FOUR THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
MELISSA VESTER A MATURE WOMAN-
YOU NEED USER TAKER VAPING-%
BOARD MEMBER OF NEIGHBORHOOD
MARKET AJ JOHN AN OWNER OF BAIT
AND THE SIX ONE NINE I'M
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. AND WHAT
A LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SIX ONE FIVE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SH I MISSED THAT
SHORT ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ON COLLEGES. I'M IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND THE BUS
EXHAUST THE QUEUE YOU MAY
CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION- WILL NOW BRING%
BACK DISCUSSION MEMBERS-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS MEASURE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SEEING
NONE IF NINE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB SEVEN NINETY THREE WILL MOVE
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE WHICH
BRINGS UP TO MISTER HILLS NEXT
BILL SB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE AND
YOU'RE GONNA. PRESENT THAT
BRIEFLY IT'S A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU CHAIR-
GOOD MORNING AND MEMBERS- IT SB
EIGHT SIXTY FIVE MAKES
COMMONSENSE CHANGES TO THE DIG
SAFE LAW THAT SUPPORT LOOKS
SAFE EXCAVATION PRACTICES AND
STRENGTH AND COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN SUBSURFACE
INFRASTRUCTURE. STAKEHOLDERS
THE BOARD WAS ESTABLISHED TO
IMPROVE ENFORCEMENT OF CALL
BEFORE YOU DIG LAW AND ABOUT
THE WAIT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
IMPROVING SAFETY BUT THEY
CANNOT DO THEIR JOB THESE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ARE ACTIVELY
INVESTIGATING AND FORCE IN.
THIS REQUIREMENT CANNOT DO
THEIR JOB WITHOUT THE PROPER
DATA SUCH AS HOW MANY DIGGINS
ARE OCCURRING WHERE THEY ARE
HAPPENING HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
CALLING EIGHT ONE ONE WHO IS
CALLING AND WHO ISN'T. EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE EQUIPS THE DIG SAFE
BOARD WITH THE NECESSARY TOOLS
TO PERFORM THEIR STATUTORY
DUTY. SB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE ALSO
ENSURES THAT ACTUALLY LEADERS
HAVE ACCURATE INFORMATION
BEFORE A SHOVEL FULL OF EARTH
IS TURN BY REQUIRING ALL NEW
SUBSURFACE INSTALLATIONS BGP.
G. I. S. TAG. AND ALSO MOVES IT
TAKES A POOR TO THE OFFICE OF
ENERGY AND INFRASTRUCTURE
SAFETY. MY OFFICE CONTINUES TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS. NOT
CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL BE ABLE
TO FIND A RESOLUTION THAT WORKS
FOR ALL STAKEHOLDERS. IN FACT
WE HAVE A- IF WE- IF ANY
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE WE CAN
DISCUSS SOME OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS. AND WHERE WE ARE
SOME OF THEM WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE ALREADY ON THE- THE SENATE
FLOOR SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT
AND I DO HAVE I DO HAVE A
WITNESS- WHO- ROB CROSS GLASS-
GROWS CLOSER WILL BE TESTIFYING
ON BEHALF OF USA NORTH IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. AND THEY
SHE IN THIS RUMOR SHE HE IS-
ROB IS. I THINK ON THE LINE.
ALL RIGHT. ROB SHOULD WE GO TO
THE ROOM FIRST. HI I DON'T SEE
THEM ON THE PHONE AFTER THE
MODERATOR FROM. MODERATOR IS
ROB ON THE LINE. CHECKING FOR
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THESE ARE
WITNESS. I AM NOT SHOWING THEM
ON THE AUDIO ALL RIGHT IN THAT
CASE WE'LL JUST GO THROUGH OUR
PROCEDURES AND WE'LL CATCH UP
TO HIM IF WE CATCH UP TO HIM IS
THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK I IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE. SEEING NO RUSH IS
THERE ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. THAT WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE.
SEEING NONE A MODERATOR PLEASE-
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE ON THE PHONE THAT
THIS IS THE SUPPORT TIME AND
LET ME KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
THERE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN
THE AUDIO LINE AND WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN IT'S ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I HAVE ONE CURRENTLY IN THE
QUEUE ORDER LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN ONE TO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
RATHER CHRIS CLOSER IN SUPPORT
OF CREDIBILITY FIFTY FIVE ON
BEHALF OF UNDERGROUND SERVICE
ALERT OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
NEVADA. COMMONLY KNOWN AS YOU
AS THE NORTH IN ONE ONE. WHICH
IS THE ORIGINAL CALL CENTER OUR
ORIGINAL CALL BEFORE YOU DIG
NOTIFICATION CENTER THAT SERVES
THE NORTHERN TWO THIRDS OF THE
STATE. BUT I DON'T THINK
SENATOR HELPERS CONTINUED
DEDICATION TO THE TISSUE AND
FOR BEING AN ABSOLUTE CHAMPION
OF UNDERGROUND THANK YOU
PROTECTIONS. THIS MEASURE LATE
BECAUSE THAT DAMAGE PREVENTION
AND SAFETY IN ADDITION WE
BELIEVE WILL LEAD TO BETTER
PROTECTION OF CALIFORNIA'S
UNDERGROUND UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY. TO GIVE
CALIFORNIANS WE ARE YOUR
SUPPORT- SENATE BILL EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- THERE'S ANYONE ELSE ON THE
LINE IN SUPPORT. THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE CUED UP AT THIS TIME
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU WILL
GO BACK TO FORTY TWO OR THREE
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE OR THEN WE WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION SEEING NINE THEN WE
WILL GO TO OUR PHONE LINE
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO IS IN OPPOSITION OF
SB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE AND LET ME
KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE THERE.
SECURE UP IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES TO EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
YOU MAY DO SO BY PRESSING ONE
HAVE ONE THAT IS COMING UP
PLEASE WHILE MOMENT. DOWN FOR.
ONE AND A HALF TO GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SIX ONE SIX SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS TODD BLOOM STEIN
THROUGH THE UNDERGROUND SERVICE
ALERT. OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COMMONLY CALLED DICK ALERT.
NUCLEAR DOES ADOPTED IN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THE
BILL. OUR CONCERNS ARE
PRIMARILY RELATED WITH THE
MANDATE IN SECTION THREE. THAT
REQUIRES BIGELOW TO PROVIDE ALL
NOTIFICATION RECORDS TO THE
STATE. BIGELOW FIELDED
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND CONTACTS FOR
SERVICE LAST YEAR DOES YOUR
QUESTION READ ABOUT EIGHT AND A
HALF MILLION NOTIFICATION
RECORDS NUCLEAR PREFERS A MORE
COOPERATIVE BEEN PARTNERING
APPROACH INSTEAD OF THE MANDATE
JAMES AND THE CURRENT LANGUAGE
WE'VE HAD SEVERAL ELEMENTS ON
THE LITTLE DIFFICULT AND YOU
HAVE COMMENTS ON THE FISCAL
IMPACT AS OPPOSED TO THE POLICY.
RELATED ISSUE NONETHELESS I
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE ARE IN
CONTACT WITH THE SENATOR AND
HIS OFFICE WE HAVE A DEEP
RESPECT FOR HIM AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER- IT
AT THIS TIME THE DEALER DOES
HAVE AN OPPOSE LESS AMENDED
STATION ON THE BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE ON THE LINE. NO ONE ELSE
AT THIS TIME SIR ALL RIGHT SO
THAT EXHAUSTS ARE FORTY AGAINST
COMMENTS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS
BILL ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. WE HAVE A MOTION I
SEE NO HAND UP ON MY- SCREEN.
MR HELL I ASSUME YOU HAVE A
SHORT CLIENTS RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONAUT VOTE AND THE ISSUES
RAISED BY A- MISTER BRUSTEIN IS
WILL GET THE RESULT I BELIEVE
BEFORE THE FOR VOTE AND SERVE
AS WELL AS THE WEST FROM
GROVER'S CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
UNITED CONTRACTORS HAVE
CONCERNS AND IT'LL BE DONE
BEFORE THE FOR VOTERS WELL SO
THANK YOU RESPECT AS PRIVATE
MEMBERS ARE RIFE WITH THAT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THANK YOU
MISTER THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE- FLOOR PORTANTINO. HI TINA
HI BATES. BRADFORD OUR BRADFORD
BY HILL HI BILL I JONES VOTING.
LEYVA HI LEYVA OUR WHITE HOUSE
SKI HI BY CASKEY FIVE. VOTERS
FIVE ZERO THE BILL IS OUT. OF
THOSE AT FIVE ZERO. ARE WE WILL
MOVE ON TO SB NINE TWENTY SIX
WHICH IS A CANDIDATE FORCES
SPENCE- AND MISTER WAS WAY
PRESENTATIONS WILL RISE THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONIES ANYBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE IN
SUPPORT OF NINE TWENTY SIX.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANYONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT OF
NINE TWENTY SIX. SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF NINE TWENTY SIX
MODERATOR PLEASE LET ME KNOW.
THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR NINE TWENTY
SIX THREE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. HELLO WE DO
HAVE TWO THAT ARE SHOWING UP
PLEASE ALLOW MOMENT. BURGER
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN ONE ONE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER
ON BEHALF OF DISABILITYRIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE TWENTY SIX. THANK YOU A
LITTLE AYE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVEN ONE ZERO SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS DRIVING GRAY WELL IF
YOU HAVE TO W. AS- COUNSEL AND
APART. AND THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL COME BACK TO
FORTY TWO OR THREE YEARS OR ANY
OPPOSITION. SHE AND WE WILL GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION. SCENE NINE THE
MODERATOR WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE PLEASE GIVE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION TO LET ME KNOW IF
THERE'S ANYBODY THERE. THANK
YOU COULD LIKE TO JOKE IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE
IS NO OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
LINES AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
COMING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANYBODY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE NO COMMENTS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB NINE TWENTY SIX
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
TO SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE ALSO BY
MISTER HILL- WHO IS WAY
PRESENTATION WE WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENT IS THERE
ANYBODY IN FORTY TWO OH THREE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE
ON WORKERS COMPENSATION. SEEING
NO ONE IN THIS ROOM IS THERE
ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. SEE
NO ONE AT ELEVEN FORTY IS OR
ANYONE ONLINE. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AGAIN ON THE LEVIN
FIFTY NINE WE CAN SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE THOSE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE. A
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SEVEN ONE FIVE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE CHECK
YOUR LINE FROM HERE TO. HEARING
NO RESPONSE LITTLE LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN
ONE EIGHT SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AS TO WHEN WE BRAG ARE IN
VENTURA COUNTY I AM CALLING TO
OPPOSE A. B. EIGHT SIXTY. WRONG
WILL THANK YOU WRONG WILL WRONG
HOUSE. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE CAN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GO TO WAS AT A. I WE'RE
GONNA COME BACK TO BUT I GOT
DISTRACTED REALLY COME BACK TO
OUR COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE- WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB ELEVEN FIFTY NINE
WILL GO TO. SUSPENSE WE WILL BE
MOVING THANK YOU MISTER HILL.
WILL BE MOVING TO MISTER BELL.
THE BILL HAS SB SEVEN NINETY
FIVE ON ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT HE
IS WAY PRESENTATION FOR ANYBODY
IN FORTY TWO OR THREE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SEVEN
NINETY FIVE. ANYBODY WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ACTION ME
WE'RE GONNA GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYBODY WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN NINETY FIVE. AND LET ME
KNOW HOW MANY ARE SUPPORTED SB
SEVEN NINETY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE. AT THIS TIME TO VOICE
SUPPORT. BELOW THE LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN ONE ONE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THERE'S NO
RESPONSE FROM THAT LINE ONE
MOMENT WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE THAT
SECURING. GROWING NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED NINETY SIX ONE NINE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH FIND
ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE CHECK
YOUR LINE FOR MUTE. HEARING
ONLY BACKGROUND NOISE THERE IS
NO RESPONSE THERE'S ALSO NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
TO OPPOSITION LET'S COME BACK
TO FORTY TWO OH THREE IS
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION. TO SEVEN
NINETY FIVE SEEING NINE WILL GO
TO TWENTY FORTY. DOES ANYBODY
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE WILL GO
ONLINE MODERATOR PLEASE GIVE
ANYBODY WHO IS IN OPPOSITION.
TO SEVEN NINETY FIVE. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO VOICE OPPOSITION TO
SEVEN NINETY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN IS ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX ONE NINE
EIGHT SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY MY NAME IS DIRECTLY WITH
THE LA COUNTY BUSINESS
FEDERATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL I THINK IT WAS A
MISCOMMUNICATION WITH SECURITY.
THANK YOU. AND THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT- THAT- FINISHES WITH
OUR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. I
BELIEVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS SOME COMMENTS ON
THIS MEASURE AND THAT WILL BE
V. AS SOON THERE SHE IS GOOD
MORNING. MORNING GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS JOANNA
THERE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL BUT WITH
NO TO- AS YOUR STAFF COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCES ALSO NOTES THAT THE
BILL CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATE.
TEN BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND OR TWO BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY OR TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND FOR THE
FOLLOWING FOR FISCAL YEARS OF
WHICH ONE POINT ONE FIVE
BILLION GOES TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. A SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION WOULD GO TO THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD AND ONE
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE MILLION TO
GO IS. ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD
NOT THE BILL WILL RESULT IN
ONGOING COST OF ABOUT ELEVEN
POINT THREE MILLION TO TWENTY
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. TO
MEET THE MONITORING OBLIGATIONS
INCLUDED IN THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SEVEN
NINETY FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON THE SP EIGHT OH THREE
ALSO BY MISTER BELL HAS WAY
PRESENTATION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF SB EIGHT
OH THREE BY MISTER BELL. HE IS
MOVING. THE SPONSOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
ON THIS. SEEING NONE WE WILL GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. ANYBODY
WANTS TO SPEAK ON SB EIGHT OH
THREE. THING NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY S. ANYONE ONLINE I
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF.
SB EIGHT OH THREE. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR SB
EIGHT ZERO THREE AM IMPRESSED
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE FOUR ZERO
ONE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING PREFERRED KIDDOS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY
IMPORT AT SB. EIGHT ZERO THREE
THANK YOUNG. GOOD LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN ONE ONE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN. YEAH GOOD MORNING- TYLER
RANDY ON BEHALF OF THE AT THE
EIGHT OH THREE CO SPONSORS THE
CALIFORNIA EXPROPRIATION OF
MENTAL HELP YOUR RUN
ORGANIZATION THE LA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS STEINBERG
INSTITUTING COUNTY THEY HAVE OR
HOW PRACTICAL JOKE ASIAN- WE
ARE YOUR STRONG BOB YOUR
SUPPORT ON THE BELT. THANK YOU.
LITTLE AYE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
TWO ZERO ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU CAN SALAS NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
GROWING NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
SIX TWO ZERO SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I CONTACTED CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
IN CONCORD. ONE OR TWO HUNDRED
AND TWO TWO ZERO TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING DANNY
OFFER FROM PLASMA VISORS
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS ALSO
KNOWN AS NAMI CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANKS. GROWING
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND NINETEEN
ONE ONE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WEARING STRONG SUPPORT IN THIS
MEASURE. IT'LL AYE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND TEN TWO ONE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
NOT A VERY COMPLIMENTARY AND
SUPPORTIVE AT THE SEVEN NINE
FIVE EIGHT EIGHT. GROWING
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE ONE EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CARE
MEMBERS ROBERT TERRACE ON
BEHALF ABOUT SIERRA YOU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. GROWING NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIX ONE ZERO SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. KAREN VESSEL
MENTAL HEALTH AND OPTIONS AND
INSURANCE PROJECT IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. GOING NUMBER SIXTY
TWO SIX TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIND SIX WE'RE HEARING OR
THEY'LL GO AHEAD. HOW DO WE
KNOW WHICH NUMBER WE ARE- LOOKS
GOOD SIGNS THE NUMBER TWO IS TO
SPEAK BECAUSE I WANTED TO
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT SENATE BILL
SEVEN NINE FINE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
BEING SENT TO DIFFERENT.
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. I CLOSE CARRY
PLAYERS ARE. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. THE LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN ONE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ADRIAN
SHELTON WITH FOR CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES AND SUPPORT SB EIGHT
ZERO THREE THANK YOU. AND ONE
MOMENT WE HAVE ONE MORE THAT IS.
COMING IN LATE.
THAT WAS
SUPPORT. AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO TWO TWO TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NICOLE WATERMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AWFUL IN
SUPPORT OF THAT THE EIGHT OH
THREE. AND WE HAVE ONE FROM THE
LINE OF ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
TWO ONE EIGHT TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RANDALL HAGER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. DENNIS
ACOSTA QUEUE AT THIS TIME
PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL COME BACK IN HERE IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE. FOR ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM WHO OPPOSES THE BILL.
SEEING NONE AND LET'S GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS OR ANYBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. WILL
POSES THE BILL. SEEING NINE
WILL GO BACK TO THE PHONE.
MODERATORS OR ANYBODY IN THE
QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE
TO QUEUE UP YOU MAY DO SO BY
PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE THAT JUST
HIT UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
BUT
ONE ONE EIGHTY ONE EIGHT ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS DIANE BOARD AND I'M FROM
APPLE VALLEY CALIFORNIA I'M
LOOKING AT THE BILL. FOR EIGHT
ZERO EIGHT SIX ZERO MULLIN
BALLOTS WHEN IS THAT GOING TO
BE ON. NINETY IS UP LATER TODAY
AND THAT IS NOT THE BILL WE'RE
ON NOW. AND. NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT- THERE
WAS NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP FINANCE HAS A DOES
NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL-
SO SHE NOBODY RAISE YOUR HANDS
I DO WANT TO MAKE ONE COMMENT
TO. YOU KNOW MISTER BILL BELL
IS BEEN A LONG CHAMPION AND
THIS PLACE IS GONNA MISS HIS
BIG HEART SELF SEEING THE
OBJECTION SB EIGHT OH THREE.
WILL GO ON SUSPENSE WILL GO TO
MISTER BELLS NEXT BILL SB NINE
TWELVE. WHICH IS ON FOSTER
YOUTH ANOTHER. ISSUE NEAR AND
DEAR TO MISTER BELL- HIS WAY
PRESENTATION AND IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM THAT WANTS
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT SEEING
NONE. ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
TWELVE. SEEING NONE FOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF THAT
THE NINE TWELVE. THANK YOU UP
YOU MAY DO SO BY PRESSING ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED TWO ZERO ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE
MORE THE JUST CORRECT ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. GROWING NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
TWO TWO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
TWO TWO EIGHT OKAY SO AM. I AM
I SUPPOSED TO TALK NOW. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN- OKAY- MY NAME IS
STILL MAY AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CONCERNED
CITIZENS A CALIFORNIA. AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE- CHANGING THE
ELECTION RULES. FOR SATURDAY.
WHAT'S WHICH AB. SIXTY WILL DO
THEM HERE ON THE WRONG BILL
WERE ON A DIFFERENT BILL RIGHT
NOW SO. FOLLOW ALONG THE AGENDA
ONLINE AND ANYBODY ELSE OUT
THERE. THE AGENDA IS POSTED
WITH THE ORDER. AND YOU CAN
FOLLOW. SIXTY SOME ASPECT. I
WAS THE LAST BILL. THE VERY
LAST BILL SO COME BACK IN ABOUT
FIVE HOURS. ALL OF YOU WHO WANT
TO SPEAK ON THAT ELECTIONS BILL
LATE AFTERNOON WE'LL SEE YOU
THEN. HAVE LUNCH ALL RIGHT
MOVING ON. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND SIX
ONE ZERO SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE ZERO SIX CHECK YOUR LINE
FOR MUTE. OUR SPONSOR AND
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
ANYONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM WANTS
TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL. IN
TWENTY FORTY. ANYBODY ONLINE.
ALL RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS
BILL SO WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE MEMBERS NOT
RAISING THEIR HANDS- AGAIN JUST
PROPS TO MISTER BELL AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB. NINE
TWELVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO MISTER GLAZERS
BILLS- SB EIGHT OH ONE HEARS
WAVE PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE. IN THIS ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK ON SB EIGHT OH
ONE- ON BACK UP ELECTRIC
RESOURCES. SEEING NO ONE HERE
IS ANYBODY IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
I WANT TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL.
SEEING NO ONE IN TWENTY FORTY
IS THERE ANYONE IN ONLINE ARE
TO ME ON THE PHONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF SB
EIGHT OH ONE. LIKE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF SB EIGHT OH ONE YOU
MAY DO SO BY PRESSING A ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'RE
GONNA GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE TWO
THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AT METLIFE HAS DROPPED FROM THE
CONFERENCE WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
APOLGIES AND CONNECT ANY
OPPOSITION. GROWING NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN ONE ONE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. AND NO ONE ELSE AND
YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL COME BACK TO THIS ROOM IS
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK. SEEING NONE HAVE
A ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS OR
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NO ONE IN TWENTY FORTY YEARS OR
ANYONE ONLINE ARE ON THE PHONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT A ONE.
THANK SPEAK OUT NOT POSITION ON
SB EIGHT A ONE YOU MAY DO SO BY
PRESSING ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
THAT ARE JUST COMING UP NOW ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. LITTLE AYE
NUMBER SEVENTY ONE SEVEN ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
LARA PAR ON BEHALF OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL THANK YOU. THE LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS NICOLETTA
MANDATE BUT THEN THE OF GAS AND
ELECTRIC AND OPPOSITION AS WELL.
RECENTLY CONDITIONALLY APPROVED
OUR WELFARE MEDICATION
PLANTATION COOK AT THE
EXPANSION OF OUR GENERATOR
GRANT PROGRAM. THANK YOU WILL
AYE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED NINE ONE
ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THE BEING OF
FUNDING FROM THE HALF OF THE
CIVIC AFTER ELECTRIC COMPANY WE
ALSO OPPOSE SB EIGHT OH ONE HAS
THE. IT HAS EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT I THINK
THE LAST PERSON GOT CUT OFF BUT
THEY DIDN'T REGISTER THEIR
OPPOSITION. MEMBERS SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB. EIGHT HOUR LET'S DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE
ON THIS BILL. AND SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB EIGHT A ONE WILL
GO TO. SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO.
MISTER GLAZERS NEXT BILL. SB
TWELVE. THIRTY TWO HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
SEEING NO RUSH TO THE
MICROPHONE WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. ANYONE THERE DOES
NOT LOOK LIKE ANYONE'S THERE.
WE WILL GO ON TO THE PHONE TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE
QUEUE THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. OF SB TWELVE THIRTY
TWO ON CAL WORKS POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. IF YOU LIKE TO VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THE CURRENT BILLING
WE DO SO BY PRESSING ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE ONE
THAT JUST HIT UP ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. READING A LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR TWO
FOUR FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU. I'M IN OPPOSITION TO
AB EIGHT SIX ZERO. THANK YOU.
NO ONE ELSE AND YOU AT THIS
TIME SIR. ALL RIGHT ANYBODY IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION OF TWELVE THIRTY TWO.
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY IN
OPPOSITION AT TWELVE THIRTY TWO.
ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
IF YOUR OPPOSITION TO BILL ALL
THREE TO ONLY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
ONE IT'S FROM LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE EIGHT
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. OUR NO
ONE ELSE IN HERE AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT THAT IS OUR TWELVE
THIRTY TWO- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL SO WE'LL BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK ANYBODY HAVE A
QUESTION COMMENT SAYING NO RUSH
TO HANDS- WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWELVE THIRTY TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE BY MR GLAZER ON
PROPERTY TAXATION IN THE SAT
AND DISASTER RELIEF FOR ANYONE
IN THIS ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK ON TWELVE. THIRTY ONE.
SEEING NOBODY RUSHED TO THE
MICROPHONE WILL MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. AGAIN NO THRONG
OF PEOPLE RUSHING TO THE
MICROPHONE. WE WILL GO ON TO
OUR PHONE SYSTEM IS OR ANYONE
IN SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN THIRTY
ONE. LIKE TO VOICE SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN ONE
FIVE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BY ONE FIFTY SEVEN CHECK YOUR
LINE FOR MUTE. HEARING NO
RESPONSE WILL HOLD ON THE LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
ONE EIGHT ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES WELL THERE WAS THIS.
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE. PROPERTY
TAX. YEAH. TO RAISE THE
PROPERTY TAX- TO GET RID OF.
THIRTEEN WHAT IS THIS ONE. HAVE
A GREAT DAY THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. LITTLE AYE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE ONE ONE TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JACKIE-
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION COUNTY- IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
PRESIDENT OF THAT. EARLY IT HAD
EXTREME PHYSICAL AFFECTS BOTH
FOR THE STATE AND OR LOCAL
AGENCIES- AND IN DOING SO-
LIKELY NOT. EVEN ACCOMPLISH ITS
GOALS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU NEXT. NO ONE ELSE IN
Q. AT THIS TIME. WE'RE GONNA GO
TO OPPOSITION IN THIS ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE ANYBODY IN
HERE OPPOSED. SEEING NONE HAVE
A TWENTY FORTY. ANYBODY OPPOSED.
WE'LL GO ON THE PHONE LINE SO
ANYBODY ON LINE THAT WANTS TO
OPPOSE SB FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE.
YOU MAY DO SO AT THIS TIME AYE
PRESSING ONE AND ZERO WE'LL GO
TO LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN ONE THREE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
MORNING ELIZABETH ASK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS AND
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU. A GROWING NUMBER TWENTY
NINE TO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO TRÊN NUMBERS CATALINA
DANCE AS THE CARPETING KAISER
WITH THE TAX REFORM EVEN
CALTRAIN TAX REFORM ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THE
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE ONE TWO FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JEAN HEARST
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVE. CALIFORNIA ALSO
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. BUT A
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED NINETY
NINE ONE NINE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS TEAR OFF ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF BURBANK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU. BUT A
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY ONE TWO FOUR ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MORNING SHARING
MEMBERS HELLO WITH CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
ALIGNING OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
COUNTY IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
WE HAVE ONE MORE THAT JUST CUED
UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND
BERMAN. LITTLE LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO TO FOUR
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
TOM LOWER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE AT FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE ONE MORE FROM LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE
EIGHT ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OPPOSITION AS WELL. NO MORE IN
Q. AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT- THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL SO
WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SEEING NO RUSH OF
HANDS GO UP. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE WE'LL GO
TO SUSPENSE. BAKER THE BILL
NEXT SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR-
PRESENTATIONS BEEN WAIVED THIS
IS. A BE IN P. COMMITTEE BILL-
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT.
OF SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR.
SEEING NOBODY COME UP ANYBODY
IN TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NO ONE THERE ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE. IN SUPPORT OF THIS
COMMITTEE BELL. YOU MAY VOICE
YOUR SUPPORT BY PRESSING ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE'S
NO ONE QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO BACK INTO
THIS ROOM ANY OPPOSITION.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR. SEEING
NINE ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IN OPPOSITION OF FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR. ANYONE ON THE
PHONE. IN A ONE OF THE OWNERS
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE ONE THAT JUST CUED UP ONE
MOMENT. I HAVE A NAME PLEASE.
HELLO I NEED YOUR NAME FOR THE
QUESTION. THEN YOU'RE IN THE
MAIN. COLLEGES AS ONE OF OUR
OPERATORS IN THE WRONG PLACE
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE TWO
FIVE THREE YEAR LINE IS OPEN.
BUT I AM MY NAME IS MERRY
STICKER ON THE M. FROM SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHT. SIXTY WRONG WILL
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT ANYONE
ELSE. WE HAVE ONE THAT'S WITH
AN OPERATOR GETTING THE LINE
NUMBER IT LOOKS LIKE IT IS LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO TO FIVE TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BOB GALE
COST ME AND I'M IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU NO ONE ELSE INTO IT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL I SEE
NO HANDS GO UP FROM THE
COMMITTEE WITHOUT OBJECTION- SB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR WILL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE. TEN BILLS IN AN
HOUR. IT'S A GREAT RATE. ALL
RIGHT. CAUCUS HAS BEN MOVED
BACK TO TWELVE THIRTY AND SO WE
MAY BE ABLE TO GET IN SOME
BILLS DEPENDING ON HOW LONG ARE
A GERMAN AT ELEVEN O'CLOCK- SO
WE'LL STAY FLUID ON THAT
EVERYBODY MOVING ON TO MY THREE
BILLS- WHICH I WAY PRESENTATION
SB EIGHT OH FIVE IS THE FIRST
ONE UP. ON SCHOOL EMPLOYEES IS
THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT. ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IN SUPPORT. ANYONE ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT. YOU LIKE TO
VOICE SUPPORT IN LINES PLEASE
PRESS ONE AT THIS TIME. THERE'S
NO ONE SHOWING UP AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WILL COME BACK TO
THIS ROOM FOR OPPOSITION. FOR
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM. SEEING
NONE ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NONE ANYONE ON THE LINE.
ONE ON ONE AND GEHRY AS WELL.
MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN ONE THREE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU.
ONE THREE SEVEN I DON'T BELIEVE
THEY HEARD YOUR RESPONSE PLEASE
RE RE STATE. MAY HAVE DROPPED
OFF I APOLOGIZE. ALL RIGHT WITH
THIS TIME. WITH IT SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. IS THAT SUPPORT.
RIGHT OPPOSITION IN THIS ROOM
SEEING NONE AND TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NONE ONLINE. ONE OF
THOSE STATE OH FIVE JUST.
SEEING NONE RIGHT. IT IS SEVEN
A OKAY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAS COMMENTS ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
BILL AT THIS TIME I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT THE BILL COULD CREATE
A REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE.
WITH COSTS IN THE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OR MORE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND COSTS WOULD BE
DEPENDENT ON THE OCCURRENCE OF
THE SPECIFIED BACKED REDUCTION
OR EMERGENCY AT THE NET OF
AFFECTED EMPLOYEES AND THE
EVENT OF FOR CONTEXT AND AS AN
EXAMPLE. IF 1% OF CERTIFICATED
AND CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES BECAME
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROPOSED PAID
LEAVE FOR TWENTY SCHOOL DAYS
ACOSTA COULD RANGE BETWEEN
FORTY FOUR MILLION TO FIFTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SEEING NINE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB EIGHT OH FIVE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. SB NINE
FOURTEEN I'M WAVING
PRESENTATIONS AS WELL ON
FIREARMS. WHEN A THE THREE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN. OF
BEING PAYING FOURTEEN. SEEING
NINE ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SEEING NONE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
FOURTEEN. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
FORTY SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE ONE IN THE QUEUE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WHY NUMBER FORTY
SIX FOUR SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES THIS IS ROY GRODIN SPEAKING
ON THE AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
RIGHT ON COASTAL POLLUTION AND
THE NRA WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT.
ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED.
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED.
ANYONE ELSE ONLINE OPPOSED.
SCENE NINE WE WILL COME BACK TO
PARTNER FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A
FILE ANYBODY FROM THIS
COMMITTEE WANT TO SAY ANYTHING.
SEEING NO HANDS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB NINE FOURTEEN WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING TEST BE
TWELVE NINETY NINE ON HOUSING.
AND I'M WAVING PRESENTATION IS
THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT. ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY
AND SUPPORT. ANYONE ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT. THE POOR IN A
PRESS ONE AND ZERO IF YOU LIKE
TO VOICE SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
LITTLE LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND NINETY NINE ONE NINE NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE
HUNDRED NINETY NINE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. DURING A RESPONSIBLE
THE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO TO SIX TO HELP PAY
FOR MOVE THEMSELVES FROM THE
QUEUE NEVER MIND ONE MOMENT.
LITTLE ONE ON ONE MOMENT
WAITING FOR A LINE NUMBER.
WE'LL GO BACK TO LINE ONE
NINETY NINE ONE NINE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE NINETY NINE
WE STILL CAN'T HEAR YOU. RIGHT
LITTLE LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY ONE EIGHT ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES I'M IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU WILL GET A LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE TWO FIVE
NINE YOUR LINES OPEN. GOOD
MORNING DIRECTLY FROM LA COUNTY
BUSINESS FEDERATION SB TOLD
NINE AS A GREAT ECONOMIC
RECOVERY PACKAGE AND WEIRD FULL
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THIS ROOM TO
TWELVE NINETY NINE. SO ANY
OPPOSITION IN TWENTY FORTY. TO
TWELVE NINETY NINE. IS THERE
ANYONE ONLINE IN OPPOSITION OF
TWELVE NINETY NINE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THE LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETY NINE ONCE MORE ONE NINE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIND
ONE NINETY NINE YOU KEEP
QUEUING UP BUT WE'RE NOT
HEARING ANY AUDIO ON YOUR AND
YOU MUST BE SELF MUTED. THAT'S
THE ONE NINE. AND NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS THAT
OF A FILE ON THIS BILL. SEEING
NO RUSH OF HANDS GO UP FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWELVE NINETY NINE. WILL GO TO
SUSPEND STARTER PANS BILLS NEXT
AB EIGHT FIFTY TWO. HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION IT'S ON HEALTHCARE
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO. SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANYONE IN TWENTY
FORTY. IT'S SUPPORT OF FIFTY SB
EIGHT FIFTY TWO. ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OF SB. EIGHT
FIFTY TWO. DOES NOT SOUND LIKE
IT MISTER MODERATOR. SOMEONE
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WILL GO THE OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE IN OPPOSITION. STE NINE
IS THERE ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY
IN OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION EIGHT FIFTY TWO.
MISTER MODERATOR. ONE NINE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. NO ONE SHOWING UP
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES
NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL-
SEEING NOBODY WITH THEIR HAND
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB EIGHT
FIFTY TWO BY DR PAN WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE. WE WILL MOVE TO OUR
HOLD ON ONE SECOND. WILL MOVE
TO OUR NEXT AUTHOR MISTER
WEINER WHO I SAW. HE HAS. HE
HAS A FEW. HE HAS A FEW EASE
WAVING PRESENTATION. IS WAVING
PRESENTATION ON. EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE. AS WITH PRESENTATIONS AS
ANYBODY HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT WE HAVE THE YOU'RE HERE
FOR A FIFTY FIVE ALL RIGHT I
WILL START THE CLOCK. ALL RIGHT
IN HERE IN OPPOSITION SB EIGHT
SIXTY OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT.
GETTING ARE YOU IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION I'M IN THE I'M IN
SUPPORT MISTER CHAIR SORRY BAD
JOKE ALL RIGHT START AGAIN OKAY.
CHOOSE NOT A REPRESENTING THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE- WE'RE
PLEASED BECAUSE SPONSORING SB
FIFTY FIVE- AS ONE OF ONLY TWO
SENATE MENTAL HEALTH BILLS IN%
FRONT OF YOUR COMMITTEE SENATOR
WINNERS BILLS AND INTERNAL
COMPONENT OF YOUR- APPROACH. TO
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
THE ANTICIPATED RISE IN
SUICIDES AND FATAL OVERDOSES AS
A RESULT OF THE ECONOMIC
FALLOUT OKAY- SB EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE ACCOMPLISHES A SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT IN CARE. FOR A
MINUSCULE PREMIUM INCREASE OF
TWO ONE THOUSANDTHS OF ONE
PERCENT. DOES THE ANALYSIS
OUTLINES THERE'S ALSO NO
GENERAL FUND IMPACT OF THE BILL
OF THE REGULATORY COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE FIRST YEAR WE'LL
BE COVERED COMPLETELY BLACK. BY
SORRY FEES ON PLANS AND WITH
FIFTY FIVE PLANS IN THE STATE
THAT'S EIGHT THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER PLAY ON.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY SMALL
PRICE TO PAY FOR ACHIEVING.
READY FOR MEN HEALTH IN SO USE
SORT. AND WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU I UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE A CO HOST ON THE LINE. OUR
CO SPONSOR ON THE LINE WHO
WANTS TO FILL OUT THE-
ADVOCATE. FORUM. MODERATOR YOU
COULD HEAR MORE THANK YOU
QUALITY FELLOW THE CAN FORM
APPROACH ON JUNE THE BILL THE
CALIFORNIA COULD BE WORSENING
MENTAL HEALTH ADDICTION MORE OF
KOBE THE THAT WE NEED MENTAL
AND SO USE SURVEY LOSING IT
AGAIN AS GREAT THAT PEOPLE AND
SHE ACROSS COVER FOR MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS LITTLE AND LONG TERM
FEEDING TO THE STATE FOR. AND
OF A LARGE INDUSTRY CROTCH
ACROSS THIRTEEN KIND IN
CALIFORNIA FOUND THAT FOR EVERY
DOLLAR SPENT ON EACH TREATMENT
THERE WERE SOME DOLLARS A MONTH
BUT. NORMA PUBLIC THANK COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH ENTRY OF
SUBSTANCE USE AND LOCAL ONLY
INCLUDING HOMELESSNESS
DISABILITY AND HARDSHIP
FUNCTION BUT ACCOUNT OTHER
PUBLIC PROGRAM. EIGHTY FIVE IS
A BOLD APPROACH THE CALIFORNIA
NEEDS WE HAVE GOING ON SECOND
AND REALLY IT BECAUSE I'M LIKE
A MENTAL HEALTH AND ADDICTION.
QUE FORM IS A STRONG ARE
SUPPORTER. AB POSSIBLE OFF THAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
WILL COME TO THE ROOM IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WE GO TO TWENTY
FORTY IS THERE ANYBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY OF SUPPORT. SHE
NINE WILL GO TO THE PHONES IS
THERE ANYONE- CUED UP IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. SB EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE. IF YOU'D LIKE YOU UP IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT FIFTY FIVE
YOU MAY DO SO AT THIS TIME BY
PRESSING ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
WILL BEGIN AT THE LINE OF TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX TO
SEVEN SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JERRY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND QUIRK.
WHAT DO I NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND TWO TWO ZERO TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. DANNY OFFERS FROM
FLATMAN VISORS REPRESENTING THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS NAMI CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. OKAY ONE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SEVEN TWO FIVE SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOU WILL COME BACK
SAYING IN A DOUGLAS ON BEHALF
OF HEALTH ACT OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORTED SB THIRTY FIVE.
TWENTY ONE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE TWO THREE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OUR
STORES ARE STRATEGIES CREE
SIXTY ON THE APPLE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. OUR
LITTLE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SIX TWO FIVE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS JIM LIMBURG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION THAT CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU A LITTLE AYE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
TWO SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MICHAEL SOTO WITH THE
NATIONAL UNION OF HEALTHCARE
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. FIRST I THANK YOU AND IF
YOU'RE A REMINDER FOR THOSE
THAT ARE CLOSE ON THE CALL
PLEASE MEET YOUR LINES WERE NOT
SPEAKING WE ARE HEARING SOME
ECHO FEEDBACK FROM ONE OF YOUR
LINES. WILL GET A LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED TWO ZERO ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WHAT BACKING
GONZALEZ NOW SELECT THE STATION
ACOSTA WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. MY NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
TO SEVEN H. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ADRIAN SO PLAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
FAMILY SERVICES AND SUPPORT
THANKS. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE ONE TWO FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TING HERS HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND SIX TWO
ZERO SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
COMSTOCK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ATION OF LOCAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS IN SUPPORT. LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO ONE
EIGHT TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RANDALL HAGER HERE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY TO THREE
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JOHN RAN
OVER ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPRESSION BIPOLAR SUPPORT
ALLIANCE IN CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN TWO
EIGHT SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HEARING NO
RESPONSE FOR THE LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE
TWO EIGHT THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND THEN THE LADY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETEEN
ONE ONE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. CAROLINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE EIGHT
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE
ONE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DURING A RESPONSE LITTLE LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE ONE EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MAN
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ROBERT
HARRIS ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY THE DICTION MEDICINE IN
SUPPORT. ALSO ON BEHALF BASS
YEAH YOU CALIFORNIANS COURT
THANK YOU. AND THAT DOES
EXHAUSTED Q. AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT WILL COME BACK TO THIS
ROOM IS EARNING MONEY IN
OPPOSITION. DATE FIFTY FIVE
SEEING NONE ANYBODY IN TWENTY
FORTY. IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE ANYONE ON THE PHONE AND
OPPOSITION. ONE AND ZERO TO
VOICE OPPOSITION. A LINE NUMBER
TWO OR- NINE NINE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI ELLIE THEY ARE
DO WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. SELECT COLOR TO THE
PARTY THERE'S NO OPPOSITION IN
Q. AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL SO
WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. SIGNAL HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SB EIGHT EIGHT TWO.
MR WINNERS AWAY PRESENTATION-
IS OR ANYONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT EIGHT TWO
WE ARE CAO FRESH. SHE NOBODY
HERE ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
FOR SEEING NO ONE IN TWENTY
FORTY IS THERE ANYONE ONLINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT EIGHT TWO.
LIKE TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR SB
EIGHTY TWO YOU MAY DO SO BY
PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GET A LINE NUMBER
THREE HUNDRED THREE ZERO ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE THREE
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NO
AUDIO RESPONSE ON THE LINE IT
WAS THE ONLY ONE IN Q. ALRIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK TO THIS ROOM
FOR OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION. OF EIGHT EIGHT
TWO SEEING NO ONE HERE ANYBODY
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE THERE ATTORNEY
ONE ONLINE IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHT EIGHT TWO OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY TWO AND WISH TO MAKE
THEIR OPPOSITION KNOWN YOU MAY
DO SO BY PRESSING A ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS
BILL SO WILL NOW COME BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS SEEING
NON. WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHT
INTO. WILL GO TO SUSPENSE OR
MOVING ON SB EIGHT. NINE NINE.
ON PLANNING AND ZONING HOUSING-
MISTER WIENER- WAY PRESENTATION
IS THERE ANYONE IN FORTY TWO.
OH THREE WHO IS HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. SEEING NONE ANYBODY
TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NINE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO VOICE SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE LINES YOU MAY DO SO AT
THIS TIME BY PRESSING ONE AND
THEN ZERO. WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
THAT ARE QUEUING UP PLEASE
ALLOW MOMENT. BURGER LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ONE ONE FIVE ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE BOND MARKET DRIVERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY
PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT. LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY
ONE LINE TO NINE ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE MORNING HEARING
MEMBERS DOESN'T MATTER NOT LIKE
HOW PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING GRANT
THE COURT AND HOW IT HAPPENED.
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIANS. AND
THE GREEN BEAN- COALITION WHICH
INCLUDES GNG PARTNER YEAH HOME
IN BURKE AND THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION THANK YOU.
THE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY ONE TWO SIX ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WITH THE BAY AREA
HOUSING ADVOCATES THE COALITION
IMPORT THANK. GROWING NUMBER
THIRTY THREE THREE THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STILL BE- FOR
OUR IN BEHALF OF FACEBOOK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I HAVE ONE
MORE THE JUST CUED UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE A LITTLE AYE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FOUR TO EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ALL RIGHT IF YOU MIGHT
ONLY THE DAIRY COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT SB EIGHT NINE NINE. AND
NOT EXHAUSTED YOU AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT- THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OF I WAS SUPPORT- LET'S
GO BACK TO THIS ROOM ANY
OPPOSITION. EIGHT NINE NINE
SEEING NONE TWENTY FORTY. ANY
OPPOSITION SEEING NINE ANYONE
ONLINE MOVED TO OUR PHONE LINE
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION DATE
NINE NINE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL YOU FOR EIGHT NINE NINE
YOU MAY QUEUE UP BY PRESSING
ONE AND ZERO. THE MOMENT WE DO
HAVE ONE THAT JUST YOU'RE NOT.
AND ONE MOMENT WE'RE GOING TO
LINE NUMBER FORTY NINE FOUR
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH. THE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES WE'RE OPPOSED TODAY BUT
HAVE ENGAGED WITH AND
CONVERSATIONS LISTENER WINNER
AND STAFF LOOK FORWARD TO
HOPEFULLY MANY THE BILL TO
ENSURE THAT CAN WORKERS ON
THESE PROJECTS FROM THE
PREVAILING WAGE AT THE USE OF
THE SCOPE AND TRAIN WORKFORCE
IS UTILIZED TO BUILD THESE
PROJECTS. THANK YOU. AND WE
JUST GOT ONE MORE THAT JUST
CURA ONE MOMENT PLANS. HELLO I
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
ONE EIGHT ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IN OPPOSITION. GROWING
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FIVE TWO EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES GOOD MEETING.
PEOPLE HELPFUL. FIND YOUR WAY
IS OPEN HELLO THIS IS ANNA
WITHOUT AND I LIVE IN SAM
FRANCISCO AND I AM OPPOSED TO
AND BE. EIGHT NINETY NINE. AND
THERE IS NO MORE IN THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE NO HANDS
UP SO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
EIGHT NINE NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. GOING ON SB NINE OUT
TO. FATHER HAS WAY PRESENTATION
OF TO HOUSING BILL SURE ANYONE
IN FORTY TWO OH THREE THAT IS
HERE TO SUPPORT SB NINE OH TWO.
SEEING NONE ANYONE IN TWENTY
FORTY. SEEING NONE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
ISSUE SUPPORT FOR NOW SB NINE
OH TWO YOU MAY DO SO AT THIS
TIME BY PRESSING ONE AND THEN
ZERO WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE TWO
SIX ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EVEN
THOUGH IT THE BAY AREA HOUSING
ADVOCACY COALITION IN SUPPORT
THANKS. WE'RE LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX TWO NINE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS IS
BOB NAIL REPRESENTING SHIELDS
SEVEN COMPANY AN ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS STRONGLY SUPPORT OF
CALIFORNIA U. M. B. AND S. B.
NINE OH TWO. HELLO I NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY ONE LINE TO
NINE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING TERRY MEMBERS SAYS
THEY'RE NOT A NOT LIKE HEALTH
PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
HEARING BE. ALL THE THREE KEYS
COLLECTION INTO COURT THANK YOU.
WELL I NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE TWO THREE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ALLOSAURUS BUT
STRATEGY THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF
OF UPPER BROKE BACK TO
CALIFORNIA AND TRANSPORT THANK
YOU. LITTLE AYE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE ONE
NINE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE ONE NINETY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. DURING THE AUDIO
RESPONSE LITTLE LINE NUMBER
FIFTY NINE FIVE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE FIFTY NINE CHECK
FOR SELF MUTE PLEASE. ONLY
BACKGROUND NOISE HEARD AT THIS
TIME LINE THIRTY THREE THREE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING- MEMBERS SILVIO FERRARI
IN BEHALF OF FACEBOOK IN
SUPPORT. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE TWO EIGHT FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. YOU CAN CIRCLE BACK
I WILL GO TO LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FOUR TO EIGHT FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY FOR YOUR OPEN.
AND LOOKS LIKE A FOR MOVE
THEMSELVES FROM THE QUEUE
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE INTO IT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WILL COME
BACK TO THIS ROOM IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE OH TWO.
SEEING NONE WE GOT A ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IS ARE ANY
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE.
OPPOSED TO SB NINE OH TWO. YOUR
PA SB NINE OH TO YOU MAKE YOU
UP BY PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME WHAT A LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE TWO
EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TWO EIGHT FIVE. HELLO. CIRCLE
BACK. OKAY WELL THE LINEUP FOR
NINE FOUR NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE CARE
MEANS THAT YOU'RE ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL. I
WOULD JUST AS BUDGET MYSELF BUT
THE COMMENT I MADE WITH SB I
DON'T TO. THIS RECIPE EIGHT
NINE NINE OR SB NINE ABUSE WELL
THANK YOU. WOULD LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE EIGHT
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
EIGHT ZERO ONCE AGAIN WE CANNOT
HEAR YOU WE BELIEVE YOU TO BE
SELF MUTED YOU'RE KIDDING
PREVIOUSLY WE HAVE HEARD NO
AUDIO. WE'LL GO BACK TO LINE
TWO HUNDRED NINETY FOUR TWO
NINE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
DAVE CONOR ON BEHALF OF A
BETTER WAY TO HOW CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. CAROLINE TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR TO
EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE ONE MOMENT
THEY REMOVE THEMSELVES FROM THE
QUEUE WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
FIFTEEN ONE FIVE YOUR LINES
OPEN. MY NAME IS GWEN WIRES I
LIVE IN ROSEVILLE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED THIS BILL.
THANK YOU WILL GET A LINE
NUMBERS THREE HUNDRED ELEVEN
THREE ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MIKE WESTRA PRESENTING
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES. YEAH BECAUSE
THE SENTIMENT OF THE BUILDING
TRADES HUMBLE EIGHT NINETY NINE
AND I KNOW TO THANK YOU. WELL I
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR
TO EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE TWO EIGHT FOUR RESTORE
CANNOT HEAR YOU. RIGHT. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. NINE TWO EIGHT
FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN AGAIN
PLEASE REITERATE. HI FI MY WITH
GARY COUNSEL AND THE COURT AT
THE NINE OH TWO. IT WILL CUT
THE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE TWO EIGHT FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO HELLO MA'AM
YOUR LINE OPEN GO AHEAD AND I
DALY OF ANNAPOLIS FROM SAN
FRANCISCO OPPOSED TO SB. NINE
OH TWO. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY TWO TO EIGHT TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES STILL QUALITY
SOME SAN GABRIEL VALLEY- I'M
OPPOSED TO BILL. NOT AT. THANK
YOU WILL AYE NUMBER SIXTY TWO
SIX TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE
SIXTY TO CHECK YOUR LINE FOR
MEAT STATUS. NO RESPONSE WILL
GO BACK TO LINE ONE EIGHTY ONE
MORE TIME WE HAVEN'T HAD MUCH
LUCK WITH THAT LINE PREVIOUSLY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE ONE
EIGHTY. YEAH I'M SORRY I WAS
STILL TRYING TO GET THE DETAILS
OF THIS BILL AND- IN OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL. THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. AT THIS TIME. ALL.
SORRY CHAIRPERSON NOT SURE IF
YOU HEARD ME THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE
WILL COME BACK TO FINANCE DOES
NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL.
COMMITTEE SIGNAL WAS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB NINE OH
TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING
ON TO SB NINE THIRTY TO. FIVE
MISTER WINNER AS WELL- HE HAS
WAVE PRESENTATION. ON THAT BILL
AND IS THERE ANYONE IN THIS
ROOM. WHO WANTS TO SPEAK. ON
THE SB NINE THIRTY TWO DATA
COLLECTION SEEING NO ONE HERE.
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY. SEE NO
ONE IN TWENTY FORTY ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF NINE
THIRTY TO. IF YOU WISH TO VOICE
SUPPORT FOR SB NINE THIRTY TWO
YOU MAY DO SO AT THIS TIME BY
PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO. WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SIX LINE TWO SEVEN
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. STE ANNE
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ON THEIR OF
THE BILL AND JOHN THE COURT. NO
ONE ELSE ON THE AUDIO LINES AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WILL COME
BACK TO THIS RARE BOOK.
OPPOSITION ANYBODY IN FORTY TWO
OR THREE IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY.
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE. YOU'RE
NOT POSITION SB NINE THIRTY TWO
YOUR MAKE YOU UP BY PRESSING
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. NOT
IN OPPOSITION. BUT. MICHAEL
MARTINEZ FROM THE HOUSE OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
EIGHT NINE THREE TWO THANK YOU.
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THE
AUDIO LINES ALL RIGHT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NOT OF
A FILE ON THIS BILL. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM OUR
COMMITTEE SB NINE THIRTY TO. GO
TO SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WE WILL BE MOVING ON TO SB NINE
THIRTY NINE WHICH IS A-
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND THE
OFFICER WHO IS PRESENTING
ANOTHER BILL TODAY- IS GOING TO
BE PRESENTING THIS HOPEFULLY
FOCUSING ON THE FISCAL IMPACTS.
ONLY SO MISTER WINNER TELL US
ABOUT NINE THIRTY NINE FISCAL
IMPACTS ABSOLUTELY AND THANK
YOUR CALLING THE FISCAL IMPACTS
ARE EXT EXCEPTIONALLY SMALL ON
THIS ON THIS BILL- AND- I WAS
JUST PUT THAT THERE I WANT TO
THANK MY JOINT AUTHORED PARTNER
IN THIS BILL CENTER LINK IS ALL
I WANT TO THIS BILL IS A BILL-
THAT WILL- FRANKLY. IMPROVE THE
FINANCES OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- BY AVOIDING A MASS
EXTINCTION EVENT OF SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE WE'VE A MASSIVE
NUMBER OF SMALL BUSINESSES-
THAT- OR RISK OF NEVER COMING
BACK WHICH WILL. AND THERE ARE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN ADDITION
TO UNDERMINE NEIGHBORHOODS BY
CAUSING MASS- VACANCIES. START
WITH THIS IS THE ONLY SMALL
BUSINESS EVICTION PROTECTION
BILL THAT WE'RE AWARE OF THAT
IS PENDING IN THE LEGISLATURE-
SO THIS BILL DOES NOT MOVE
FORWARD RUN A WORK ANY- BILL
THAT WILL ADDRESS THIS VERY
VERY. SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM. OUR
CALIFORNIA- WE ARE ACTIVELY
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS AT
ALL WHO WOULD BILLS EVERY HAS
BEEN ON A SHORT TIME FRAME- WE
HAVEN'T HAD SIX MONTHS- WOULD
WITH OTHER BILLS. BUT WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING INTENSIVELY WITH
STAKEHOLDER CLUED IN THE
OPPOSITE TURN UP AND DOWN THE
STATE- CONSULTANT DANIEL. TIME
ON. OPPONENTS TO GET. WE WILL
BE FOR THIS COMMITTEE WITH. AND
I'M AND- THE BILL INCLUDING.
THE LEASE TERM PROVISION WITH
ANOTHER PROVISION THAT IS
SOFTER BUT WILL STILL CREATE
INCENTIVES FOR LANDLORDS TO
RENEGOTIATE LEASE. WITH
HOSPITALITY BUSINESSES WHOSE
CAPACITY HAS BEEN SLASHED BY
THE GOVERNMENT AND YET THEY'RE
STILL EXPECTED TO PAY THE FULL
RENT BEEN NEGOTIATED- YEARS AGO
SO WE'VE TAKEN OUT FEEDBACK
INTO ACCOUNT OR MAKING NOT
CHANGED. THE BILL WILL BE
FOCUSED COLUSA BELIEVE ON SMALL
BUSINESSES- IN ADDITION FOR THE
COMMERCIAL FICTION MORATORIUM-
THE TENANTS WILL BE EXPECTED TO
PAY AT LEAST 25% OF THE RENT
THIS ISN'T ABOUT PEOPLE NOT
PAYING ANY RENT AT ALL. HELLO
THIS IS TO HAVE AN ONLINE. TO
GET THROUGH THE BE ABLE TO BUY.
AN ALTERNATE. REPAY THEIR
BACKGROUND IN ADDITION WE'RE-
THE TIME FRAME OF THE
COMMERCIAL FICTION- MORATORIUM-
SO THAT IT IS SHORTER AND MORE
CONDENSE SO OUR WORK HAS BEEN
TO MAKE THIS A TRULY. FOCUSED
TARGETED BILL TO HELP OUR
SMALLEST CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES
HANG ON BY THEIR FINGERNAILS
WITH THE HOPE OF SURVIVING- AND
THEN TO BE ABLE TO GET BACK UP
ON THEIR FEET I WANT TO SAY
THAT MANY MANY COMMERCIAL AND-
ARE WORKING WITH OUR TENANTS TO
RENEGOTIATE LEASES. BUT
TRAGICALLY MANY ARE NOT AND WE
HAVE HORROR STORIES FROM THE
SMALL BUSINESSES WHO ARE BEING
TOLD BY THEIR LANDLORDS ARE NOT
GETTING A RENT REDUCTION. HALEY
IF YOU'RE LATE OTHERWISE GET
OUT THAT IS NOT THE RIGHT
APPROACH FOR THIS UNIQUE
PANDEMIC THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING OR FOR OUR
ECONOMY- AND- IF THIS COMES OFF
SUSPENSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A COUPLE OF YOUR PRIMARY-
SPOKES PEOPLE I BELIEVE ARE
CUED UP- IS MORTON- AND- I MISS
FISH SO I HOPE THEY'RE CUED UP
TO BE YOUR PRIMARY WITNESSES
AND HOPEFULLY THEY CAN CAN FIND
THEIR COMMENTS TO A THREE
MINUTE TOTAL. THIS AN ON FISCAL
EXACTLY MISS BORTON. WHAT
MESSAGE IS FISH OKAY HI. THE
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS EIGHT
YEARS AGO I STARTED A SMALL
RESTAURANT COMPANY CALLED
NATIVE HOW WITH MY FRIEND AND
BUSINESS PARTNER KAITLYN NEED
TODAY I WILL READ A JOINT
STATEMENT ON OUR BEHALF THE
BOARD AT THE NINETY NINE. IN A
FEW SHORT MONTHS OUR BUSINESS
ALONG SO MANY OTHERS HAVE
CRUMBLED. STARTING IN EARLY
FEBRUARY WE RECOGNIZE THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT OF COMING
NINETEEN AND THAT EVERY MEASURE
TO PREPARE FOR THE IMPORTANCIA
HAD. I ARE QUITE CATCH YOUR
THIRDS AND THEREFORE HAVING
PETER THELSTAN. FOR THE
PANDEMIC OUR BUSINESS BUT THE
THOUGHT WILL BE AVERAGE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND MONTHLY
REVENUE BUT SHE MADE 325%
PROFIT. LAST MONTH YOUR SHELTER
IN PLACE OUR REVENUES WERE
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND. THAT IS
THE COMBINED COMBINED CAUGHT
THERE ARE A RENT FOR TWO
DECADES OF THE LOCATION AND
WRITE THEM RIGHT RELIEF DURING
A PANDEMIC IS CRITICAL TO OUR
SURVIVAL. IT NOT ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE WITH ONE OF OUR LAND
LORD. NEWMAN THE FIELD IN TERMS
IN GOOD FAITH ASKING ONLY
REDUCTION IN RENT BASED ON BAD
NEWS THAT WE BELIEVE IT. THE
PARTY IS. OTHER TODAY THE
LANDLORD HAS ONLY BEEN WILLING
DO THAT ARE RENT BERMAN. WE
WERE TO RECEIVE A NO FROM HER
AT AMP LATE. APRIL MAY JUNE RAN
AND ALSO A REMINDER OF THEIR
RIGHT BEGIN LEGAL AGAINST THAT
AT THE EARLIEST CONVENIENCE. WE
ARE CRITICAL GUARANTORS
HONESTLY BUT THIS LANDLORD IS
NOT IDENTIFIED NEGOTIATE WITH
US. AND WE CAN AFFORD RENT. A
COMMERCIAL ELECTION OR THAT THE
CLOTHES BOTH LOCATION AND FILED
FOR PERSONAL BANKRUPTCY. WE
SUPPORTED NOT ONLY BECAUSE
IT'LL HELP OUR BUSINESS BUT
BECAUSE IT'LL HAVE A POSITIVE
FISCAL IMPACT ON OUR ECONOMY.
PIT IS AN ARIA. ONE WHEN OUR
NEGOTIATE WITH THEIR CANNONS
AND COME TO AN AGREEMENT THAT
AFFORD THE TENANT THE ABILITY
TO KEEP OPERATING THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC. SHORT TERM IMPACT ON
REVENUE FOR BOTH PARTIES WILL
BE WELL WORTH THE LONG TERM
PROSPERITY OF OUR ECONOMY. AND
TO NONE OF YOU KNOW
NEGOTIATIONS I REQUEST SMALL
BUSINESSES CAN'T AFFORD PRETEND
TO MAKE RENT AND WE WILL BE
FORCED TO CLOSE. ALL THE
MAPPING OF THESE WITHOUT SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE OLD. THE COURT
WILL BE FLOODED WITH BANKRUPTCY
IS. UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS WELL
BECOME HER. AND IF IN THIS
ISSUE. BOB L<C.CYAN>G. IN OUR- WILL</C>
SUFFER THEM DAM. IF WE HAVE
THAT THE NINE THREE NINE THAT
CAN BE AVOIDED. OUR GOAL IS TO
MINIMIZE THE FISCAL IMPACT
ACROSS INDUSTRIES THAT WE ARE
ALL IN A BETTER POSITION TO
REBUILD COMING OUT OF THAT.
PLANET WILL BE INCENTIVIZE THE
WORK WITH THEIR- FOUR HUNDRED
NINE. HAD THE SUCCESSFUL AGAIN.
EXTREMELY PROUD OF THE BUSINESS
THE BILL WE WANT NOTHING MORE
THAN TO CONTINUE OUR EMPLOYEES
AND CONTRIBUTING FOR EXAMPLE
DIFFICULT COMMUNITY I URGE YOU
TO PLEASE PASS AT THE NINETY
NINE AND GIVE US THAT
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT SHE TOOK ALMOST ALL YOUR
TIME SO MS BORDEN IF YOU COULD
TO COME UP NEXT PLEASE. YES A
LARGE FISCAL IMPACT OF THE BILL
THAT WILL BE TWO CLASSIFICATION
AS WELL AS HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS FOR THE HOSPITALITY
SECTOR THERE'S A CLEAR
PFUNDAMENTAL REASON. BOTH PARTY
ENTERING INTO A CONTRACT OR
LEASE BEEN FRUSTRATED BUT INTO
IT ENTER MEETING CIRCUMVENT THE
STRENGTH ACTUALLY THE VALUE FOR
THE CONTRACT SB NINE THREE NINE
POTENTIALLY THEN APPLIES THE
METRIC. EQUIPMENT WHICH IS
LEGAL DOCTOR CALIFORNIA ANTIQUE
SO WOULD COST. OF BRING
TOGETHER. THE FEELING THAT THE
F. B. NINE NINE JOB CALIFORNIA.
NUMBER AT RECORD HIGH.
UNEMPLOYMENT GROWTH AND IMPACT
BUT SECTOR IN THE BUSINESS. IT
COULD THANK THEY COULD BANKRUPT
THE WHEN. THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHEN IT WHEN WE NEEDED
BUILDING BUT I MEAN HIGHER
DEPEND UPON WHETHER WHETHER NOT
LEVEL TO THEM ONE BY. IT
DOESN'T DEFINITELY WANT RE OPEN
LARGE NUMBERS ACROSS THE
ALREADY FILE LAWSUITS IT BUT
NOT MY RENTER. BY THE WAY OUT.
NONPROFIT BECAUSE HOW. THE
QUICK OKAY RENT EVERYTHING HELP
QUICK THE ECONOMY PLEASE GIVE
THEM A BY CHANCE WITH A THE
NINETY NINE THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT IS THERE A- HOW. WHO IS
HERE TO STAY THERE NAY. THEIR
ORGAN. AND THEIR- SUPPORT IN
ROOM. SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY. SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE WHO IS IN SUPPORT AND
AGAIN WE'RE T THE POINT WHERE
IT'S NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION SUPPORT PLEASE. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO UP FOR SUPPORT
YOU MAY DO SO BY PRESSING ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SIX TO SEVEN SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JERRY MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. GROWING
NUMBERS THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE THREE TWO THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OUR STORES A
STRATEGY THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF
OF HUGHES MARINO IN IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GROWING NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT THREE
TWO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY EIGHT CHECK
YOUR LINE FOR SELF ME PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JENNIFER
HEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT POLICY ALLIANCE OF
MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND
ORGANIZATIONS WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FOUR ONE ZERO
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS THAT A NOVEL RIGHT WITH
THE INDEPENDENT HOSPITALITY
COALITION REPRESENTING ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED AND A FAMILY OWNED
RESTAURANT IN LA COUNTY IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE THREE NINE.
SMALL BUSINESSES. MEETING ON
GENERATE. THE CARD. NIKE BUT
ALLOW SMALL BIT GET A LIFE ON
THE KEEP WORKING SAFE. BUT ALL
I NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE TWO SEVEN FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS JAY
CREATE ON BEHALF AND SHE AROUND
THE CORPORATION ALAMEDA COUNTY
RESTAURATEUR I AM STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF SB ON THREE NINE
THANK YOU. NO I NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETY THREE ONE
NINE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS TERRA GEREN
AND OWNER OF WIND DOWN THE LINE
VERY DIFFICULT AT THE QUALITY
BEEN MARCH I AM A STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB NINE THREE NINE.
HAVING THE ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE
WITH IRAN I DID THE ONLY WAY TO
A SMALL BUSINESSES LIKE OURS
THAT ARE THE BACKBONE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. FIND ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX ONE
SEVEN SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS BRIAN BUCKLEY- I CANNOT.
I AGREE MORE WITH THE PREVIOUS
STATEMENT THIRTY YEARS AGO I
BUILT A BUSINESS FROM NOTHING
I'VE BEEN IN THE HOSPITALITY
BUSINESS EVER SINCE EMPLOYED
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE AND- THE BUT
LANDLORDS THAT ARE JUST
UNCOOPERATIVE RIGHT NOW AND-
I'VE AYE I CANNOT STRESS HOW
DESPERATELY WE NEED SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. AS A
REMINDER PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO NAME WHO YOU
REPRESENT AND YOUR SUPPORT LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE TWO
FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE END OWNER OF CHIU
RESTAURANT ALSO REPRESENTING
THE INDEPENDENT HOSPITALITY
COALITION FOUR HUNDRED
RESTAURANTS EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES I'M IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THE GROWING
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE THREE TWO FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS NOT A TO
MUST LEARN I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF OUR COULD NOT BREWERS
COLLECTIVE IN LOS ANGELES AND
LEGALLY SUPPORT INTEL BUT WE
NEED TO. THANK YOU ONE THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR THREE
TWO FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS TONY AND I'M A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY VENTURA COUNTY AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTY- THE RESTAURANT
WORKERS AND BAR OWNERS. BY
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
DESPERATELY NEED THIS BILL I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ONE FIVE ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BIRD ECONOMY BEACH
FROM G. E. LAW GROUP A FIRM
THAT PRIMARILY PRACTICES IN
HOSPITALITY LONG IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE THREE NINE. SH MY
NUMBER FORTY FOUR FOUR FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI ENSURING- CO
OWNER TO RESTAURANTS IN SANTA
MONICA ALSO CO FOUNDING MEMBER
OF THE INDEPENDENT HOSPITALITY
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB NINE THREE NINE THANK YOU.
LINE THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SIX THREE TWO SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER
LEARNED BOTH MY HUSBAND ANDRE
NINE OF THEM BUT YOU'RE A
CHURCH IN SAN FRANCISCO
ALMAGUER SEAFOOD GRILL FOR
TWENTY TWO YEARS AND I'M
STRONGLY IMPORTANT AT THE NINE
THREE NINE. YOU WILL AYE NUMBER
SIXTY FOUR SIX FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AS LONG TIME I COHEN TO
SMALL BUSINESSES LOS ANGELES
RESTAURANT CALLED A BABY AND
YOU'RE TALKING A YEAR AND A IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB NINETY NINE.
NINE TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO
TO EIGHT TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS DALE CLOCK NEAR
WHERE. THE REALTORS ASSOCIATION
AND NOW FOR. VALLEY I'M- IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL. YOUR LINE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THREE THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LINE THREE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN CHECK FOR SELF
MUTE. SELECT ABOUT THEIR
CHILDREN AT THE RESTAURANT WAS
ALL TRAIN IT FROM THE GOOGLE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU LITTLE AE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED NINETY TWO
TWO NINE TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HEY MY NAME'S JOE HARGRAVE BAND
I HAVE VARIOUS TACO LICIOUS
LOCATIONS AROUND CALIFORNIA. IN
SUPPORT AND NEEDING YOUR HELP
THANK YOU. NAS EXHAUST THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
COME BACK TO THIS ROOM IS
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. TWO NINE
THREE NINE SEEING NONE LET'S GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. TWENTY
ONE IN OPPOSITION IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NO ONE IS
THERE ANYONE IN ON THE PHONE
WHO WAS IN OPPOSITION OF. NINE
THREE NINE. WE HAVE SOMEBODY
CUTER. YES SEVERAL PEOPLE. YES
SIR I MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
YOU HAD TO WITNESSES ON THE
AUDIO LINE THAT WE'RE GONNA
GIVE TESTIMONY ALREADY WENT TO
THE PUBLIC. GO TO THEM YES. GO
AHEAD THREE MINUTES FOR THE TWO
OF YOU. HELLO CARE PORTANTINO
CAN YOU HEAR ME THE- I CAN. ARE
WE HIGH RETURN AND DOES TRACY
IN MATTHEW RIGHT THE HERNANDEZ
YES EXACTLY- I'M THE TRACY
HERNANDEZ THE FOUNDING CEO A
BIT SAID- GRASSROOTS ALLIANCE
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND EMPLOYERS
LARGE AND SMALL FROM EVERY
SECTOR AND WE HAVE BOTH TENANTS
AND PROPERTY OWNERS THE
EMPLOYEE THREE AND A HALF
MILLION PEOPLE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WE STRONGLY. WE
UNDERSTAND IMPOSSIBLE TWO THAT
OUR BUSINESSES ARE FACING
ACROSS THE STATE DUE TO COPE
WITH NINETEEN AND WE EMPATHIZE
WITH THE INTENT OF THE BILL BUT
NINE THIRTY NINE UNFAIRLY
BENEFITS ONE BUSINESS OWNER
OVER ANOTHER. THIS BILL IS NOT
TAILORED TO FIXING OUR RECOVERY
PROBLEMS BUT RATHER ONLY
PROVIDE PROTECTION TO A VERY
SMALL SEGMENT WILL SHIFT
ECONOMIC HARM TO MANY OTHERS.
THIS BILL WILL ONLY EXACERBATE
OUR CURRENT ECONOMIC EMERGENCY
AND SEVERELY SLOW OUR RECOVERY
YOU CAN DO MUCH BETTER PLEASE
MOVE NINE THIRTY NINE AND- THEN.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT OUR OTHER
PRIMARY RESEARCHER. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I MATTHEW HARD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION WHEN STRONG
OPPOSITION SB NINE THIRTY NINE
IN ORDER TO SAVE TIME ON
MULTIPLE CALLS I'M REPRESENTING
THE FOLLOWING A SOAP SO
STATIONS REPRESENTING PROPERTY
OWNERS AND COMMERCIAL TENANTS
INTERNATIONAL COUNCIL OF
SHOPPING CENTERS MADE UP OF
CALIFORNIA- MY CALIFORNIA I RUN
NAY RE AND A I. R. C. R. E. THE
COMMERCIAL REAL ESTATE BUSINESS
MODEL IS TO HAVE TENANTS. AND
AS THE SPONSORS HAVE NOTED
PROPERTY OWNERS ACROSS THE
STATE MORE WORKING WITH THEM TO
GET TO THIS PANDEMIC THIS BILL
TRADES SHORT TERM AT LEAST FOR
A FEW COMPANIES FOR A LONG TERM
COMMERCIAL MORTGAGE CRISIS THAT
WILL DRAG DOWN THE ECONOMY AND
THE GENERAL FUND WITH THAT THE
STATE CUP THE BILL ARE
POTENTIALLY HUGE. AS URINALYSIS
NOTE. THE NEW LEASES WILL GO
DOWN BECOME MORE. TO MANAGE AND
COURT COSTS WILL RISE TO THE
INCREASE CIVIL SUIT. WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH MISTER WINNER
SINCE MARCH FOURTEENTH ON THIS
BILL THROUGH THREE ROUNDS OF
AMENDMENTS AND WE HAVE YET TO
SEE ANYTHING THAT ADDRESSES THE
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES. OR MANY
OTHER COMPLAINT WE REMAIN
OPPOSED WE APPRECIATE THE BILL
GOING SUSPENSE AND HOPE IT HELD
THERE THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE ONLINE WE
WENT THROUGH THIS ROOM AND
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ELSE CUED UP. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU LIKE TO VOICE OPPOSITION
ON THE AUDIO LINES FOR SB NINE
THREE NINE YOU MAY DO SO BY
PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE WILL BEGIN WITH LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SEVEN ONE FIVE SEVEN PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME WE REPRESENT
AND YOUR OPPOSITION. NINE ONE
FIVE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HEARING NO
RESPONSE WE WILL MOVE ON TO
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY SIX LINE TWO FOUR SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS CHRIS WHITE
SAKE WITH WESTERN MANUFACTURED
HOUSING COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION
AND WE'RE IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU WILL GET ONE NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND TEN THREE ONE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THIS IS KATHY VAN
AUSTIN I REPRESENT MANY
BROTHERS REAL ESTATE GROUP. AND
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE- THE
NINE THIRTY NINE. GILDER LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
TWO TWO ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TWENTY CHAIRED MEMBERS
ADAMANTLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION BUT NOT
THE IN THE LATE AT THE MOMENT
SO FAR THE MOMENT OF NOT
ADDRESS MANY OF THE- THANK YOU.
THE LITTLE AYE NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE TWO
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING SIR PORTANTINO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JONATHAN CLAY
ON BEHALF REPORTED SEEING IT
AGAIN WE ARE REGRETFULLY OF.
THE WIRE ONE OF. HE WORKS LIKE
AGENCIES- ACTING UP OR YOU.
REVENUE BASE AND WE BOUGHT
MILLION. YOU. YOUR FOR.
INTERESTING MODERATOR. POLICIES
ONE MOMENT PLEASE I'M
EXPERIENCING A LITTLE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTY. PLEASE BEAR WITH ME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MAY MAKE A
COMMENT SO I MIGHT LEAVE. WHICH
IS THE QUESTION AND DIRECTION
CAN WE WAIT TILL WE FINISH. WE
SHOULD BE WE'RE JUST ABOUT DONE.
OKAY I THINK WE MIGHT BE BACK
LET'S TRY MY NUMBER'S THREE
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN THREE ONE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS DAVID TOLL I REPRESENT
JABBER ORIGINAL HOLDING SCREEN
JOB REGIONAL HOLDINGS FIVE IN
LOS ANGELES- WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THREE NINE THREE NINE. IMPACT
WILL BE REPAIRABLE HARM TO
PROPERTY OWNERS. OF THE
ARBITRARY THIRD TAKE YOUR NAME
AND YOUR POSITION PLEASE. DAVID
HOLE AND YOUR POSTS JABBER
ORIGINAL I AM OPPOSED THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE YOU
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT SPEAKER.
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED IN TWO
THREE ZERO TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MOIRA TOP ON BEHALF OF
ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL
IN OPPOSITION. YOUR LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE ONE
THREE FIVE YEAR LONG. FIVE DEAL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
EIGHT TO FIVE EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHEN
MEMBERS TO STILL I WOULD PLAY
WITH MATH ON BEHALF OF BRICKS
FOR PROPERTY GROUP IN
OPPOSITION. LINE THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TO PREACH TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND MARIN WITH THEIR IN
READING ASSOCIATE REPRESENTING
SOME CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION. SHE THANK YOU. BY
NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN THREE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JAMES CAME
UP WITH NAY UP STRONGLY OPPOSED
IT WILL CAUSE LANDLORDS TO FOR
NAY NOT BE ABLE TO PAY TEIR
DEBT SERVICE AS YOUR NAME IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS POINT THANK
YOU NEXT PERSON. BUYING TO OPEN
SEVENTY NINE TWO SEVEN NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR NUMBER TWO JUST KELLY HAD
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DESTINATION OF PORTABILITY AND
WE HAVE AN OPPOSED AMENDED
POSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
THREE THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MORE MANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JACOB HOW
THE AND I'M AT THE HOLLYWOOD
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND ON
BEHALF OF OUR OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED MEMBERS WE AREN'T
OPPOSITION THAT. WE NINE THREE
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU OVER
THE LINE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
AND FORTY THREE THREE FOUR
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN JOHN
CALDWELL ABOUT HALF THE
CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND LODGING
ASSOCIATION WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL. LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE THREE
THREE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MEMBERS NOT OURS WITH THE
SUBJUGATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES.
BUT ALL I NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE THREE THREE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
SEVEN QUARTER ON BEHALF OF BOOK
FIELD RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. BY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY
TWO NINE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR KERRY MEMBERS
THE ENGINE MINETTI OPPOSITION
ON BEHALF OF HUDSON TO DEPICT
PROPERTY THANK YOU. FIND TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE TWO
EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
SEC MATE FOR THREE. DID YOU
OKAY THIS IS ANASTACIO
ANNAPOLIS A MEMBER OF SAN
FRANCISCO ANTI DISPLACEMENT
COALITION THE BILL SEEMS VERY
UNFAIR TO. MINORITY MEN YOU'RE
ON JUST THE NAME IN YOUR
POSITION MA'AM. NYNEX PERSON.
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
TWO FOUR ONE YEAR PLAN OPEN.
GOOD MORNING SURE MEMBERS M. L.
BUT THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS SOLUTION ATION
REPRESENTING OVER A THOUSAND
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
UNFORTUNATELY IN RESPECTFULLY
LET'S SUPPOSE I'M ALSO MEASURES
AMENDED. EXCLUDE PUBLIC
AGENCIES. NINE THREE HUNDRED
AND FORTY FIVE THREE FOUR FIVE
YOUR LINE IS A WEST. HI GOOD
MORNING I'M ON THE FLOOR TO THE
VALLEY MISSION COMMERCE MASON
BICA IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
LINE THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
SEVEN THREE FOUR SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS JOHN
PALMER I'M A SMALL LANDLORD ALL
THE TESTIMONIALS FROM
RESTAURANT BUT THIS BILL COVERS
ALL ATTENDANCE. OFFICE TENANTS
HEDGE GUNS VENTURE CAPITAL
RACED. EVEN AS PRIDE CAPITAL
BASE WOULD BE SURE YOU HAVE
MILLION OF DOLLARS THE BANK
THEY ARE WELL RECOVERY THEY
DON'T EVEN KNOW IF THEY NEED
OFFICE SPACE ANYMORE MODERATOR
NOT THIS BILL IS WAY TOO BROAD
THANK YOU. LINE THREE FORTY
FOUR THREE FOUR FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN IF THE SPEAKERS GOOD
MORNING MISTER. PLEASE LIMIT
YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME AND
YOUR POSITION AT THIS POINT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS HERE NAME ALL OF
REPRESENTING MAJESTIC REALTY
ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
NINE THREE FOUR SIX THREE FOUR
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RAMOS TO
GERMANY'S RUN KINKS IN MY
REPRESENTS THREE REGIONAL
APARTMENT ASSOCIATIONS PURPOSES
YUSHIN ORANGE COUNTY EAST BAY
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION AND
THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN CITIES WE
JOINED THE OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
LINE THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
NINE THREE FOUR NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR TURN
MEMBERS ANTHONY HELPING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LAND TITLE
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SEVEN ONE FIVE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
CHECK. YOUR LINE FOR SELF MUTE
WE ARE HEARING NOBODY. HELLO WE
CAN. IN HEAR ME YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY SORRY MY NAME IS.
PATRICIA BROWNELL AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE AND
YOUR AIR CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
THE NINE THREE NINE. OKAY LINE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SIX THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE RICHARD MARX AND
ON BEHALF THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. AND
WE HAVE EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT AT THIS
POINT WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD OF THIS
BILL AND WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
BRIEF ADJOURNMENT CAN YOU HOLD
YOUR QUESTIONS UNTIL WE GET
BACK IF WE STAY ON THIS HI YES
YES COMING TO THIS SITE WE'RE
GOING TO ADJOURN. LONG IT TAKES
STEPS A COME BACK FOR BIGGEST
CAUCUSES BEEN PUSHED TO TWELVE
THIRTY- MY TO MY HOPE TO DO
BILLS IN TWELVE TWELVE THIRTY.
NOT WILL WHAT. JOURNEY BUT- A
TOP AFTER LUNCH. YEAH. WHAT OF
THE WEST STEPS.
MISTER MODERATOR
WILL BEGIN SHORTLY. WILSON IS
MS BATES GETS BACK WE WILL
PROCEED. WE HAVE- ENDED PUBLIC
COMMENT ON NINE THREE NINE
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. MS BATES
THAN MISTER WHAT CASKEY THAN
MISTER WEINER FOR HIS CLOTHES.
SO. THERE ARE A FEW DIFFERENT
BRANDS CONNECTED OVER VIDEO OF
OFF MICROPHONE. I HAVE HEARD
YEAH MICROPHONE IS OFF. THE
BOTTOM LINE TRANSIT. THANKS
VERY MUCH FOR SOMETHING THEY
DON'T HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL
I DON'T HEAR THAT. AND THE
REASON I ASK IS BECAUSE- YOU'RE
LISTENING THIS IS ABOUT ONE
TWENTY THREE FIFTY. WELL I
WOULD.
WE'LL JUST WAIT FOR HER.
RESTORE COUNTY WILL COACH SO WE
ARE BACK WHEN I CALL THIS
MEETING BACK TO ORDER WE HAVE
FINISHED PUBLIC COMMENT ON SB
NINE THREE NINE BY MISTER
WIENER MISTER WHITE COUNT SKI
BUT LET ME GO DEPARTMENT SAID
PHARMA FINANCES NOT HAVE A FILE
ON THIS BILL. SO MISTER WHITE
CALCIUM TO TURN BACK TO YOU
YEAH I WAS ONE TEST CENTER
WINNER ABOUT THE WORKLOAD
IMPACT ON THE COURTS THE FEE
THERE'S NOTHING SAID DURING
THE- DISCUSSION IN THE
WITNESSES IT SEEMS LIKE THIS
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT AND
GIVEN THE CUTS THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS ON THE ON THE
COURTS- IT MAY PUT PRESSURE
GENERAL FUND TO INCREASE- COURT
PERSONNEL TO DEAL WITH. ALL
THESE DISPUTES CAN YOU HAVE A
COMMENT ON THAT WELL I ACTUALLY
THINK THE OPPOSITE IS THE CASE
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW- IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
HUGE THE CITY ITSELF IF WE
DON'T ACT AND PUT A STRUCTURE
IN PLACE FOR WHAT THE
EXPECTATIONS ARE WE'RE GOING TO
SEE A LOT OF THESE BUSINESSES
CLOSED DOWN THERE'S GOING TO BE
A LOT OF LITIGATION. AGAINST
THE OWNERS OF BUSINESSES TO
COLLECT YOU KNOW RAN OVER
ETCETERA ETCETERA ETCETERA SO I
DON'T SO THERE WILL BE WITHOUT
THIS BILL THERE WILL BE
SIGNIFICANT LITIGATION I'M I
THINK OF ANYTHING THAT THIS
FIVE BILL WILL REDUCE. THE
AMOUNT OF LITIGATION COMPARED
TO WHAT HAPPENED WITH THAT THIS
BILL AND I KNOW SOMETIMES THIS
COMMITTEE YOU HAVE THE LOOK AT
THE KEY CREATED WITHOUT THE
CALL OF WITH AND SO I DON'T
THINK IT'S SO OBVIOUS RESULT.
IN REDUCED COST PRESSURE ON A
IN MAY EVEN DECREASE OF A PRESS.
ALL RIGHT I SHARE THE SAME
CONCERN THE MISTER Y. CASKEY-
DOES END OF THE ANALYSIS YOU
KNOW MENTIONED AS AN UNKNOWN.
COST PRESSURE AT THIS POINT SO
OBVIOUSLY STE MISTER WINNER
WHEN YOU AND I TALKED WE'LL BE
TALKING ABOUT THAT I KNOW WE
HAVE A- YEAH AND WE HAVE A
MEETING SCHEDULED- AND THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY TO I THINK-
OBVIOUSLY- SOMETHING I'M GONNA
WANT TO TALK TO YOU AND THEN
PSIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS THAT
YOU'RE GONNA BE PROPOSING THE
SOONER YOU GET THOSE TO STAFF
THE BETTER TODAY. TODAY IT WILL
GET THE MOCK UP TODAY AND THEN
THE COUNCIL DRAFTED WILL BE
LATER BUT THE MOUTH OF THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL THE SOONER THE
BETTER WOULD BE HELPFUL SO WE
CAN WE CAN ANALYZE THEM IN
RELATION TO WHAT THE WORK
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN DONE UP TO
THIS POINT. A MISTAKE SHE
WANTED TO- MAKE A COMMENT A YES
THANK YOU A- PORTANTINO. THIS
HAS TO DO WITH A REQUEST THAT
ARE FISCAL STAFF- PLEASE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WELL IN
ADVANCE. OF THE HEARING SO WE
COULD BE PREPARED TO. HEAR THE
FISCAL IMPACTS SIDE TODAY- WE
WERE TOLD THAT FINANCE WOULD
NOT HAVE A FILE WE ALSO ASKED
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES TO ATTEND TODAY'S
HEARING. BE PREPARED TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AND THIS ISABOUT
FISCAL IMPACT. AS IT RELATES TO
STATE PROPERTIES SO WHERE WE
HAVE LEASES. IDG EFFORT BY SAYS
IT WOULD NOT LIKELY BE ABLE TO
GET APPROVAL FROM
ADMINISTRATION TO A TOWN. BOB
THIS IS FOR YOU KNOW MISSILE
DISTURBING ESPECIALLY AT THESE
TIMES WE HAVE THESE KIND OF
AMENDED SORT OF EDITED
HEARINGS. DGL FOR ADVICE THEY
PABLE TO GET APPROVAL. CANCEL
WERE FRUSTRATED THAT WE CANNOT
GET TIMELY INFORMATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. EVEN ASK OF. OUR
EVEN WHEN WE ASK FOR IT IN
ADVANCE. AND IT CERTAINLY HAS
AN ISSUE REGARDING OUR STATE
PROPERTIES AND I THINK THAT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN MENTIONED I WAS
I WAS SIGNED A JOINT GREEK.
JOINING US SO. I'D LIKE TO MAKE
A REQUEST ON THE RECORD THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AN
APARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES.
ALONG WITH OUR STATE PARKS.
PROVIDE INFORMATION ON THE COST
IMPACTS. IN THE WORKLOAD
IMPACTS THE BILL WILL HAVE
WHILE IT IS ON SIXPENCE. THING
AND I JUST LIKE TO SAY YOU KNOW
THIS KIND OF AN EQUATION WE
HAVE THOSE WHO. OWN PROPERTIES
HAVE FISCAL. ARE SIGNIFICANT
WITH THOSE PROPERTIES
MORTGAGES. PROPERTY TAXES AND
ON THE OTHER SIDE WE HAVE
PEOPLE WHO ARE LEAST FROM THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. THERE A
POSSIBILITY BUT THEY ALSO HAVE.
PRESSURES WE KNOW IN TERMS OF
BEING ABLE TO GENERATE
REVENUES. BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
ANTIQUATED AND IT REALLY NEEDS
TO BE BALANCED ON BOTH SIDES.
AND I SAID. THAT WE ARE GOING
TO ASK FOR. HIS VERY A
RETROACTIVE AND SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL IMPACT ON ONE SIDE OF
THE OF. XIN THAT'D BE GRANTED
TO THE OTHER SIDE WHICH WOULD
MEAN. OF REMOVING THE RECORD.
ON GET FOR. ON TARGET. FOR THIS
SAME L<C.CYAN>G OF TIME AND ALSO</C>
WITH NO PENALTIES TO. AND ALSO
PRO TAX OF HALF BE CAN. THAT'S
A HUGE A- TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE ALREADY KNOW
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
IMPACTS THERE. SO THOSE ARE
JUST COMMENTS THAT REALLY NEED
TO BE TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION
AND WE GO FORWARD. ARE TRYING
TO FIND A BALANCE WITH THIS
BILL TO CERTAINLY HELP. BOTH
SIDES OF THE EQUATION BECAUSE
THEY ARE CERTAINLY EXTREMELY
VITAL TO THE RECOVERY OF OUR
ECONOMY HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
BATES- OBVIOUSLY I'LL CHECK IN
WITH THE- APPROACH STAFF AS
WELL TO SEE WHAT THE STATUS OF
YOUR REQUESTS ARE AND SEE WHAT
INFORMATION WE CAN- WE CAN GET
TO AID IN. GETTING THE PUBLIC
PROPERTY IMPACTS THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY MISTER WINNER OF IF
YOU WANT TO ADDRESS THOSE
QUESTIONS IN YOUR CLOTHES ARE.
OBVIOUSLY PLEASE DO AND THEN
WE'LL KEEP GOING. BUT OF IT TO
CLOSE NOW- THANK YOU MS
APARTMENT FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE
A FILE- BUT WE ARE GOING TO
DRILL DOWN ON HIS BATES
CONCERNS YEAH ABSOLUTELY AND WE
WERE WE WALKING A CONVERSATION
SO THANK YOU FOR THE DISCUSSION
TODAY INTO AS YOU CAN SEE
THERE'S A LOT OF STRONG
OPINIONS ON THIS BILL ON BOTH
SIDES- AND WE HAVE THE RULES
THIS THREE EXTREMELY OPPOSED
AND THEN WE HAVE. MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES WHO ARE COMING TO
THIS LEGISLATURE AND ASKING FOR
A LIFELINE ALERT FIND THAT THEY
DO NOT HAVE RIGHT NOW AND I
RESPECTFULLY. IT'S SOME SORT OF
ECONOMIC MELTDOWN WELL
RESPECTFULLY WE ARE IN AN
ECONOMIC MELTDOWN NOW AND IF WE
DON'T THROW A LIFELINE TO THE
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF SMALL BUSINESSES
UP AND DOWN THE STATE WHO ARE
AT RISK SEVERE RISK OF
PERMANENT CLOSURE. THAT IS A
RECIPE FOR A LONG TERM ECONOMIC
MELTDOWN BECAUSE WE KNOW SMALL
BUSINESS IS ARE ARE THE CORE OF
OUR JOBS. IN CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS THE VIBRANCY OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS- IN TERMS OF THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY A PROCEDURE
IN THE POLICY COMMITTEE THAT
HAS JURISDICTION OVER THINGS
LIKE CONSTITUTIONALITY.
ACTUALLY DID AN EXTENSIVE
DISCUSSION AND THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. THANK
INCLUDED THAT THIS BILL IS VERY
DEFENSIBLE FROM A
CONSTITUTIONAL PERSPECTIVE
SOMEONE CAN ALWAYS CHALLENGE OF
COURSE HAVE A RIGHT TO DO THAT.
BUT THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THE
POLICY COMMITTEE CONCLUDED THAT
THIS IS A VERY DEFENSIBLE BILL
CONSTITUTIONALLY WE ARE IN A
UNIQUE- HEALTH PANDEMIC. THAT
IS THREATENING MASSIVE ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES AND WE HAVE THE
ABILITY AS A LEGISLATURE- TO
ADDRESS THAT. AS I NOTED- WE
ARE GOING TO REMOVE THE LEASE
TERMINATION PROVISION REPLACE
IT WITH SOMETHING SOFTER- WE
ARE TRYING TO RESPOND TO SOME
OF THE CONCERNS. ON IN TERMS OF
LOAN DEFAULTS BECAUSE THAT'S
BEEN MEANT. NONE OF US WANTS
ANY OF THESE LANDLORDS LARGE OR
SMALL TO GO INTO FAULT OR
FORECLOSURE- AND TO SENATOR
BATES I WOULD LOVE TO ALSO
ADDRESS THE MORTGAGE ISSUES AND
BUILT. GIVEN THE FEATHER JURY
OVER SO MANY THE MORE IS THERE.
REGULATE IT'S HARD ENOUGH SPLIT.
FEDERAL AND STATE SO WE ARE
DOING A WE TIME BUT I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN.
THE IT IS NOT CASE. THAT THESE.
LANDLORDS ARE JUST PEACHY KEEN
RIGHT EVERY IS ALL GOOD
EVERYONE'S PAYING THEIR RENT
AND YOU KNOW SCOTT WIENER
LEANING AND SALAS COME ALONG
AND SAY WE THINK THEY SHOULD
PAY REDUCE RIGHT. THEY'RE NOT
GETTING THE RENT OVERWHELMINGLY
RIGHT NOW. AND SO THIS BILL
DISAPPEAR TOMORROW IT'S NOT
LIKE THEY WOULD BE COLLECTING
FOR RENT. THOSE BUSINESSES ARE
JUST GOING TO CLOSE DOWN THE
CHOICE FOR SO MANY OF THESE
LANDLORDS IS NOT. DO YOU GET
FOR RENT OR REDUCED RAN. IT'S
DO YOU GET REDUCED RIGHT OR NO
RENT YOU CAN'T SQUEEZE BLOOD
FROM A TURNIP THESE BUSINESSES
ARE JUST GOING TO CLOSE. DOWN
SO IT'S NOT THE CASE THAT
THERE'S NO RISK OF LOAN DEFAULT
ALARIC WE'RE CREATING I THINK
QUITE. THE OPPOSITE- I WANT TO
STRESS AGAIN IN CLOSING- THAT.
AS FAR AS WE KNOW THIS IS THE
ONLY BILL IN THE LEGISLATURE.
TO TRY TO ADDRESS WHAT IS
WHATEVER ONE'S PERSPECTIVE WHAT
IS A VERY REAL ISSUE. IN TERMS
OF THE THREAT OF A MASS
EXTINCTION EVENT. FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND PARTICULARLY OUR
SMALL NEIGHBORHOOD BUSINESSES.
AND COMMUNITY SERVING
NONPROFITS THERE IS NOTHING
ELSE THAT I KNOW OF IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS THAT.
THIS IS THE VEHICLE. IT IS ON A
COMPRESSED TIMELINE LIKE ALL
COOPER BILLS. WE'VE ALREADY
MADE AND WILL CONSIDER AND ARE
MAKING SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO
WHAT WE KNOW IT'S A WORK IN
PROGRESS WE WILL WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. AND I'M ASKING-
THAT WITH THAT IF THIS COMES
OFF SUSPENSE AND I HOPE IT WILL
THAT WOULD BE GIVEN OPPORTUNITY
WORKING WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
CENTER. TO FORMULATE A BILL
THAT EVERYONE CAN LIVE WITH.
THAT THROWS A LIFELINE TO THESE
ESSENTIAL SMALL BUSINESSES.
THIS COMES OUT SUSPENSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MAYOR I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU WELL IT'S SUSPEND
TO HAVE THOSE CON. AND USE CA
TIMELINE JUDICIOUSLY OBVIOUSLY
MENTIONING TO GET THE- AND
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER SO WE
CAN START EVALUATING THAT. AND
WITHOUT ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR OBJECTION SB NINE THREE NINE
GOES TO SUSPECTS. YOU HAVE A
HOUSING BILLS BUT IT IS A
HOUSING ON THE BUS BILLS IT'S A
HOUSING COMMITTEE ACROSS THE A
HOUSING COMMITTEE BILL I'M
SORRY. SB TEN THIRTY MISTER
CHAIRMAN YEAH YES AND THIS IS A
IS A BECAUSE OF ONE PROVISION A
COULD BE TWENTY POINT EIGHT
EIGHT SO I'M- TO BRIEFLY
PRESENT. BY MISTER MEMBERSTHIS
IS A ARE AT YOU WILL. ON THE
MOST. CONTAINS ENOUGH OF TAX
AND NON CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES.
TO STATE HOUSING LAW. IT PASSED
OUT OF THE SENATE HOUSING
COMMITTEE ON CONSENT. AND I
UNDERSTAND THE RECOMMENDATION
TODAY IS TO PASS WE ARE UNAWARE
OF ANY OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
MOVE THE BILL HOLD ON WE GOT
AYE WE HAVE A MOTION BUT LET'S
SEE IF THERE ANYBODY HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM KNOWN ANYBODY IN TEN FORTY
KNOW ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
MISTER MODERATOR. THANK YOU IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THERE IS NO ONE
SHOWING UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT ANY OPPOSITION IN THIS
ROOM SEEING NINE ANY OPPOSITION
IN TEN FORTY. SEEING NINE ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE. ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE'S NO ONE SHOWING UP AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL WE
HAVE A MOTION MISTER WEINER I
ASSUME YOU'RE CLOSES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PROVIDE VOTE.
WITH THAT TO MISTER CLARK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB TEN
THIRTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO I
WANT TO KNOW HI BATES HI BATES
I BRADFORD ARE BRADFORD BY HILL
I. BILL ARE JOURNAL I JONES ARE
LEYVA HI LEYVA HI MY CASKEY BY
MY COUNT ARE. SEVEN ZERO. THE
BILL IS OUT SERVE ZERO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER WIENER
YOU HAVE ONE MORE BILL WHICH
YOU WERE PRESENTATION ON SB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT WHICH IS A
HOUSE L. EMERGENCY SHELTER BILL
IS A ANYWAY HERE IN SUPPORT SEE
NINE AND EVEN OR- TWENTY FORTY.
SAYING NO ANY ON THE- PRESS ONE
ZERO ON THE PHONE LINES IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT WE DO
HAVE ONE IT'S GOING TO COME
FROM THE LINE NUMBER. NEVER
MIND THEY DO DROP OUT. AND
THEY'RE BACK WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY
SIX TWO NINE SIX ONE IS OPEN.
IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX ARE ONLY
HEARING BACKGROUND. HI THIS IS
BOB NAYLOR A RISEN FEELS INCOME
IN ORDER TO COUNTY BILL FROM
SUPPORTIVE OF HEALTH YOU HIM WE
STRONG SUPPORT US NEIL. THIRTY
EIGHT. ANYONE ELSE. NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME OUR
WE WILL GO TO OPPOSITE ANY IN
THIS UP ELEVEN THIRTY C. NINE
AND IN TEN TWENTY FIVE. SAYING
NINE ANYONE ON THE PHONE. YOUR
IQ UP ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION IT'S ONE MAN ZERO.
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THE BILL SEEING
NO HANDS FOR MY COLLEAGUES GO
UP. WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT WE'LL GO TO SAYS
SPENDS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO MISTER DODDS BILLS STARTING
WITH A SB. STATE SIXTY TWO
WHICH IS A PLANNED POWER HOUR
OUTAGE PUBLIC SAFETY BILL- IS
OR ANYONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT. OF MR DOT IS WAY
PRESENTATION THERE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT. OF EIGHT SIX TWO.
SEEING NINE ANYBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHT SIX TWO. SEEING NOT
ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT
OF EIGHT SIX TWO. IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHT SIX TWO ON THE AUDIO YOU
MAY VOICES BY PRESSING A ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND NO
ONE IS COMING UP AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT WILL COME BACK TO
THIS ROOM ANY OPPOSITION TATE
SIX TWO. SEEING NONE ANYBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN OPPOSITION
OF EIGHT SIX TWO. SEEING NONE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHT SIX TWO.
YOU'RE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHT SIX TWO
YOU'RE A PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE THAT
JUST CUED UP PLEASE ALLOW US
MOMENT TO PRIDE IN THEIR LINE
NUMBER. FOLLOWING NUMBER FOUR
ZERO FIVE FOUR HUNDRED AND FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS OF THE
NATIONAL TEN DAY OF JACK AND
ELECT IN OPPOSITION FORWARD TO
WORKING THE AUTHOR. ALL RIGHT
ANYONE ELSE. AND ANOTHER ONE
THAT JUST ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
FOR LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHT
FOUR ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON LARA PAR
WITH BUT IN CALIFORNIA AND
INSTEAD WE HAVE A TO HOLD THEM
BUT NOT THAT. I WOULD LIKE TO
COULD YOU WORKING THE AUTHOR
GEORGIA THANK THANK YOU. NO ONE
IN THE KEY. JUST OUR RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINE THIS HAVE A
ON THE BILL SEEING NO RUSH OF
HANDS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHT
SIXTY TWO WILL GO TO CSUS FENCE
MOVING ON TO OUR NEXT BILL
WHICH IS SB EIGHT FOUR ALSO BY
MISTER DODD. HE IS WAY
PRESENTATION IT DEALS WITH
EDUCATION FINANCE OR ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT
EIGHT FOUR SEEING NO ONE
RUSSIAN THE MICROPHONE MOVING
TO. TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NO ONE
ANYWHERE WE WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHT EIGHT FOUR ONLINE. IF YOU
ARE ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHT EIGHT FOR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT FOUR THREE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ELIZABETH AFTER
ALL OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALSO GO TO LINE NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED AND NINE FOUR ZERO NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
CHRIS CHOICE ARGUE WITH WESTERN
MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION AND I
THINK I WAS PUT INTO THE WRONG
QUEUE BUT WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
AB- SB. EIGHT SIX TWO. NO ONE
ELSE IN HERE AT THIS TIME. OUR
I'M SORRY. NO ONE ELSE IS INTO
IT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT ANY
OPPOSITION. ON EIGHT EIGHT FOUR
IN THIS ROOM NOW IN THE OTHER
ROOM. NO ONLINE. ANY OPPOSITION.
ONE NINE ZERO. THAT ONE COMING
UP AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
A HOT DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL I DON'T SEE ANY HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
EIGHT EIGHT FOUR WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN
BY MISTER DOT ON NURSE
MIDWIVES- IS THERE ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN. SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
OTHER ROOM IN SUPPORT. SEEING
NO ONE IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OF SB. TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN. ON THE PHONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WE DO A FEW WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL QUEUING UP ACTUALLY ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. THREE YEAR. WHAT
A LINE NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ONE FOUR FIVE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME
IS TERRYLAMBERT. AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT PLEASE ARE TRYING TO GET
CAUGHT UP ON THE QUEUE.
ONE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FOUR TWO THREE FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO YES YOUR LINE IS
OPEN MANDO HAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME'S REVERTED FRANK I'M WITH
BEST START BIRTH CENTER AND I'M
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU OVER THE
LINE NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FOUR FIVE ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. EIGHT ONE NINE FOUR
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. HERE'S A REMOVE
THEMSELVES FROM THEIR QUEUE
WILL GO TO ONE FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE FOUR FOUR THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS ON A ROB PORTMAN CALIFORNIA
NURSE MIDWIFE AND I SUPPORT SB
ONE TWO THREE. THANK YOU. IT
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE TWO FOUR
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS KATHLEEN BELL THERE
AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION. I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE JUSTICE
AND EQUITY IN MATERNITY CARE
ACT THANK YOU. WHAT A LINE
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT FOUR FOUR EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS ELIZABETH
CALLING ON BEHALF OF SANTA ROSA
BURKE CENTER I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB. ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN. LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN FOUR ONE FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS HOLLY THAT
LEGISLATIVE CARE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HERE'S MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN FOUR
FIVE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS CAN BE A NOBLE
CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIFE IN STRONG SUPPORT. YOU
LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX
FOUR FIVE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS REBECCA GERRY
BROWN ANNE ON THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REP AND I'M INTO
PERCY ANIME AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ONE TWO THREE
SEVEN. IN ORDER LINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE FOUR
FIVE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON ERIC
PUBLISHED ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED NURSES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q. AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
BACK TO THIS ROOM FOR
OPPOSITION- THERE'S NO ONE HERE
WILL MOVE TO. TWENTY FORTY.
THERE'S NO ONE THERE WILL GO
BACK TO THE LINE IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE. TO VOICE OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE
ON THIS BILL I SEE NO HANDS
FROM MY I'M SURE. HEY IF I'M
SURE TO BE SO THERE WAS I
THOUGHT SO THE WITH WHAT.
AUTHOR HE SAID THERE WAS NO ONE
Q. UP I'M HEARD OF. WE DO HAVE
ONE IN THE QUEUE WELL ALL RIGHT
GO AHEAD AND EIGHTY THREE EIGHT
FOUR AHEAD. HI THIS IS USE THE
YOU FROM HEALTH FAMILIES
CORRECT TO MAKE WE. OVER FACT
CONSUMERS AND STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE AND AMENDED.
ALL RIGHT WILL GIVE US TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY ELSE. ONE AGAIN
FOR OPPOSITION A ONE THAT ZERO.
NO ONE IS SECURING UP ACOSTA
ALL RIGHTS KNOWN AS IS KEY UP
THERE IS NO FILE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB. TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN WE'LL
GO TO SUSPENSE. I HAVE A
FEELING THE NEXT BILL IS GOING
TO TAKE AWHILE. AND SO WE HAVE
CAUCUS IN. FIVE MINUTES SO I
THINK WE SHOULD PROBABLY DELAY.
HISTORY THAT YES SO THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE THE WE GOT A FEW
IN. IT'S SO EVERYBODY WHO IS
ONLINE WE ARE GOING TO- ADJOURN
UNTIL. RECESS SIXTY MILLION A
RECESS UNTIL. TO LAST YEAR WELL
WE KNOW CAUCUSES BUT SAY. TO
ONE FORTY FIVE OKAY WE WILL WE
WILL RECONVENE AT. ONE FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THESE WAVE PRESENTATION AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WE
HAVE SOME WITNESSES THAT ARE
OPPOSED THAT HAVE BEEN PRE
QUEUED UP BUT LET'S DO THE
SUPPORT IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT NOBODY'S
HERE. SENATE BODY IN HER ROOM
TWELVE. FORTY I SEE NOBODY
THERE IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
LINE IN SUPPORT. IF YOU'D LIKE
TO VOICE SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME THIS
IS SCA SIX. THERE'S NO ONE
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT WE WILL GO TO THE
OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE. TWO
SPEAKERS THAT OUR PRIMARY
OPPOSITION THE GENTLEMAN IF YOU
COULD CONFINE YOUR COMMENTS TO
THREE MINUTES IN TOTAL- AS YOU
SAW THERE WAS NO. THE SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT. BECAUSE THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL MATTER GOING TO
SUSPENSE BUT WE HAVE HAD NGUYEN
ROMERO. OF THE BROADBAND
COMMISSION INDUSTRY IN INDIANS
AND WE HAVE. JAMES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA NATION'S INDIAN
GAMING ASSOCIATION BOTH
CHAIRMAN PLEASE. B. CUED UP AND
WILL AWAIT YOUR COMMENTS. HOW.
GOOD MORNING I KNOW GOOD
AFTERNOON. GERMAN BORN JUNE
PERMITTING BY INTERNAL MERYL
BOTTOM A MEASURE INDIANS. ONE
OF THE OF DOESN'T OF TRY. I WAS
GONNA TRY OPPOSITE DRESSED SAID.
PUBLISHER OF TIME TO SHOW WITH
YOU AND HAVE THESE CO. IN A WAY
BUT NOW THIS WHOLE TO DO. SIX
DUE TO CONSIDER THE TROUBLED
HISTORY. THE PENCIL IMPACT ON
OUR PEOPLE. A LOCAL GAMING
INDUSTRY ALSO PROVIDES BENEFITS
BEYOND OUR RESERVATIONS IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN YOU IN GAINING
IN CALIFORNIA DIRECTLY AND
INDIRECTLY GENERATED ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
JOBS AND THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION THE TAXES AND REVENUE
SHARING PAYMENTS TO THE FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
EDUCATION PROPONENTS CLAIM
EXAGGERATED ECONOMIC BETTER
LIVES TO CALIFORNIA. THERE
WOULD BE NO BENEFIT TO THE
STATE IN THE NEAR TERM TO HELP
WITH COLD THE CRISIS BECAUSE IT
WOULD TAKE YOU UP ON THAT ANY
SPORTS BETTING OPPORTUNITIES.
EXAGGERATED REVENUE PROJECTION
OF SCA SIX DEPEND ON THE USE OF
ONLINE BETTING. WHICH WE AND
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
VOTERS REJECT. IN DOWN THIS
ONLINE THE SUPPORT BETTING NOW
ANOTHER GAINS IN THE FUTURE
WOULD DEVASTATE THE ECONOMY.
ALL AND NON PROBLEM COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. ALSO
PLEASE UNDER. EDUCATION PROVIDE
CULTURE PROTECTION TO THE
ILLEGAL PLAYING GAINES CARTONS
HAVE BEEN. THIS TO DIRECTLY
TARGETS CHRIST. WELL BEING.
WHAT THE OLDER KIDS FIVE AND TO
BE A ONE FOR EVERY INCLUDING
CRIED. PLEASE NOTE LIVES
DISTURBING BE MADE ONLY BY
LEADERS. CALLING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU CAN FOR YOUR- FOR
CONSIDERING MY- I RESPECTFULLY
ALL SEAC. THANK YOU MISTER OUR
NEXT SPEAKER. HELLO GOOD
MORNING THIS IS A JAMES PEOPLE
AND I AM THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
CALIFORNIA MISSIONS INDIAN
GAMING ASSOCIATION AND WE AS AN
ASSOCIATION STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THIS IS A BILL THAT
SEEKS TO REWARD ALYSSA
PRACTICES AT THE STATE'S
COMMERCIAL FOR PROFIT CARTER.
HIDE BEHIND THE TIME AND THE
AND THE COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS
TO REACH THAT AND- COMMERCIAL
FOR PROFIT INDUSTRY. AGAIN
PENALIZE MORE THAN THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS BY THE FEDERAL
FINANCIAL CRIMES ENFORCEMENT
NETWORK OTHERWISE KNOWN
ATTENTION. FOR FAILURE TO
COMPLY WITH ANTI MONEY
LAUNDERING LAWS AND HIDING
PROFIT SUPPORT TAXES AND NOW AT
THE A SIX WOULD GIVE THE
SERVICE INDUSTRY THE GREEN
LIGHT TO CONTINUE GAMES. THEY
OFFERED ILLEGALLY THIS MAKES NO
SENSE. LIKE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE FELT THE PAIN OF LOSS OF
REVENUE. DUE TO THE CLOSURES OF
OUR BUSINESSES DURING THIS
PANDEMIC WHICH ARE PRIME
REVENUE SOURCES. AND ARE ALSO
STRUGGLING TO FIND OUR OWN
SERVICES. WE SYMPATHIZE WITH
THE STATE TRYING TO FIND
REVENUE SOURCES IN WHICH TO DO
THIS. HOWEVER SCA SIX IS NOT
THE WAY. ON THE STATE SIDE
REVENUE GENERATED BY THIS BILL
WILL LIKELY NOT BE REALIZE
UNTIL LONG AFTER THE CODE THAT
NINETEEN CRISIS HAS PASSED.
RULES WILL HAVE TO BE REVISED
AND A NEW REGULATORY STRUCTURE
WILL NOT BE DONE OVERNIGHT
ESPECIALLY WITH THE NEW ONLINE
COMPONENT. MOREOVER CONTACT THE
TRIES WILL HAVE TO BE
NEGOTIATED RATIFIED AND
APPROVED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
THE INTERIOR FOR THE SPORTS
WAGERING COMPONENTS WELL FOR
ANY TROUBLE REVENUES REALIZE.
BY THE TIME I TO GET ETIQUETTE
FUNDING COMES AND- THE CRISIS
HAD PASSED BUT THE DAMAGE TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WILL REMAIN
AND BE CODIFIED INTO LAW. THIS
IS YET ANOTHER BROKEN AGREEMENT
BETWEEN TRIBES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IF NOT FOR THE COPA
NINETEEN CRISIS AND OVER ONE
WEEK WHICH ALREADY OF THE STATE
IN THE TRIBES WILL BE HERE
TODAY TO SHARE THEIR STRONG
OPPOSITION. THESE READING
LONGER DUE TO VOTE NO. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU. WE
INADVERTENTLY MISSED ONE
PROPONENT. NO OKAY. WERE WE'RE
GOOD SO THANK YOU GERMAN AS THE
PRIMARY SPEAKERS WE'RE GOING TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED. SEEING NONE
WE WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
THERE IS NO ONE THERE. AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO THE MODERATOR
ANYONE ELSE ONLINE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE AN OPPOSE POSITION
ON SCA SIX- PLEASE RESERVE YOUR
COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION
WE'VE HAD OUR SPEAKERS SO
PLEASE OF THERE'S ANYONE
ONLINE. MODERATOR TAKEOVER.
THANK YOU WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
GIVE ONE ZERO INSTRUCTIONS IF
YOU'D LIKE TO QUEUE UP TO VOICE
OPPOSITION. WE'LL GO FIRST TO
LINE UP FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FOUR FIVE TWO FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PAM LOPEZ BUT KATE TREAT
CONSULTING ON BEHALF OF THE
RING CONN BAND OF THE PENA
INDIA. THAT TRULY RIVER TRIED
AND DRY CREEK RANCHERIA IN
OPPOSITION. SH SH SH. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE UP FIVE HUNDRED
AND ONE FIVE ZERO ONE YEAR ONE
IS A- HI THIS IS JON MONTHLY
TROUBLED BY THEIR FOR THE
AUGUSTINE BAND OF CAHUILLA
INDIANS. ALL THE THINGS
STRONGLY OPPOSES FTA SIX THANK
YOU. CAROLINE NUMBER FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX FIVE OR
SECURE LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
FRANK MOLINA ON BEHALF SENDING
THIS BAND SHOULD WHICH INDIANS
IN THE SEMINAL BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
WELL LINE FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ONE FIVE FIVE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AS CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S CONFUSION
IN OPPOSITION TO FTA CLICK.
NINE FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
NINE FIVE FOUR NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE FIVE FOUR NINE
CHECK FOR SELF MUTE. HEARING NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
TRIPLE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU THIS IS CAROLINE
BEALE HUNTER WITH WHAT HE
CONSENTS IN AN APPROPRIATE ON
BEHALF OF THE- TODAY HE WENT TO
NATION. WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO FTA SIX. LINE FIVE HUNDRED
IN NINETEEN FIVE ONE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS DENNIS
A LOT OF THE AT THE CLEVELAND
INDIANS WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
FIND FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
FIVE FOUR TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME ORDER. HELLO MY
LAN AND I. WELL MY NAME'S
TERMINATE WANT CALLING ON
BEHALF OF DISABLED AND LOSING A
UNIONS WE ARE CALLING TO
REGISTER OUR STRONG OPPOSITION
SB EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU. AND
WHAT A LINE FIVE HUNDRED LINE
FIVE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WELL IT IS GREGG SERWIS
CHAIRMAN OF THE FEDERATED
INDIANS OF GRATON RANCHERIA
INTERNAL COUNTY AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE MEASURED. S. C. H. SIX.
NINE FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE TWO ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS DAVID KING KHAN ON
BEHALF OF BOTH THE HOUSE BAND
OF CAHUILLA INDIANS. THAT WILL
COME OF UPPER LIKE BROKEN VERY
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
CAROLINE FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR FIVE THREE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS OR ANYTHING LAST TIME
THE STATE PRESIDENT OF THE
EAGLE FORUM OF THE CALIFORNIA.
ALSO RESIDE IN CINEMA COUNTY
AND I AM. WE AS AN ORGANIZATION
ARE VERY OPPOSED TO ANSI C.
THANK YOU. WIND RIDER FORTY ONE.
YOUR. CATALINA CHIKAN FIVE
CHAIR OF THE TRIBAL ALLIANCE A
SOVEREIGN INDIAN NATIONS A
COALITION OF TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS
THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED AT THE
EIGHT SIX. THANK YOU. WIND FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN FIVE
FOUR SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS- GERMAN GROOVY WITH ALL
WILL CALL THE DAY BANDIT QUEEN
INDIANS AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THIS BILL SCA. SIX BUT A LINE
FIVE FIFTY TWO FIVE FIVE TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IS A THOMAS TOWARDS
NEW YEAR. HI CHAIRMAN WHEN THE
TOWARD LIKE UNITY CHEMICAL
UNIONS AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY. WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE HAJJI EIGHTY
SIX THANK. LINE FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE THREE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS AT THE NEW MAP OF ALL
DIRECTOR OF THE- TRIBAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE TWENTY NINE
PALMS SPEND A MISSION INDIANS
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AT THE
AGE SIX. FIND FIVE AND TWELVE
FIVE ONE TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS GONNA CON
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE AND
BANDAGE MASS INDIAN. WE
STRONGLY. RESULT STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THE EIGHT THANK YOUR.
LINE FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE FIVE THREE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I WOULD TREAT ON
BEHALF OF THE COLUSA TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT ASTRON THE OPPOSING
SCA SIX. LINE FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY NINE FIVE FOUR NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WHICH MURKY
TRIBAL COUNCIL YOUNGER BAND OF
THE SINGLE ENGINE. ON BEHALF OF
THE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS. WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE FTA. WE HAVE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE OF
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I
SEE THAT. SECOND. BERMAN
FINANCES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL I SEE NO HANDS GO UP
YOU HAVE A QUESTION MISTER
WHITE COUNTS BECAUSE- YES.
MISTER CHAIR I. I'M CURIOUS
ABOUT THE SECTION THAT REQUIRES
THE TRACK OPERATORS IN INDIAN
TRIBES TO REMAIN 1% OF THEIR
GROSS GAMING REVENUES TO FUND
PROBLEM GAMING- PROGRAMS AND
THEN IT PUTS A CAP ON THAT AT
TEN MILLION DOLLARS AND IT JUST
SEEMS ODD TO ME THAT A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT AS
THAT PUT A CAP ON SOMETHING
THAT WE COULD HAVE MORE GAMING
I DON'T THINK THE PROBLEMS ARE
GOING TO GO AWAY I JUST WITH-
DOT. GET THAT THE OTHER POINT
OF THIS CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT WHICH- CHALLENGES ME
IS THAT THEY COUNTY FEARS ARE
SPECIFICALLY EXCLUDED FROM THIS
OPERATION I WOULD REMIND
MEMBERS. OF BOTH HOUSES THAT WE
HAVE SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE'RE PUTTING INTO
THE BUDGET RELEASED TO. SEND A
PROPOSAL TO HELP OUT THE
COUNTIES WHO ARE HURTING RIGHT
NOW IN SEPT TWO IN THE BUDGET
WE PUT IN FORTY TO FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS SPECIFICALLY TO
HELP UP AFFAIRS. AND IF THIS IS
AN ECONOMIC THIS IS SUPPOSED TO
BE FAIR AND I NEED SEE THERE'S
UP AS HE THEM PROPONENTS BUT WE
SHOULD NOT BE PUTTING UP. AN
AREA OF GOVERNMENT WERE
ACTUALLY DEALING OUT ON A
YEARLY BASIS SO I WOULD HOPE
THAT THE AUTHOR. AND ALL SIDES
WOULD LOOK AT THIS TO SEE HOW
WE CAN HELP OUT THE COUNTY
BECAUSE WE'RE ANTICIPATING
USING THE COUNTY FAIRS. THE ALL
BIRDS SERVICE FOR IRAQI. THINGS
AT THAT IT JUST SEEMS SHORT
SIGHTED IF WE'RE CHANGING THE
CONSTITUTION THAT WE SHOULD NOT
EXCLUDE THEM YOU KNOW THEM. I
KNOW WHAT THEIR PARTICIPATION
IS BUT THERE'S THE TO SPECIFIC
EXCLUSION SO I WOULD URGE SOME
ATTENTION AT THAT. AND I'M SURE
FOR THE AUTHOR SO. AT HOME
RIVETED TO THIS HERE AND IF
NOT- MARK TOOK NOTE AND WILL.
FOR THAT COMMENT ON TO MISTER
DODD. SO THANK YOU FOR THAT-
WITH NO FURTHER. QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AC SCA SIX
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MISTER
JONES. YOU HAVE WAIVED
PRESENTATIONS. ON YOUR FIRST
BILL I BELIEVE. ARE YOU
PRESENTING YOU'RE PRESENTING AT
TEN TWENTY FOUR YOU'RE WAITING
ON EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT SB EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT
IS A SUSPENSE CAP EIGHT. ANYONE
IN THE ROOM HERE ON EIGHT SEVEN
EIGHT I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
ANYBODY FOR TWELVE FORTY. IN
ROOM TWELVE FORTY NO ONE'S
THERE ANYONE ONLINE. THANK YOU
UP ON SB EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT IT
IS ONE AND THEN ZERO. NO ONE IS
GOING UP AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT LACKEY HAVE WILL GO TO
THE OPPOSITION IS ANYBODY
OPPOSED EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT IN
THIS ROOM NOW AND TWENTY FORTY.
THEY DIDN'T CHANGE MY SCREEN.
THERE'S NO ONE THERE ANYBODY
ONLINE TO OPPOSE SB EIGHT SEVEN
EIGHT. ONE NINE ZERO TO PUT
YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE WE DO
HAVE ONE IT IS LINE FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX FIVE SIX
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I HAVE.
KAREN RAIL- CAN YOU OPPOSED.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE IS THAT WAS
THE ONE PERSON. ONE PERSON
THAT'S AT ALL RIGHT SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP- THE PART IN A
FINANCE. DOES NOT HAVE A FILE
ON THIS BILL SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB EIGHT
SEVEN EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
IS TO JONES PRESENT SB TEN
TWENTY FOUR YOU DO UNDERSTAND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE. CANDIDATE
AND SO. I HOPE YOU WILL BE
SUCCINCT THANK YOU SIR. YEAH I
DID WANT TO PRESENT- AS SENATE
BILL TEN TWENTY FOUR WHICH
CREATES- REGISTRATION PROGRAM
FOR COMPETITION OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLES. CURRENTLY COMPETITION
OPERATE. OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLES
ARE REGISTERED TO CARBS
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
RED STICKER PROGRAM HOWEVER
CARP HAS DECIDED TO INTO THEIR
PROGRAM IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WITH NO PLAN TO REPLACE IT.
WITHOUT IT PROGRAM OFFERS
PREVIOUS COMPETITION AND
PRACTICE WRITING WILL BE PUT TO
AN- CALIFORNIA. ADDITIONALLY
SIGNIFICANT REVENUES FROM THE
REGISTRATION PROGRAM WILL BE
LOST. THESE REVENUES FUND THE
HOWCALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
THE MOTOR VEHICLES. THE OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE WRECK ATION PRO.
LOCALLY ON A MUSIC RELY SUPPORT
FOR THEIR REVENUE INTAKE. IN
ORDER TO SAVE A BELOW SPORT
WITH HIS. CALIFORNIA THIS BILL
A REPLY REG AND- UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF. THE BILL INCLUDE
REGISTRATION THAT COVERS ALL
COSTS OF THE PROGRAM. THIS NEW
PROGRAM HAS BEEN CRAFTED IN
COLLABORATION WITH A VARIETY OF
STAKE HOLDERS INCLUDING THE
AFFECTED GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
AND THE HOP OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE
COMMUNITY. I BELIEVE I HAVE A
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I DON
AMADOR FROM THE COALITION OF
PUBLIC ACCESS. YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN. PLEASE RETIREMENT IN
MEMBERS COMMITTEE. GO AHEAD MY
NAME IS BONNIE HAMMER. OR ARE
WE GOOD YES. YEAH MY NAME IS
DONNA AMADOR TO REPRESENT THE
COALITION FOR PUBLIC ACCESS WE
HAVE WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH
THE LEGISLATURE IN STAKEHOLDERS
I KNOW WE SHOULD BE ISSUES THAT
ALLOW BOB I WOULD BE A COOL
RECREATION TO CONTINUE ARE
PUTTING IN PLACE ENVIRONMENTAL
AND CULTURAL PROTECTIONS. WE
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP OF
SENATOR JEFF. AND SUPPORTING
AND TOWARD THE FOR ALLOWABLE
IMPORTANT RECREATIONAL SPORT
ONE THAT IS CRITICAL THE LOCAL
ECONOMIES MANUFACTURES AND
CALIFORNIANS WHO CAN BE
RESPONSIBLE IN CALIFORNIA TO
CONTINUE. BEEN WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS FOR MORE THAN A
YEAR. THE TRANSITION OF THE CAR
RED STICKER PROGRAM TO A
CALIFORNIA PARKS COMPETITIVE
STICKER IS SMART FOR REGULATORY
MANAGEMENT AND ECONOMIC
REASONS. WE ASK THAT SB TEN
TWENTY FOUR RECEIVED CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION AS WE MOVE
FORWARD FROM SUSPENSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- ANY OTHER SPEAKERS
IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT SEEING
NONE ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEING NONE. ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE. IN SUPPORT. LIKE TO
IF YOU LIKE TO OPEN SUPPORT
IT'S ONE NINE ZERO AND IT'S SB
TEN TWENTY FOUR. I WANNA MAKE
YOU AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM. OPPOSED
SEEING NONE ANYBODY IN TEN
FORTY. THREE TWENTY FORTY. NOW
ANYBODY ONLINE OPPOSED TO SB
TEN TWENTY FOUR. ONE NINE ZERO
TO VOICE OPPOSITION FROM THE
PHONES. NO ONE IS IN THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT- COMING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE WE HAVE
THE COMMENTS FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE
A FILE. IS TO JONES WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE REAL BRIEFLY SIR
IN CLOSING SB TEN TWENTY FOUR
WILL CREATE A REPLACEMENT
REGISTRATION PROGRAM FOR
COMPETITION OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLES SO THAT THE SPORT AND
THE LARGE REVENUE STREAMS CAN
CONTINUE IN CALIFORNIA WHEN IT
COMES UP SUSPENSE I LOOK
FORWARD EVERYONE'S AYE VOTE.
OUR TEAM QUESTIONS FROM.MY
COLLAR WITHOUT OBJECTION- SB
TEN TWENTY FOUR WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE. SB TWELVE OH TWO. IS
ALSO OF THE BILL AUTHORED BY
MISTER JONES ANY OF WAY
HERE IN SUPPORT ON TWELVE OO TO.
SEEING NONE ANYBODY IN FROM
TWENTY FORTY SEEING NONE SIR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE. ONE IN
ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT. NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE SIR. ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
TO OPPOSE SEEN NOBODY ANYBODY
IN TWENTY. FORTY OPPOSING NO
ONE ANYONE ON THE LINE OPPOSED
SB TWELVE OH TWO. ONE NINE ZERO
TO PUT YOURSELF INTO THE KILL.
BUT AGAIN NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
ALL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NO
COMMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWELVE OH TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING TO MOSTAR TO
LET US BILLS HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION ALL THREE WE HAVE
SB EIGHT NINETY FIVE SIR ANYONE
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHT NINETY FIVE ON ENERGY
ZERO EMISSIONS. SEEING NO RUSH
OF THRONG TO THE- MICROPHONE WE
WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NO CROWDS THERE WE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE IS THERE ANYONE
IN SUPPORT ONLINE FOR A SB.
EIGHT NINETY FIVE. VOICE
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT NINETY
FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT THIS IS
A FEW OF ONE MINUTE QUEUING UP.
WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE FIVE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU TURN SENATORS JENNIFER
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN COALITION
AND THE COURT THANK YOU. THAT
WAS THE ONLY ONE IN THE QUEUE.
ALL RIGHT COMING BACK TO THIS
ROOM FOR OPPOSITION. TO EIGHT
NINETY FIVE THERE'S NOBODY HERE
HOW BOUT IN THE OTHER ROOM.
THERE'S NOBODY THERE IS ANYBODY
ONLINE. ONE NINE ZERO TO VOICE
OPPOSITION. NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
NO OPPOSITION AND FINANCE SAYS
HE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS
BILL I SEE NO HANDS FOR MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHT
NINETY FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
SB NINE OH SEVEN WHICH IS ON
CHILD ABUSE INVESTIGATION- IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM
SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF SB NINE OH
SEVEN SEEING NO ONE IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE OTHER ROOM SEEING
NOW ON IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE. ONE MINISTER OFFER
SUPPORT OF SB NINE OH SEVEN.
WHEN IN FACT THE NUMBER OF. NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION. SB NINE OH SEVEN.
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM ANYBODY IN
THE OTHER ROOM. SIR ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE OPPOSING SB NINE OH
SEVEN. PROPOSED SB NINE OH
SEVEN HAVE YOUR VOICE HEARD YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND THERE IS TO. ALL
RIGHT LET'S SEE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL I SEE NO HANDS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB NINE OH SEVEN.
GOES TO SUSPENSE SB ELEVEN
FIFTY SIX ALSO BY MR ARCHULETA.
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE HE'S
WAY PRESENTATION IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM
PRESENTING- SUPPORT FOR SB
ELEVEN FIFTY SIX SEEING NONE
ANYONE IN THE OTHER ROOM.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN FIFTY SIX. THE PLACE
YOU'RE WROTE PLACER WORK FOR
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE IS
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE. ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION ANYBODY HERE
NOBODY'S OPPOSED HOW ABOUT THE
OTHER ROOM. NO ONE'S THERE
ANYBODY ONLINE OPPOSED SB
ELEVEN FIFTY SIX. ONE NINE ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION. NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE. ALL RIGHT THERE'S NO
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ITEM MY
COLLEAGUES ARE RAISING HANDS SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ELEVEN
FIFTY SIX. IS GOING TO SUSPEND
MISTER WHITE COW SKI IS
PRESENTING. SB NINE OH EIGHT
WHICH IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
SO. PLEASE BE SUCCINCT AT NOT
MR CHERRY SELDOM PRESENT ON A
ITEMS COMING SURPRISE HE JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT THE ANALYSIS
SAYS THAT THE COST OF YOUR HIGH
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL MEMBERS KNOW THAT THAT
THEY'LL BE RECOUP BY THE FEES
THAT THE LICENSE HE'S- THAT
THAT DO DEBT COLLECTING. AND I
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION I AM RELATIVELY.
CLOSE WITH THE DEBT COLLECTION
AND DEBT BUYING INDUSTRIES ON
THAT I WOULD URGE- THIS ONE
BILL THAT I HAVE IN THE
COMMITTEE TO MOVE FORWARD FROM
SUSPENSE. THAT ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU FOR THAT IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT. IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE OTHER ROOM IN
SUPPORT. THIRTY ONE ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
AWAIT. TÔI SUPPORT IN A PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE IS NO ONE IN THE QUEUE.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE ONE SPEAKER
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE. TAKE IT
AWAY- MEMBERS- MIKE BELOVED
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CREDITORS BAR
ASSOCIATION FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF
AND MEMBERS FOR WORKING SO HARD
TO GET PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN
THESE A DIFFICULT TIMES- WE
HAVE HAD PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH CENTER WHAT
KOWSKI. WE ARE AT FOUR AND IT.
LAWYER WHO REPRESENT CLIENTS IN
COLLECTING DEBT OF THAT IS
OBVIOUSLY A POLICY ISSUE ON THE
FISCAL ISSUE FACING THE
COMMITTEE- YOUR ANALYSIS
SUGGESTS COSTS IN THE MILLIONS
TO TENS OF MILLIONS. AT SOME
POINT THAT WILL BE OFFSET BY
FEES I AGREE BUT WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS MAKING A MUCH
MUCH BIGGER PROGRAM AND IT
NEEDS TO BE THE LAWYERS THAT
REPRESENT REPRESENT CLIENTS THE
AND COLLECT DEBT WHETHER IT'S
CONSUMER DEBT CHILD SUPPORT
DEBT CONTRACT DEBT YOU NAME IT.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO RENDER THIS
THEY ALREADY PAY HI OF USED TO
THE STATE BAR 4% THE SAME
FUNCTION BUT YOU WILL HAVE MORE
RICHEST BORN MORE LICENSEES.
AND CAUGHT I'M MORE EMPLOYEES
TO DO PUT. FOR A SAME PEOPLE
THE SAME FUNCTION SO AGAIN WE
WOULD RENEW A REQUEST BURNINGS
AND OTHER WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU SEE
NO ONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED IS THERE ANYONE IN.
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE
THERE IS THERE ANYONE ONLINE
WHO IS SUPPOSED TO BE NOT NO
EIGHT. PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME PLACE YOURSELF IN THE
QUEUE WE DO HAVE TO ALREADY IN
Q. WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO. NINE
FIVE SIX TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO TURN NUMBERS GOING DOWN
SAYS RECORDING KAISER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THE WHAT DO I NUMBER
SIX HUNDRED AND ONE SIX ZERO
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS
FEELING AS NINE SIX ZERO ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE CHECK
TO ENSURE THAT YOU'RE NOT MUTED.
HEARING NO RESPONSE WILL GO TO
LINE FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETY
FOUR ONE FIVE NINE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MELANIE CREATED FOR
THE CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION WE REMAIN OPPOSED
ON LIKE AMENDED CONDITION. A
GROWING NUMBER OF THE COMMENTS
OF MY AND MY COLLEAGUE MICHAEL
LOCAL FOR ME AND IN THE CURRENT
PURPLE BALL WAY. VIED FOR
ADDITIONAL REGULATIONS AND
COVERAGE OF OUR MEMBER
INSTITUTIONS WERE ALREADY.
THANK YOU CAN WRITE IT IN THEIR
OWN RIGHT AND WOULD NOT BE
PAYING IT RIGHT THANK YOU FOR
THAT STRUCTURE I'M PEOPLE FOR
THE- PARTY ABOUT. THE AUTHOR
BARNEY RAGE AND COMING A. THANK
YOU. AND THEY IS NO ONE FURTHER
INTO AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL MR
CASKEY ELECTED KLAY RESPOND
ANYTHING NOW YOU'RE GOOD ALL
RIGHT SEEING NO COMMENTS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. ON
TO MS HE WAS BILLS AND SHE HAS
GRACIOUSLY WAY PRESENTATION
THANK YOU MS LEYVA SB NINE
FIFTEEN. ON MOBILE HOME PARK
EMERGENCY RELIEF IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM AND SUPPORT
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE OTHER ROOM. SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE. ONE
IN ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF INTO
THE KILL SB NINE FIFTEEN. WE DO
HAVE ONE THAT IS TEARING UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. BUT A LINE
NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
NINE FIVE FIVE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS CHRIS FOR
SAKE WITH THE WEST FOR
MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION- WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL- WE
HAVE POLICY CONCERNS BUT WE
ALSO HAVE CISCO CONCERNS. THERE
REALLY T<C.CYAN> AND SAID HOW H. D.</C>
D. IS GOING TO PAY FOR SOME OF
THE INSPECTIONS THAT. ARE GOING
TO BE COMING AT THEM SO. WITH
DUE RESPECT- WE'RE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS LEGISLATION.
AND THERE IS NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE ARRIVED. THAT WAS NINE
FIFTEEN RIGHT DID SUPPORT. AND
OPPOSITION OKAY- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE.
ALSO WORK BUT HE CAN'T HOLD IT
DOWN HE DIDN'T DO IT BECAUSE IF
YOU DO THAT. OKAY CONFUSE ME
YEAH I GOT CONFUSED THANK YOU
GUYS HI IS ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
WAS OPPOSE. ANYBODY IN THE
OTHER ROOM OPPOSE. ANYONE ON
THE PHONE OPPOSE. ONE I WAS
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION I THOUGHT I
WAS ON THE RIGHT TRACK. NO ONE
IS GOING UP. ALL RIGHT THE
FARMER FINANCES NOT HAVE A FILE
ON THIS BILL AND SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB NINE FIFTEEN WILL GO THE
SUSPENSE. SB TWELVE THIRTEEN
ALSO IS LEYVA IS ON HISTORY
SOCIAL SCIENCE ACADEMIC CONTENT.
IS THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
OTHER ROOM. SIR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT. OF TWELVE
THIRTY ONE THEIR OFFER SUPPORT.
NO ONE IS DOING UP IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT OPPOSITION
ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM KNOW
ANYBODY IN TWENTY FORTY KNOW
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE. IN
OPPOSITION OPPOSITION ONE ZERO
THE TWELVE THIRTEEN. NO ONE IS
GOING UP. ALL RIGHT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NOT
HAVE A FILE I SEE NO HANDS GO
UP SO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWELVE THIRTEEN WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE MISTER DALI HAS TWO
BILLS CITIES WAY PRESENTATION
ON SB NINE TWENTY TWO. ANYBODY
IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE TWENTY TWO ON A
RELINQUISHMENT. SEEING NO ONE
IN THE OTHER ROOM SEEING NONE
ON THE PHONE. SUPPORT OF. ONE
NINE TWO ZERO NINE TWENTY ONE.
YOUR OF ONE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. A LITTLE AYE
NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN FIVE ONE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN CAMILLE HOLD GRASS
VALLEY. I SUPPORT. THAT WAS THE
ONLY ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHTIS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM NO IN THE OTHER ROOM NO
OPPOSITION ON THE LINE. ONE AND
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. AND THERE
IS NO ONE IN Q. AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE- SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT A PHYSICIAN
SB NINE TWENTY ONE GO TO
SUSPENSE. SB NINE EIGHTY NINE.
ON SIERRA NEVADA CONSERVANCY
SUPPORT THIS ROOM NONE SUPPORT
IN THE OTHER ROOM NINE SUPPORT
ONLINE. FOR ANYONE IN YOUR OWN
EIGHTY NINE. THEN WE'RE GONNA
GO TO LINE NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTEEN FIVE ONE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EMAIL HOLD.
I'M BASS ALLEY. WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE MORE QUEUING UP PLEASE
ALLOW US MOMENT. WELL THE LINE
SIX HUNDRED AND SEVEN SIX ZERO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS PAUL
MASON WITH THE CIVIC FOREST
TRUST THIS ONE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR SB NINE EIGHTY NINE
IN THE EFFORT TO EXPAND THE
JURISDICTION OF THE AMERICAN
CURRENCY. THANK YOU. PANEL GOAL
LINE NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE SEVEN ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OUR CARLA ON
BEHALF THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
IN TOWN LIMITED BECAUSE OF THE
CELL. AND WITH THAT WE HAVE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE. ALL RIGHT
ANY OPPOSITION TO NINE EIGHTY
NINE SEEING NONE IN THIS ROOM
THE OTHER ROOM. ON THE PHONE.
ONE NINE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
NO ONE SHOWING UP AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT BERMAN FINANCES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL AND
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB NINE EIGHTY NINE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO
MISS CHIANG SPILLS- SB NINE
TWENTY TWO. ON CRIMINAL
PROCEDURES IS THERE ANY SUPPORT
IN THIS ROOM. FOR NINE TWENTY
TWO. SCENE NINE ANY SUPPORT IN
THE OTHER ROOM SAYING NINE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE. ONE AND
ZERO FOR SUPPORT. NO ONE
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT ANY OPPOSITION IN THIS
ROOM SAYING NOT ANY OPPOSITION
IN THE OTHER ROOM SEEING NINE
ANY OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE TO
SB NINE TWENTY TWO. PROPOSITION
TO NINE TWENTY TWO IT'S ONE
THEN ZERO. THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES
ALL RIGHTS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE RAISED THEIR HANDS SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB NINE
TWENTY TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SB NINE FORTY THREE BY MISH
CHIANG ON PAID FAMILY LEAVE IN
RESPONSE THE COVERED- IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT.
ANYBODY IN THE OTHER ROOM.
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT
OF NINE FORTY THREE. SUPPORT OF
NINE FORTY THREE IT'S ONE THEN
ZERO. AND THERE IS NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE. ALL RIGHT NOW WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION ANYBODY IN THIS
ROOM. ANYBODY IN THE OTHER ROOM.
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE FORTY
THREE. ONE NINE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NO OPPOSITION ON THE
AUDIO LINES ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES ONE
TELL US SOMETHING ABOUT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
BILL AT THIS TIME BUT WE KNOW
THAT THE FISCAL IMPACT OF THIS
BILL- THE RESULT IN IGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND COSTS. OF
POTENTIALLY IN EXCESS OF THE
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THE
BILL DOES REQUIRE BENEFITS TO
BE PAID FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
A AND AS A POINT OF REFERENCE
IN TWENTY NINETEEN THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT PROCESS OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND.
EIGHT FAMILY LEAVE CLAIMS AND
PAID NINE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
BENEFITS. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU- IN NOVEMBER. HER
MIKE MOLLY HOLLY. BUT AS WE GET.
BUT A LITTLE LITTLE BIT BACK.
WE WILL. OKAY SIGNAL COMING
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB NINE FORTY THREE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MS BATES
HAS SB NINE THIRTY FOUR. WHICH
SHE IS WAIVE PRESENTATION AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM ON SB NINE
THIRTY FOUR SEEING NINE ANYONE
IN THE OTHER ROOM. SEEING NONE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE. ONE NINE
ZERO. NO ONE COMING UP IN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT ANY
OPPOSITION. AND NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM ANYBODY IN THE OTHER ROOM
OPPOSED. THE NINE THIRTY FOUR.
SCENE NINE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
OPPOSED TO NINE THIRTY FOUR.
ONE NINE ZERO TO SHOW
OPPOSITION. AND NO ONE IS
COMING UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS
BILL ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
RAISED THEIR HAND. MS FACES SB
NINE THIRTY FOUR WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION
MISTER NIELSEN HAS SB NINE
FIFTY TWO ON THE ELECTRICAL
RESOURCES AND TAXES- IS THERE
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT
OF NINE FIFTY TWO SEEING NINE
ANYONE IN THE OTHER ROOM.
SEEING NONE ANYONE ON THE PHONE.
SHOW SUPPORT IT'S ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE
LINE SHOWING UP ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. WHAT I'M GONNA GO TO
LINE FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT FIVE FOUR EIGHT ONE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
I WAS THE ONLY ONE KEEP UP
SUPPORT SIR ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION ANYBODY IN THIS
ROOM. SEEING NONE ANYONE IN THE
OTHER ROOM SEEING NONE ANYONE
ONLINE WHO WAS SUPPOSED TO SB
NINE FIFTY TWO. ONE NINE ZERO
TO QUEUE UP. NO ONE SHOWING UP
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL I SEE
NO HANDS GO UP SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB NINE FIFTY TWO
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
TO MS JACKSON. SHE'S WAY
PRESENTATION ON HER BILL
STARTING WITH SB. NINE FIFTY
SIX. SB NINE FIFTY SIX. IS A
CALIFORNIA TAX EXPENDITURE
REVIEW BOARD ANYBODY IN THIS
ROOM IN SUPPORT. SEEING NONE
ANYONE IN THE OTHER ROOM IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE ANYBODY. ON
THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
FIFTY SIX. TO SHOW SUPPORT IT'S
ONE AND ZERO TWO A COUPLE
QUEUING UP WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
TWO FIVE SIX TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. REMEMBER CATALINA SANCHEZ
THE CARBON IN KAISER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION. BONTA THAN A DRUNK
THE PART OF SB NINE FIVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND WILL ALSO GO
TO LINE NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND
NINETY NINE THAT'S FIVE NINE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
KATIE HARD TO KNOW WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE COURT. AND THOSE ARE
THE ONLY TWO IN QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT GOING
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO ONE IN
OUR ROOM IN A OPPOSE ANYBODY IN
THE OTHER ROOM. SEEING NO ONE
THERE IS THERE ANYONE ON LINE
WHO WAS OPPOSED SB. NINE FIFTY
SIX. AND AGAIN THAT'S ONE THEN
ZERO. THE OPPOSITION ON THE
AUDIO LINES ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL AND
NONE OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE
RAISING THEIR HANDS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB. NINE FIVE SIX HAS
GONE TWO SUSPECTS. SB NINE
SEVENTY THREE ALSO BY MS
JACKSON IS AN EMPLOYER'S ANNUAL
REPORT HAITI THAT- BILL AND IS
THERE SUPPORT IN THIS ROOM FOR
NINE SEVENTY THREE. I DON'T SEE
ANY IS YOUR SUPPORT IN THE
OTHER ROOM NONE SIR ANYBODY ON
THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SEVENTY THREE. THAT WOULD BE
ONE MINUTE ZERO TO PLACE
YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE FOR
SUPPORT. AND NO ONE IN SECURING
UP AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION IS THEIR
OPPOSITION NOT IN THIS ROOM.
ANYBODY IN THE OTHER ROOM.
ANYBODY ONLINE OPPOSED TO SB
NINE SEVEN THREE. THAT'S ONE
AND ZERO SHOP POSITION. THERE
IS ALSO NO OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME ON THE AUDIO LINES ALL
RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL MY
COLLEAGUES DO NOT HAVE THEIR
ARMS UP SO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
NINE SEVENTY THREE. THOSE TWO
SUSPENSE FOR MOVING ON TO SB
TEN SIXTY NINE ON
TELECOMMUNICATIONS FOR ANYONE
IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT OF TEN
SIXTY NINE. SEEING NONE ANYONE
IN THE OTHER ROOM. SAYING NINE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT
OF TEN SIXTY NINE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME TO
SHOW UP SURE SHOWS SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL. WE DO HAVE ONE
THAT'S COMING UP ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. WELL I NUMBER SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE SIX TWO
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR
ARE TALKING ABOUT HER BUSINESS
IN OPPOSITION TO. NINE THANK
YOU. THAT WAS THE ONLY ONE IN
WHICH YOU ALL RIGHT DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE
NO ONE IS RAISE THEIR HANDS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TEN SIXTY
NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. ALSO BY
MISS JACKSON DEALING WITH
EMPLOYEES TIME OFF ANYBODY IN
THIS ROOM. HERE ON THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE. THERE'S NO
SUPPORT HERE HOW ABOUT THE NEXT
ROOM NO ONE STANDING UP THERE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE.
AND IT'S ONE AND ZERO TO PLACE
YOURSELF AND TO KILL. WE DO OF
ONE IT'S FROM THE LINE SIX
HUNDRED AND THREE SIX ZERO
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS STRUCK IN ROWS ON
BEHALF OF THE CHANGE IN SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. NO OTHERS
IN Q. IT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT IS
THERE OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM. THEIR OPPOSITION IN THE
OTHER ROOM. SEEING NONE IS
THERE OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
TO SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE.
ONE NINE ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF
INTO THE KILL. I DO HAVE ONE
THAT'S JUST CUED UP. CAROLINE
SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX TWO
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS CHRIS FOR SAKE WITH WESTERN
MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. NO OTHERS INTO AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT BERMAN THE
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL NO ONE'S RAISE THEIR
HANDS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. WE HAVE MISTER
MINING NEXT SB NINE SEVEN SEVEN.
HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS
CONSOLIDATION IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN SUPPORT. IN THE OTHER
ROOM. ON THE PHONE. ONE NINE
ZERO PLACE YOURSELF FROM THE
QUEUE. I DO HAVE A COUPLE THAT
JUST CUED UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
FOR A LINE OF FIVE HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR FIVE FOUR FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DIANA DOUGLAS
WITH HEALTH ACT OF CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SEVEN SEVEN THANK YOU. I'M ALSO
GOING TO LINE FIVE HUNDRED AND
NINETY FIVE FIVE NINE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HAPPENING TURN
MEMBERS JENNY THOUGHT ON BEHALF
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TOPIC.
FONT ABOUT THE NINE SEVEN SEVEN
IN SUPPORT. NO OTHERS INTO AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT IS THERE
OPPOSITION THE SB NINE SEVEN
SEVEN NOBODY IN THIS ROOM HOW
ABOUT THE OTHER ROOM. HOW ABOUT
ONLINE. SB NINE SEVEN SEVEN
EIGHT YOURSELF. THANK YOU ONE
AND ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF IN A
QUEUE IN OPPOSITION. RIGHT
LOOKS LIKE WE ARE NOW HAVING A
FEW PEOPLE QUEUE UP ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO LINE SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR THAT'S
SIX TWO FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON WORK ON BEHALF
OF PETE THE PRIVATE ESSENTIAL
ACCESS COMMUNITY HOSPITALS AND
THEN HELP AND ONE MELINDA
UNIVERSITY HEALTH IN OPPOSITION.
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIX HUNDRED IN
TWO SIX ZERO TWO YEAR ONCE OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
SHARE HEARST CALLING IN TODAY
ON BEHALF OF TO CALL IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS AS WELL THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICTS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. MOVING ONLINE SIX FOUR SIX
ZERO FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEX HAWTHORN
BUT HE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. LINE
SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR SIX
THREE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BUT
MY NAME IS FRED NOTE WHERE
REPRESENTING STANFORD
HEALTHCARE ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
LINE SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT SIX TO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HIS MERE MORTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
AND WITH THAT WE'VE EXHAUSTED
THE QUEUE OF OPPOSITION. ALL
RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS
BILL NO HANDS OF GONE UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB NINE SEVEN
SEVEN. HAS GONE TO SUSPENSE MR
UMBERG HAS THREE BILLS HE'S WAY
PRESENTATIONS FIRST ONE IS SB.
MY FATHER WAS OUT OF ORDER. ALL
RIGHT THE CARD HOLDER HERE. THE
NINE EIGHTY IS THE NEXT ONE SB
NINE EIGHTY BY MR UMBERG SIR
ANYONE HERE IT'S ON DNA TESTING
ANYBODY HERE IN SUPPORT. OF
NINE EIGHTY. ANYBODY IN THE
OTHER ROOM KNOWN ANYBODY ONLINE.
NO ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE DO HAVE ONE IN THE QUEUE
IT'S NINE FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO FIVE SIX TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M NOT GONNA
LET. ME AND SAYS. WHAT CARBON
AND HARD ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND WITH
THAT WE HAVE NO ONE LEFT IN Q.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION SB NINE EIGHTY IN
THIS ROOM. IN THE OTHER ROOM.
ANYBODY ONLINE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB NINE EIGHTY. ONE NINE ZERO
TO PLACE YOURSELF THAT YOU. WE
HAVE ONE THAT JUST ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
JUST WAITING FOR A LINE
NUMBER READ ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
READ IT ONLINE SIX HUNDRED AND
FORTY EIGHT SIX FOUR EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. Q. DENNIS SLOW
COOKER THE UNITED HOUSE
CONCENTRAION IN OPPOSITION TO
NINE SEVEN SEVEN THANK YOU. NO
ONE ELSE IN THE AUDIO KILL.
NUMBER NINE EIGHTY- DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB NINE EIGHTY WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE SB ELEVEN NINETY
SIX. ALSO BY MR UMBERG ON PRICE
GOUGING ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF ELEVEN NINETY SIX
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP ANYBODY
IN THE OTHER ROOM. SEEING NO
ONE THERE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE.
ON THE PHONE IT'S ONE AND ZERO
TO PUT YOURSELF INTO THE QUEUE.
BUT A LINE FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO FIVE SIX TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CATALINA
DOWN TO THE COMPANY HI THERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION AND
THE PART OF THAT THE ELEVEN
NINETY SIX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WELL LINE NUMBER SIX
HUNDRED AND TWELVE SIX ONE TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BRIAN
SHERMAN WITH RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION IMPORT.
ABOUT ONE LATECOMER THE JUST
CUED UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THOSE LATE COMERS WATCH OUT.
LINE SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE
SIX FOUR NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE COLD WAR LIMÓN ON BEHALF
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. AND
WITH THAT WE'VE RUN OUT OF THE
QUEUE. ALL RIGHT IS THERE
OPPOSITION. TO ELEVEN NINETY
SIX. NO ONE HERE ANYONE IN THE
OTHER ROOM. ANYONE ELSE ONLINE
WANT TO SPEAK ON ELEVEN NINETY
SIX. ONE IN ZERO TO PLACE
YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE. NO ONE
IS COMING UP AT THIS TIME SIR
BERMAN FINANCES NOT HAVE A FILE
MY COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE THEIR
ARMS UP. WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
ELEVEN NINETY SIX WILL GO THE
SUSPENSE WILL BE TWELVE TWENTY
MR UMBERG ON PEACE AND
CUSTODIAL OFFICERS. IS THERE
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT IN THIS ROOM.
IN THE OTHER ROOM. ON THE PHONE.
ONE IN ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF
FROM THE QUEUE WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIX TWELVE SIX ONE TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SIX ONE TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN CHECK FOR SELF ME
PLEASE. BLAINE SHERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
AND OPPOSITION TO. THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU. SOMEONE ELSE INTO IT
THIS TIME. THAT WAS THE SUPPORT
SIDE RIGHT. IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION AT TWELVE TWENTY IN
THIS ROOM. IN THE OTHER ROOM.
ANYMORE OPPOSITION ONLINE
ANYBODY WANT TO SPEAK ON TWELVE
TWENTY. ONE NINE ZERO TO PLACE
YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE. KNOWING
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME BERMAN
FINANCES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL MY COLLEAGUES ON HAVE
THEIR HANDS UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWELVE TWENTY WILL
GO TO SUSPEND SIR MOVING ON TO
MISS ATKINS. AS TWO BILLS- SHE
IS WAY PRESENTATION FIRST ONE
IS SB NINE NINE FIVE WHICH IS
ON ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP
BACKED. TWENTY ONE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION ACTION ME
ANYBODY IN THE OTHER ROOM.
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE. ONE IN
HERE TO PLACE YOURSELF INTO THE
QUEUE. LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE
SOME THAT ARE JUST COMING UP
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WE'RE GOING.
REGULAR LINE SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SIX FIVE ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CARE OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF PASADENA
THE COURT THE BILL. WELL NOW
THE LINE NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY FOUR FOUR NINE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS THE ONLY GATHERED WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT. ALONG THE
LINE NUMBER SIX HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN SIX ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LIMITS CHAIR MEMBERS
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO IN SUPPORT. ON THE LINE
NUMBER FIVE HUNDRED AND EIGHT
FIVE ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STILL BE
FERRARI ON BEHALF OF FACEBOOK
AND SUPPORT. LINE FIVE HUNDRED
AND. FOURTEEN I'M SURE WHAT THE
BAY AREA HOUSING- THE KEY
ADVOCACY COALITION IN SUPPORT.
AN ONLINE SIX HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO SIX TWO TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY QUEST
REPRESENTING INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES IN SUPPORT. I WENT THAT
WE'VE EXHAUSTED THE SUPPORT Q.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO NINE NINE FIVE IN
THIS ROOM. SEEING NONE IN THE
OTHER ROOM. SEEING NONE ON THE
PHONE OPPOSITION TO NINE NINE
FIVE. ONE NINE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AND THERE IS NO
AUDIO OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT SEEING THEIR HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB NINE
NINE FIVE OF THE SUSPENSE THREE
ON THE WEST FEEL OF AND LOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAD NO
FILE- SB NINE NINE FIVE DOES
THE SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION
MOVING TO SB ELEVEN TWENTY ALSO
BY MS ATKINS ON SUBDIVISIONS.
AND TENTATIVE MAPS SIR SUPPORT
IN THIS ROOM. IN THE OTHER ROOM.
ON THE PHONE. SUPPORT FOR SB
ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT ZERO. WE'LL
GO TO LINE FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINETY FOUR FOUR NINE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONCE AGAIN GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS KELLY GOT
RICK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT IF YOU. A LINE FIVE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN FIVE ONE
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I DIDN'T
EVEN THROW AT THE BAY AREA
HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION
SUPPORT THANK. LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY SIX TWO NINE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BOB NAYLOR
REPRESENTING FIELDS SAID IN
COMPANY AN ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS BILL. AND NEXUS LINE FIVE
HUNDRED AND EIGHT FIVE ZERO
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTERNOON THIS IS STILL THE-
FERRARI ON THE APP'S FACEBOOK
IN SUPPORT. AND LINE SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE SIX FIVE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBERS THOSE
AND NOT AND NOT REALLY HAVE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF AT HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIAN B. AND A
THREE PIECE COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THEY HAVE A
COUPLE MORE THAT JUST CUED UP
PLEASE ALLOW MOMENT. BLOODLINE
SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR SIX
FIVE FOUR. NEVER MIND IT LOOKS
LIKE THEY REMOVE THEMSELVES
FROM THE QUEUE. THERE ARE FREE
COUPON LINE SIX FIVE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SIX FIVE FOUR AM
SEEIN BACKGROUND NOISE SO I
KNOW YOUR LINES OPEN YOU CAN
SPEAK. AND THEY HAVE DROPPED
OFF THE CONFERENCE. GOT ONE
MORE THAT SECURED UP WITH AN
OPERATOR WERE LITTLE LINE
NUMBER SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SIX SIX FIVE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FIVE FIFTY MEADOW IN THE
DAIRY COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
NUMBER THAT THERE IS NO MORE IN
Q. ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION TO
ELEVEN TWENTY. THERE'S NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM. ANYONE IN THE
OTHER ROOM. ANYBODY ONLINE SO
IN OPPOSITION THE SB ELEVEN
TWENTY. THIRTY ONE MINUTES ZERO
TO PLACE YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE.
FOR LINE SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SIX FIVE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SIX FIVE ZERO YOUR CHECK- LINE
FOR SELF MUTE WE'RE HEARING
AUDIO. THAT LINE IS NON
RESPONSE. THERE ARE NO MORE Q.
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL NO
HANDS OF GONE UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB ELEVEN TWENTY.
VOTER SUSPENSE MOVING THE
MEASURE TADO SB TEN TWELVE. ON
OIL AND GAS WELLS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE SHE'S WAY
PRESENTATION ON ALL OUR BILLS
YOUR SUPPORT IN THIS ROOM PRESS
B. TEN TWELVE. SUPPORT IN THE
OTHER ROOMS. SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. ONE IN HERE TO PLACE
YOURSELF IN TO KILL. THERE IS
NO ONE SHOWING UP AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE OPOSITION
SB TEN TWELVE IN THIS ROOM.
PROPOSITION IN THE OTHER ROOM.
SO OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE. ONE
NINE ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF IN
THE QUEUE. AND THERE IS NO ONE
COMING UP AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT BERMAN FINANCES NOT HAVE
A FILE ON THIS BILL MY
COLLEAGUES DON'T HAVE THEIR
HANDS UP TO WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB TEN TWELVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB ELEVEN OH THREE MR
TADO AS WELL. IS WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAMS AS THEIR
SUPPORT IN THIS ROOM. SUPPORT
IN THE OTHER ROOM. SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE. ONE IN ZERO TO PLACE
YOUR LINE AND ACUTE FOR SUPPORT.
LITTLE LINE SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN SIX ONE FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MAILING CATHERINE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MYSELF
AND SUNDAY THEY- NEIGHBORS. WE
OPPOSE SB ONE ONE TWO ZERO IT'S
DEFINITELY OPENS THE DOOR TO
TURNING ONE HOME INTO FALL
BECAUSE FOR EQUAL EIGHT HOUSING
UNIT. AS IT DOES NOT FORBID
ACCESSORY LETTING YOU. MA'AM
THAT WAS THE PRIOR PANEL THAT
WAS THE PRIOR BILL WE'VE
REGISTERED YOUR NAME IN
OPPOSITION. SO THANK YOU OKAY.
WE ARE LINED ALANIS. THREE NINE
ELEVEN OH THREE. THANK YOU SIX
THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS JACKIE
ALONG WITH AND CAL POLY
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN- AND WE ARE
SPONSORED LOOK AT THE OLD
BUDGETS NUMBERS ARE SUPPORT
ALONGSIDE OUR CO SPONSOR CAL
CALIFORNIA HE YOUTH NETWORK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO
ELEVEN OH THREE IN THIS ROOM
NONE IN THE OTHER ROOM. NONE ON
THE PHONE. PROPOSITION
DESPERATE LEVEL ZERO. THANK YOU
ONE AND ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF
IN THE QUEUE. THERE IS NO ONE
IN Q. AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB ELEVEN OH THREE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
SB. ELEVEN TEN. WHICH IS MR
TADA DEALING WITH MEDICAL
SCHOLARS. YOUR SUPPORT IN THIS
ROOM. IN THE OTHER ROOM. ON THE
PHONE. PLACES OFTEN ACU IT'S
ONE AND ZERO WELL THE LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN ONE ONE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON RUNNING FOR NEW HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE COOPER
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF SB ELEVEN TEN. AND THAT WAS
THE ONLY ONE IN THE QUEUE.
THEIR OPPOSITION SB ELEVEN TEN.
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM ANYBODY IN
THE OTHER ROOM. ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE OPPOSED TO SB ELEVEN TEN.
ONE NINE ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF
IN THE QUEUE. AND NO ONE
SHOWING UP AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT THERE'S NO SUPPORT
OPPOSITION SO. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- DOES NOT HAVE A FILE
ON THIS BILL MY COLLEAGUES
DON'T HAVE THEIR HANDS UP.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ELEVEN TEN
WITH THE SUSPENSE SB TWELVE
FIFTY NINE- ADULT RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES SISTER SUPPORT FOR.
SB TWELVE FIFTY NINE. SEEING
NONE IN THIS ROOM SIGNAL IN THE
OTHER ROOM ANYBODY ON THE PHONE.
ONE NINE ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF
INTO Q. WE DO UP TO THAT OF
JUST CUED UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WHAT A LINE SIX HUNDRED AND
EIGHT. ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I TO THE FISHERIES
NORTHAMPTON COUNTY GAMER
HEALTHCARE CONSOLIDATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. AND ALSO LINE
FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX
FIVE TWO SIX YOUR LIFE IS OPEN.
YOUR MEMBERS RECTANGLE
REPRESENTING SIX BEDS AND
ASSOCIATION OF SMALL SIX THAT
THERE ARE FEWER RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY
AND DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NO ONE ELSE
CAN QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT OPPOSITION TO SB TWELVE
FIFTY NINE THERE'S NOBODY HERE
HOW ABOUT THE OTHER ROOM.
NOBODY THERE IS ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE IN OPPOSITION TO TWELVE
FIFTY NINE. ONE NINE ZERO TO
PLACE YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE.
THERE IS NO ONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
THERE IS NO FILE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON THIS
BUILDER NO HANDS UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWELVE FIFTY NINE
WILL GO TWO SUSPECTS SB TWELVE
SIXTY FOUR. IS A HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE BILL- ANY SUPPORT.
FOR TWELVE SIXTY FOUR. NOBODY
HERE IN THE OTHER ROOM. NOBODY
THERE ON THE PHONE. ONE NINE
ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF IN THE
QUEUE. NO WARNING YOU AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION TO
TWELVE SIXTY FOUR THERE'S
NOBODY HERE. ANYBODY IN THE
OTHER ROOM. NOBODY THEIR HEAVY
ON THE PHONE OPPOSED TO TWELVE
SIXTY FOUR. ONE IN THE NERO. NO
ONE IS QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT
BERMAN FINANCES NOT HAVE A FILE
PWITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWELVE
SIXTY FOUR BECAUSE THE SUSPENSE
SB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE. ALSO BY
MR TANTO ON CAL WORKS ANYONE IN
SUPPORT. ANYONE IS FOR THE
OTHER ROOM ANYBODY SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE. ONE IN ZERO TO PLACE
YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE. SOMEONE
IS DOING UP AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT IS THERE OPPOSITION TO
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE NOBODY HERE
IN THE OTHER ROOM. ON THE PHONE.
ONE NINE ZERO. NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE. ALL RIGHT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE
ON THIS BILL NO COLLEAGUES HAVE
THEIR HANDS UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE MISTER
ALLEN. HAS ONE BILL HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION IT'S TEN FORTY
FOUR ON FIREFIGHTER EQUIPMENT.
AND PHONE SIR SUPPORT. NOBODY
HERE IN THE OTHER ROOM. NOBODY
THERE IS THERE ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
FORTY FOUR. ONE NINE ZERO. AND
NO ONE IS GEARING UP AT THIS
TIME THEIR OPPOSITION TO TEN
FORTY FOUR. NOBODY HERE ANYBODY
IN THE OTHER ROOM. AND MANY ON
THE PHONE. ONE NINE ZERO TO
PLACE YOURSELF INTO Q. WE HAVE
NO ONE IN Q. AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT- PARTMINER FINANCE. DOES
NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL.
WITH OF AS TEN FORTY FOUR COSTA.
MOVING TO MISTER HUESO- TEN
FIFTY EIGHT. THE SPRINTS
CANDIDATE ANY AS WAVES
PRESENTATION AND IT IS ON
INTERNET SERVICES MR SUPPORT.
FOR TEN FIFTY EIGHT. NOBODY IN
THE OTHER ROOM ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE. ONE NINE ZERO TO PLACE
YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE. IS THERE
OPPOSITION OVER THE LINE HOLD
ON ONE SECOND YOUR DON'T WANNA
JUST CUTE ONE Q. THAT NINE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE. GOING
TO OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON YOUR
ARE RIGHT POLICY MANAGER
DECIDED IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
A POSITION OKAY. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE OPPOSITION IN THIS ROOM.
AFTERNOON MATURE MEMBERS BERNIE
ARE OSCAR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CABLE AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION- IN OPPOSITION TO
THE MEASURE. CERTAINLY TO
LEGISLATION PASSED RECENTLY BY
THIS BODY- SB NINE OH ONE
REQUIRED THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TO PROVIDE A REVIEW
AND APPROVE WHILE FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS FOR INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES JUST THREE
UTILITIES. WHAT THIS BILL
PROPOSES IS THAT- THE P. UC
EVALUATE APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED FOURTEEN DIFFERENT
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS.
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS PLANS AND
OUR NUMBER PROVISIONS IN THERE
THAT ARE QUESTIONABLE BUT EVEN
SO IF THEY'RE TO REVIEW THOSE.
BEST METHOD THEIR PROVIDE IS
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. WHEN HOUSE WHEN THE SB
NINE A ONE WENT THROUGH IT
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
ESTIMATE DOES LAWS AT. TO
FOREST AND BUDGET CHANGE POSES
IN THE MILLIONS OF. SO WELL
THIS IS A SUSPEND CANADA WE
WOULD KNOW THAT THE IS SO WITH
THE STILL IF EVEN LEGAL ARE
EXTREMELY UNDRESSED. IN THE- IN
THE UC ESTIMATE AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY. ALL THIS WORK THAT
WOULD BE DONE BY THESE
EMERGENCY OPERATION PLANTS THE
BILL KNOWS EVEN SPEAK TO WATER
THE WHAT IS THE PC DO THEM SO
THIS IS MONEY DOWN THE DRAIN SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WERE OPPOSE
THANK YOU. RESEARCHER MEMBERS
MCKAY ON BEHALF OF THE-
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION ON
POLICY GROUNDS THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT ANYONE OPPOSED IN THE
OTHER ROOM. ANYBODY POST ONLINE.
TEN FIFTY ONE AND ZERO. WE GOT
A LINE NUMBER SIX HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN SIX ONE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS WITH WITH PAM LIMITS ON
BEHALF OF CONSOLIDATED
COMMUNICATIONS IN OPPOSITION.
STE. NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. AFFIRMATIVE
FINANCES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL AND MY COLLEAGUES
WILL HAVE THEIR ARMS UP SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TEN FIFTY
EIGHT. GOES TO SUSPENSE SB
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT ALSO BY MR
HUESO. HIGHWAYS AND ROADS
RECYCLED PLASTIC IS THERE
SUPPORT IN THIS ROOM. SEEING
NONE IS THERE SUPPORT IN THE
OTHER ROOM. SEEING NONE IS
THERE SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. ONE
AND ZERO PLACE YOURSELF IN THE
QUEUE. I HAVE ONE IT'S LINES
SIX HUNDRED SIXTY SIX FULL SIX
EUROPE. ONE SIX HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SIX ARE LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE CHECK FROM YOU. MY NAME
IS BRYCE CARED I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE BENEFITS TO
HIGH SCHOOL PROGRESSIVE CLUB
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
AT THIS TIME. DODD. I'M SURE
THAT WAS THE LAST SUPPORT. NO I
DON'T THINK YOU AT THIS TIME
SIR ALL RIGHT SB TWELVE THIRTY
EIGHT IS THERE ANYONE HERE AND
IN OPPOSITION SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IN
THE OTHER ROOM SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANYONE ONLINE. IN
OPPOSITION. TO TWELVE THIRTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU IT'S ONE NINE
ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF IN THE
QUEUE. THERE'S NO ONE IN WHICH
YOU AT THIS TIME. BERMAN
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL. WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT COAST TO
SUSPENSE SB. THIRTEEN OH ONE.
ON TIJUANA RIVER VALLEY
WATERSHED PLAN- THEIR SUPPORT
IN THIS ROOM SEEING NONE IS
THERE SUPPORT IN THE OTHER ROOM.
SEEING NONE IS THERE SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE. ONE NINE ZERO TO
PLACE YOURSELF INTO THE QUEUE.
NO ONE IS GOING U AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION IN THIS
ROOM. OPPOSITION IN THE OTHER
ROOM. OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE.
ONE NINE ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF
IN THE QUEUE. NO ONE IS COMING
UP AT THIS TIME RIGHT TO BERMAN
FINANCES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL IN MY COLLEAGUES
DON'T HAVE THEIR ARMS UP SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN A
ONE WILL GO THE SUSPENSE SB
FORTINO THREE ON HOME
WEATHERIZATION. AS OUR SUPPORT
IN THIS ROOM. SEEING ONE IS
THERE SUPPORT IN THE OTHER
ROOM. SEEING NONE IS THERE
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. ONE EIGHT
ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF IN THE
QUEUE. THERE IS NO ONE Q. AT
THIS TIME THEIR OPPOSITION TO
FORTINO THREE NOBODY HERE. IN
THE OTHER ROOM. NOBODY THERE.
ON THE PHONE. ONE IS HERE TO
PLACE YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE.
AND NO ONE IS COMING UP AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT FORMER FINANCES
THAT HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL.
MY COLLEAGUES DON'T HAVE THEIR
ARMS UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
FORTINO THREE GOES TO SUSPENSE.
LIVING ANIMIST SKINNER'S BILLS
SB TEN SIXTY FOUR. ON PRISON
CAN CONFIDENTIAL INFORMANTS IS
THERE SUPPORT FOR. TEN SIXTY
FOUR. NOT IN THIS ROOM THE
OTHER ROOM. NON THERE ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE. ONE IN ZERO TO
PLACE YOURSELF IN TO KILL. THE
ONE THAT JUST KILLED UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
PUT A LINE SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE SIX TWO
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HERE'S A
GENERAL IN STABLE TURN- OF
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
PEACE ALLIANCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THAT SPEECH AND SIX
FOUR. I GENERAL IN. NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. IS
THERE OPPOSITION TO TEN SIXTY
FOUR OR ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM
NOW ANY MONEY IN THE OTHER ROOM.
THE MONEY ON THE LINE. ONE NINE
ZERO. BUT WE HAVE ONE THAT JUST
CUED UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WHERE TO GO TO LINE SIX HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY TWO SIX SEVEN TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN YOU READ
THE BILL. THOUGH THIS IS PUBLIC
COMMENT WHAT'S YOUR POSITION. I
AM OPPOSED THANK YOU. NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS
BILL MY COLLEAGUES DON'T HAVE
THEIR ARMS UP SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TEN SIXTY FOUR
CLOSE TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB
TEN SEVENTY NINE. ALSO SUSPENDS
CANDIDATE ON RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY FORECLOSURES SIR
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM KNOWS OR
ANYONE IN THE OTHER ROOM. NO IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE. TEN
ONE ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF IN
THE QUEUE. WE DO HAVE ONE EXTRA
SECURED UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THE WAITING LINE NUMBER TO BE
ABLE TO RETURN IT IS LYING SIX
SEVENTY SEVEN SIX SEVEN SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH MY NAME
IS DAISY CHÁVEZ I'M WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO KNOW. PHONE NUMBER IS NOT ON
THE SCREEN FOR PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO CALL AND THEY HAVE TO
GO TO THE WEBSITE TO FIND. AT.
THANK YOU NO ONE ELSE IN TWO AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT IS THERE
OPPOSITION TO TEN SEVENTY NINE
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM.
NOBODY IN THE OTHER ROOM. IS
THERE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSED TO TEN SEVENTY NINE.
THAT'S ONE IN PLACE YOURSELF IN
THE QUEUE. NO ONE IS COMING UP
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL. AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE WAS OF A SUSPENSE
MOVING ON THE TEN EIGHTY FIVE.
DENSITY BONUS BILL AS THEIR
SUPPORT IN THIS ROOM. SEEING
NONE IS THERE SUPPORT IN THE
OTHER ROOM. FOR SUPPORT ON THE
LINE. FOR TEN EIGHTY FIVE. ONE
AND ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF FROM
THE QUEUE. IF YOU'RE A KID UP
PREVIOUSLY SO I HAVE THEIR LINE
NUMBERS HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX TWO NINE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BOB NAIL
REPRESENTING FEELS SAID IN
COMPANY AN ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF
CALIFORNIA YEARLY. AND STRONGLY
SUPPORT OF US BE TEN EIGHTY
FIVE THANK YOU. BELOW THE LINE
NUMBER SIX FIFTY FIVE SIX FIVE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CHAIR
NUMBER AND I'M NOT LIKE HAVE TO
LOOK AT VARIOUS CALLING ON
BEHALF. AND HAVE YOU MANY
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIAN B. AND A
THREE PIECE COLLECTION IN
SUPPORT YEAH. I WILL THE LINE
SIX ON- ONE SIX SEVEN ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE SIX SEVEN
ONE CHECK FOR SELF MUTE WE'RE
HEARING AUDIO. DURING A
RESPONSIBLE ONLINE SIX HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO SIX SIX TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HE THEN STRAW
WITH THE BAY AREA HOUSING
ADVOCACY COALITION IN SUPPORT
THANKS. Q. LITTLE LINE FIVE
HUNDRED AND EIGHT FIVE ZERO
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS SILVIO
FERRARI ON BEHALF OF FACEBOOK
IN SUPPORT. AND SIX HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FOUR FOUR SIX EIGHT FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS STEVE CARLSON
PROCEED PA THE WIRELESS
ASSOCIATION- WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION SORRY I MIGHT HAVE
GOTTEN OUT OF YOU. WE THINK
THIS IS- REDUNDANT REPORTING
I'M ON MANY AREAS THAT ARE
BEING COVERED OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS. AND IN FACT WILL
LEAD TO COST OF LITIGATION
BECAUSE OF THE REQUIREMENT THAT
CARRIER IS PROVIDED AFFORDABLE
CLASS OF BROADBAND WHICH THEY
ARE ALREADY DOING. THANK FOR
THOSE REASONS WE MUST OPPOSE.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE STILL ON
SUPPORT. FOR TEN EIGHTY FIVE.
LOOK MY SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
ONE SIX SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS ALLEY
TUNING CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
BAY AREA COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
AND WITH THAT WE'VE EXHAUSTED
TO SUPPORT Q. ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION TO TEN EIGHTY FIVE
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM.
ANYBODY IN THE OTHER ROOM KNOW
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE. ONE ZERO
TO PLACE YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE
FOR OPPOSITION. OKAY ALIGNED TO
CUT IN FIFTEEN SIX ONE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MAILING GAS
AND SPEAKING FOR MYSELF AND A
GROUP OF SUNNYVALE NAY BUSH WE
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB AND EIGHTY
FIVE. THANK YOU. YOU KNOW ONE
ONLINE SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SIX SIX SEVEN SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN CARE ROCK ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF PASADENA IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THERE'S
NONE FURTHER IN Q. IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TEN EIGHTY
FIVE. WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE SB
THIRTEEN HUNDRED REDEVELOPMENT
CITY OF HERCULES THEIR SUPPORT
IN THE ROOM NOW IS YOUR SUPPORT
IN THE OTHER ROOM KNOWS THEIR
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. ONE NINE
ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF FROM THE
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT. THERE'S NO
ONE COMING UP AT THIS TIME SIR.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE OPPOSITION.
SB THIRTEEN HUNDRED. NO ONE IN
THIS ROM KNOWN IN THE OTHER
ROOM ANYBODY ON THE LINE. ONE
NINE ZERO. AGAIN NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE. ALL RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS SOME COMMENTS FOR
US. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION ON THIS MEASURE BUT WE
KNOW THAT APPROVAL OF THE STILL
MAY ALLOW THE CITY OF HERCULES
SUCCESSOR AGENCY. TO REPAY
LOANS NOT CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE
FOR REPAYMENT UNDER DISSOLUTION
LAW RESULTING IN LESS TAX
INCREMENTS FLOWING TO THE
AFFECTED TAXING ENTITIES
INCLUDING SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
CAUSING AN INCREASED COST
TO THE STATE GENERAL FUNDS
BY AN UNKNOWN BUT POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT FUNDS THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE BE DISTRIBUTED
TO THE AFFECTED TAXING
ENTITIES FOR CORE GOVERNMENT
SERVICES WILL BE DIVERTED TO
PAY AGENCY OBLIGATIONS THAT
DISSOLUTION LAW INTENDED NOT
TO BE PAYABLE THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY NINE OTHER CALIFORNIA
SUCCESSOR AGENCIES COMPLIED
WITH LAW AND RECEIVED A
FINDING OF COMPLETION OF
THE STATUTORY DEADLINE
ONLY NINE SUCCESSOR AGENCY
STATE WEB FAILS TO RECEIVE
A FINDING OF COMPLETION AND
PASSAGE OF THIS MEASURE MAY
SET A PRECEDENT FOR THE OTHER
AGENCIES FINALLY I WOULD NOTE
THAT A FINDING OF COMPLETION --
IS NOT NEEDED TO REFINANCE THE
AGENCY'S OBLIGATIONS THANK YOU
NO COMMENTS FROM MY CUT
NO COLLEAGUES -- S.
B.
THIRTEEN HUNDRED WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO SP TEN
SIXTY FIVE BY MR HERTZBERG ON
CAL WORKS HIS WAY PRESENTATIONS
FOR SUPPORT IN THE ROOM FOR
TEN EIGHTY FIVE SEEING NONE
IS OUR SUPPORT IN THE OTHER
ROOM SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE WANTS
TO TALK TO US ABOUT TEN SIXTY
FIVE THAT'S ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
NO ONE IS DOING UP AT THIS
TIME THIRTY OPPOSITION TO TURN
SIXTY FIVE IN THIS ROOM IN
THE OTHER ROOM ON THE PHONE
BUT AGAIN IT'S ONE
ZERO ON THE PHONE
NO ONE IS COMING UP AT THIS
TIME RIGHT FROM ITS FINANCES
NO FILE ON TEN SIXTY FIVE
WITHOUT OBJECTION IT WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO MISTER
ROGERS BILLS -- STARTING WITH
ELEVEN ELEVEN BUT IT'S A --
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE ON JUVENILE
DETENTION FACILITIES SEARCH
SUPPORT IN THIS ROOM KNOWS
OUR SUPPORT IN THE OTHER ROOM
WE'RE HAVING TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES YES YEAH THERE
WE WERE AT CAMP OH MY GOODNESS
TWENTY SEVEN WITH CISCO YEAH
BUT I THINK THAT OUR STORE
I WAS SCREAMING JUST DO IT
WELL WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE
IS THERE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
FOR ELEVEN ELEVEN THAT'S ONE
IN ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF IN
THE QUEUE IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
ELEVEN WE HAVE ONE IT'S FROM
LINE SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
TWO SIX SEVEN TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN I'M IN OPPOSITION WE'LL
TAKE YOUR NAME AND TELL US ALL
RIGHT OKAY ALL RIGHT WE'VE GOT
YOU DOWN ALL RIGHT ANYBODY ELSE
IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN ELEVEN
NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE ALL
RIGHT WELL WE'RE WAITING ON
THE OTHER ROOM IS THERE ANYBODY
IN OPPOSITION HERE NO THE
OTHER ROOM WE'RE STILL WAITING
ON WE'LL GO BACK TO THERE
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE THAT
OPPOSES ELEVEN ELEVEN OTHER
THAN THAT GENTLEMAN WE JUST
HEARD FROM YOU TO OPPOSE
A MOMENT WE HAVE
WON THE TICKET UP
ONE SIX HUNDRED AND NINETY
THREE SIX NINE THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN HELLO MY NAME IS MIGUEL
GARCIA QUALITY COORDINATOR WITH
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION CO
SPONSOR OF AT ELEVEN ELEVEN AM
HELP SUPPORT THANK YOU SH SH
ALL RIGHT WE'RE ON OPPOSITION
NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME RIGHT WELL WE'RE
WAITING FOR OUR CAMERA I SEE
ARE WE UP NOW WE WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS SOME
WORDS FOR US ON ELEVEN ELEVEN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WOULD
KNOW THAT IT IS UNCLEAR HOW THE
LEGISLATION WOULD IMPACT THE
POPULATION OF YOUTH CURRENTLY
EDUCATED TO THE DIVISION
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE HOWEVER
ASSUMING THAT THE BILL APPLIES
PROSPECTIVELY BEGINNING JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
BILL COULD RESULT IN STATE
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS IN THE
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AND INCREASING THEIR
AFTER AS HE IS CURRENTLY
SERVING THEIR SENTENCES A DJJ
COMPLETE THEIR TERMS AND A
TRIP OUT OF THE FACILITIES ARE
THE SAVINGS WOULD BE SOMEWHAT
OFFSET BY LOSS IN GENERAL
FUND REVENUES PROVIDED BY
COUNTIES TO THE DJJ FOR WARDS
SENTENCED TO DJJ FACILITIES BY
JUVENILE COURTS ADDITIONALLY
BY SHIFTING CASELOADS -- FROM
COUNTY SHERIFF DEPARTMENTS
IN ADULT JAILS TO KIND OF A
PATIENT APARTMENTS IN JUVENILE
HALLS THIS BILL POTENTIALLY
INCLUDES A GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES RESEARCH PROPOSITION
THIRTY IN ADDITION THE STONEY
CREEK STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE BECAUSE IT REQUIRES
A NEW PROGRAM OR HIGHER LEVEL
OF SERVICE TO BE PROVIDED BY
LOCAL AGENCIES THANK YOU THANK
YOU TO PAY ATTENTION TO KIDS --
CAN ANYBODY TELL ME IF ANYBODY
WAS IN THAT ROOM OKAY SO I
ALL RIGHT SO THERE WAS NOBODY
IN THAT ROOM PHARMA FINANCES
SPOKEN SO THIS BILL IS GOING TO
GO TO SUSPENSE S.
B.
ELEVEN ELEVEN WITHOUT OBJECTION
I HAVE TWO SUGGESTIONS FOR OUR
SITUATION WE CAN PUT UP A SIGN
IN TWELVE IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
JUST SAY PLEASE GO TO FORTY
TWO OH THREE OR WE CAN PUT
SOMEBODY IN THE ROOM WITH THE
CELL PHONE TO LET US KNOW IF
THERE'S ACTUALLY ANYBODY IN
THERE SO CAN WE PUT A SIGN ON
THE DOOR AND SAY IT'S LOCKED
BUT WE KNOW EVERYBODY THAT
COMES ALL RIGHT I WAS JUST
GONNA SAY PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
DIRECTED TO THAT ROOM THERE
SHOULD BE MAYBE SOMEBODY OKAY
GREAT SO WE'RE GOOD SO WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP GOING AND WE'LL
JUST SKIP THAT PART OF THE
PROCEEDINGS ALL RIGHT MOVING
ON TO ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE BY
MR RASO ON PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
EMPLOYEE INFORMATION -- THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM AND SUPPORT
WE KNOW THERE'S NOBODY IN THE
OTHER ROOM WILL GO RIGHT TO
THE PHONE ON ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE IT'S ONE IN ZERO TO
PLACE YOURSELF INTO THE QUEUE
AND THERE IS NO ONE SHOWING
UP AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
HERE AT ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE
IS THERE ANYBODY ON THE
LINE OPPOSED TO S.
B.
ELEVEN SEVENTY THREE WE DO HAVE
A COUPLE BLOWING UP WE'LL GO
TO LINE SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
TWO SIX SEVEN TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN I'M POSED TO THE BILL
IT ONE MOMENT WE HAVE TWO
MORE THIRTY NINE MEMBERS
HE'S RIGHT AT THE POINT
OVER THE LINE NINETY FOUR SIX
NINE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
HERE ARE ROCK AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BURBANK
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
AND LINE SIX HUNDRED AND TWO
SIX ZERO TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HELLO MISTER CHAIR I APOLOGIZE
FOR BEING OUT OF ORDER
STUFF FROM HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION ONE STRONG SUPPORT
AND NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT --
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
NO FILE ON THIS BILL WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE S.
B.
ELEVEN NINETY
-- TENNESSEE TERMINATION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THE
ROOM AND SUPPORT SIR
ANYBODY ONLINE IN SUPPORT
ONE ZERO TO PLACE
YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE
I DON'T WANT YOU AT THIS TIME
SIR ALL RIGHT IS THERE ANYBODY
IN THIS ROOM IN OPPOSITION
SIR ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE IN OPPOSITION
BROKE TO MAKE YOUR VOICE
HEARD IN OPPOSITION WE
HAVE A CUE TO THAT JUST
QUEUED UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE
I THINK
IF YOU WERE GONNA GO TO LINE
SITTARD IN SEVENTY TWO SIX
SEVEN TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PRESENTING AT THE END I AM
OPPOSED TO THE BILL OKAY
YEAH HELLO TO LINE THE SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE SIX
THREE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS KAREEM THREE C.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS
MY APOLOGIES MISTER CHAIR
EXPERIENCE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES EARLIER IN THE
DAY SO I WOULD NOT ONLY LIKE
TO REGISTER OUT THIS VISION FOR
XP ELEVEN NINETY -- BUT ALSO
RESPECT WE REGISTER OPPOSITION
OR SP NINE FIFTEEN AN SP NINE
THREE NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH
ALKALINE NUMBER SIX HUNDRED
AND NINETY ONE SIX NINE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS TAMPERING WITH
AARON READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL THANK YOU
AND WE'VE EXHAUSTED OPPOSITION
UNTIL THIS TIME ALL RIGHT TO
FARM IN A FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL AND
-- WITHOUT OBJECTION AS WE LIVE
IN NINETY WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE
SP TWELVE TWENTY TWO DETENTION
FACILITIES CONTRACTS THERE IS
NO SUPPORT IN THIS ROOM SIR
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT
OF TWELVE TWENTY TWO YOUR BREAK
YOU UP BY PRESSING ONE END ZERO
WE'LL GO TO LINE FIVE HUNDRED
AND FORTY EIGHT FIVE FOUR
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT AND WE ALSO SUPPORT
SENATE BILL ELEVEN ELEVEN BUY
ANOTHER CAR ALSO THANK YOU
TOTAL THIRTY EIGHT FIVE
SIX EIGHT FIVE ONE MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
NUMBER SIX HUNDRED AND
NINETY SEVEN CENTS TIME
IN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
RESPONSES ARE TERRIBLE
OR PROBABLY A SPONSOR
WINE SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE SIX FIVE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN SURE
MEMBERS RYAN SHERMAN WITH
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
TWELVE TWENTY TWO THANK YOU
NINE SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
TWO SIX SEVEN TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN I'M SORRY I'M OUT OF ORDER
GO TO THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS
THANK YOU WE HAVE -- ONE
MORE THAT GETTING THEIR LINE
NUMBER ONE MOMENT PLEASE
ONE FOUR HUNDRED AND NINETY
SIX FOUR NINE SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN I LANDED LAND WITH THE
VITAMIN GROUP PUBLISHING NEXT
IN CALIFORNIA AND THE PART
WELL THE LINE SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FOUR SEVEN ZERO FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN I HATED
HIM OUT OF THE PRODUCT WITH
THEIR EXAMPLE AND COMPLAINED
THAT HE CAN EIGHTY FIVE
AND WITH THAT WE'VE EXHAUSTED
THE KILL BUTTON AND MICHAEL
MARTIN ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
DO OPPOSITION OF TWELVE
TWENTY TWO THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM THE OTHER ROOM
IS LOCKED WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE PHONE OPPOSITION FOR
TWELVE TWENTY TWO IT'S ONE
ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF IN
THE QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION
YOU DON'T WANT GETTING A
LINE NUMBER ONE MOMENT PLEASE
ONE SIX HUNDRED AND NINETY
EIGHT SIX NINE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ROBIN DID
SEND WITH THE REMEMBRANCE
PROJECT IN OPPOSITION
AND WILL RETURN TO LINE SIX
SEVENTY TWO WHO IS NOW IN
ORDER YOUR LINE IS OPEN YES
I AM OPPOSED TO THE BILL
AND THERE IS NO MORE OPPOSITION
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT BARMOUTH FINANCE DOES
NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL
WITHOUT OBJECTION S.
B.
TWELVE TWENTY TWO GOES
TO SUSPENSE AS B.
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN ON DOMESTIC
SERVICE EMPLOYEE SAFETY
-- IS FOR CONSIDERATION OF
SUSPENSE AND THERE'S NOBODY
HERE AND IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE LINE IN SUPPORT IT'S ONE
AND ONE AND REPLACE YOURSELF
FROM THE QUEUE AND SUPPORT
WHAT A LINE SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVEN SIX NINE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN CHRISTOPHER
SIZES WHICH OF THE COALITION
AND THE IRAQI STRONG SUPPORT
AND NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION TO TWELVE
FIFTY SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY
HERE SURE ANYBODY ON THE LINE
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE IT'S ONE
IN ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF IN
THE QUEUE WILL GO TO LINE SIX
SEVENTY TWO SIX SEVENTY TWO
YEAR OLD I OPPOSE THE BILL
NO ONE ELSE INTO IT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT -- FORMER
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION TWELVE
FIFTY SEVEN WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE TWELVE NINETY SIX
IS THERE ANYONE HERE TO SPEAK
ON NATURE AND PARKS RESILIENCY
ACT NOBODY IN THE ROOM ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE ONE ZERO ZERO
ONE MOMENT WE DO UP ONE
ONE SEVEN HUNDRED SEVEN ZERO
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN HI THIS
IS JEANNIE CHO AND I JUST
WANTED TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
AT EIGHT TWELVE NINETY SIX ON
BEHALF OF AUDUBON CALIFORNIA
CAL TROUT A TOOL LETS YOU
KNOW OUTDOORS THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY IN THE
PARK NOW COALITION THANK YOU
AND THERE'S NO ONE ELSE CAN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION THE TWELVE NINETY
SIX THERE'S NOBODY HERE
ANYBODY ONLINE OPPOSED TO
TWELVE NINETY SIX NINE SIX
SEVEN TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
I OPPOSE THE BILL STRENUOUSLY
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT THE PERMANENT
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A
FILE ON THIS BILL WITHOUT
OBJECTION TWELVE NINETY SIX
WE'LL GO TO SUSPEND MOVING
ON THE THIRTEEN NINETY NINE
THE NINETY NINE ON EMPLOYMENT
GARMENT MANUFACTURING IS
THERE SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
NOBODY'S HERE ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE IT'S ONE ZERO TO PUT
YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE WE'LL
GO TO LINE SIX HUNDRED AND
NINETY SEVEN SIX NINE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN AS A RESULT
OF A TRULY CALL THE TERMINAL
RIGHT NOW ON STRONG SUPPORT
FULL METAL LINE OF FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO THAT'S
FIVE SIX TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN HELLO CATALINA SANCHEZ
ACCORDING KAISER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION
AND THE PART THANK YOU
M.
LINE SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE SIX SEVEN
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
SIX SEVEN NINE WHEN YOU CHECK
FOR SELF MUTE WE ARE HEARING
THE AUDIO GOOD AFTERNOON
MATTHEW THE CARLESS OF THAT
STATIC LEGAL SERVICES WHEN
THE SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS
OF THIRTEEN NINETY NINE
OKAY ONE MORE THAT JUST QUEUED
UP PLEASE ALLOW SOME MOMENT
BORDERLINE SIX NINETY SIX
NINE ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HELLO MY NAME IS MARISSA
NUNEZ HILL DIRECTOR OF THE
GARMENT WORKERS AND KERR
HOW COSPONSORED SB THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IF YOU CONSIDER THE
COST OF THIS BILL WORKERS ASK
YOU TO BEAR IN MIND THE FULL
COST OF WEEKS THAT'S TO THE
STATE AS WELL AS TO THEM AND
THEIR FAMILY A STUDY BY THE
UCLA LABOR CENTER REVEALED
THAT LOW WAGE WORKERS SPEND
A GREATER PROPORTION OF THEIR
INCOME IN THE LOCAL ECONOMY
ANOTHER WORKER ON HOUSING
FOOD AND UTILITY THE STUDY
ALSO REVEALED THAT IT ONLY
COUNTY ALONE BLEACH THAT'S
BECAUSE THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
BETWEEN ONE HUNDRED AND THREE
MILLION AND A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THREE MILLION ANNUALLY AND
LOST INCOME TAX SALES TAX AND
CONTRIBUTIONS TO UNEMPLOYMENT
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING TAX AND
STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE
GIVEN THAT THE STUDIES ON THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY IS THE WORST
OF THE LOW WAGE INDUSTRIES
WE KNOW THAT A LARGE PORTION
OF THIS LOST REVENUE FROM THE
INDUSTRY AND BE THIRTEEN NINETY
NINE BUT HOLDEN SCRUPULOUS
BUSINESS RESPONSIBLE FOR AND
HE REACHES ITS LABOR COSTS
BACK TO BUSINESSES AND PREVENTS
THE DRAIN ON COLONEL AND
THE SUBSEQUENT DRAIN ON TAX
REVENUES THAT THESE BUSINESSES
BECAUSE FAR TOO LONG FOR THESE
REASONS WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE SIX EIGHT
EIGHT SIX EIGHT EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN MICHAEL YOUNG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO STRONG SUPPORT
AND WITH THAT WE'VE EXHAUSTED
THE SUPPORT QUEUE ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM IS THERE ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE -- AND IT IS
THE CUSTOM AND PRACTICE TO
IDENTIFY YOURSELF WHEN YOU
MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT SO IF
YOU PLEASE COULD IDENTIFY
YOURSELF BEFORE YOU SAY YOU'RE
A POSER SUPPORT POSITIONS
THAT WOULD BE APPRECIATED
WE WILL GO TO LINE SIX SEVEN
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN MY NAME
IS MARSHALL I'M A RESIDENT
OF THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA
I'M IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL IS UNNECESSARY
CONSTRAINT -- PRIVATE BUSINESS
AN OLDER LINE IS SIX EIGHTY
SIX SIX EIGHT SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN THANK YOU HI MY NAME
IS PATRICIA BRUNELLE AND
NINE I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE CAN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT FOR
ME TO FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A
FILE ON THIRTEEN NINETY NINE
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION IT WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO
SP ONE ONE ONE FIVE BY MISTER
WELK ON COMMERCIAL BLOOD
BANKS FOR ANIMALS THERE'S NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT
IS THERE ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
FIFTEEN AND THAT'S ONE ZERO
TO PLACE YOURSELF THANK YOU
FOR SUPPORT WE HAVE ONE THAT
IS QUEUED UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WHAT A LINE SIX HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THREE SIX SIX THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN HI YES MY NAME
IS JUDY MAN CREW SO PRESIDENT
OF SOCIAL COMPASSION IN
LEGISLATION WE ARE SPONSORING
THE BILL -- SP ELEVEN FIFTEEN
IS -- THE SAME BILL IS THAT
THE TRUE TRUE THEY GOT A TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHT LAST YEAR -- BUT
IT WAS VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR
AFTER IT GOT UNANIMOUS ACCORD
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE WE
BROUGHT IT BACK TO ANSWER
HIS VETO MESSAGE AND COULD
BE ADDITIONAL -- PHASE OUT OF
THE BLOOD BANK IN THAT BATTLE
AND I HOPE THAT YOU HELP ON
IT TO GET IT BACK TO HIS DESK
FOR SIGNATURE AND I WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE A COUPLE OF HUNDRED
GESTIONE NUMBER ONE I THINK YOU
SHOULD PUT THE ONE ZERO ON YOUR
APPROPRIATION WEBSITE ON HOW
TO BE DURING THE CALL AND ALSO
THERE IS A HUGE DELAY BETWEEN
THE VIDEO AND THAT TELEPHONE
AND THAT'S WHY SO MANY PEOPLE
ARE SPEAKING AFTER -- THE BILL
COMES UP AND -- AND I JUST
WANTED TO SAY THAT I THINK THAT
THE PREVIOUS CALL ALERT THAT
SAID THAT YOU SHOULD PUT THE
TELEPHONE NUMBER ON THE VIDEO
SCREEN -- AND MAKE PEOPLE AWARE
OF THE DELAY WHEN YOU DON'T
BUT I THINK IT WOULD BE GOOD
FOR YOUR COMMITTEE AND GO TO
THE GENERAL PUBLIC SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION
SP ELEVEN FIFTEEN THERE'S
NOBODY HERE ANYBODY ONLINE
ONE IN ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF
IN THE QUEUE IN OPPOSITION
NO ONE IS SHOWING UP AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT FORMER FINANCE
IS NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION AS B.
ONE ONE ONE FIVE WILL GO
THE SUSPENSE AS B.
LEVIN THIRTY BY -- SENATOR
GONZALEZ ON CALIFORNIA ADVANCE
SERVICES FUNDS IS THERE
ANYONE IN SUPPORT SEEING NO
ONE HEARS EVERYONE ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
THIRTY IT'S ONE THEN ZERO TO
PLACE YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE
WE HAVE ONE IT'S FROM LINE
FIVE HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO
FIVE SIX TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
NEVER MIND ONE MOMENT PLEASE
SO NOW WE'LL GO TO LINE FIVE
SIX TO PROPERLY GO AHEAD
HELLO CATALINA SANCHEZ A
CORPSMAN IN KEIZER ON BEHALF
OF THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION AND COMMON SENSE
-- JUST DROP THE PORT ON
AT ELEVEN THIRTY THANK YOU
AND NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME OPPOSITION
TO ELEVEN THIRTY
THE FUTURE MEMBERS BERNIE
OROZCO WITH CALIFORNIA
CABLE AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OPPOSED
THE ANALYSIS SAYS THAT THERE
ARE UNKNOWN HUGE UPPER COST
PRESSURES WITH THIS PROPOSAL
THE CALIFORNIA MAN SERVICES
FUND CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT RIGHT NOW HAS A
BALANCE OF ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATED FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE PROGRAM
ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
OF THAT IS NOW BEEN DEDICATED
THERE'S JUST THIS TWO HUNDRED
MILLION THAT IS LEFT AS OF THIS
MONTH THERE ARE FIFTY PENDING
APPLICATIONS AT THE P.
U.
C.
FOR HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
THE PROJECTS OF UNMET NEEDS
SO CURRENTLY THE DEFINITION
OF UNMET UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY
IS SIX MEGABITS DOWN AND ONE
MEGABIT UP THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
REDEFINE AN UNDERSERVED AREA
TO BE TWENTY FIVE MEGABITS
DOWN AND TWENTY FIVE MEGABITS
UP THIS WOULD ESSENTIALLY OPEN
THE ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
UP TO BEING ELIGIBLE FOR
FUNDS TO INCREASE BROADBAND
SPEEDS SO FOR THESE REASONS
LOSING FOCUS WITH THE RURAL
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED TO BE
SERVED -- AND THE HUGE COSTS
INCREASES WE ARE OPPOSED
ANY OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
LINE TO ELEVEN THIRTY IT'S ONE
THEN ZERO TO PUT YOURSELF IN
THE QUEUE WE'LL GO TO LINE SIX
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
MY NAME IS FARZANA RESIDENCY
SANTA MONICA I'M SUPPOSED TO
FILL THESE IMPOSES UNNECESSARY
COSTS ON PRIVATE BUSINESS AND
BROADBAND IS NOT AN ESSENTIAL
NEED THE AVERAGE CITIZEN
THANK YOU SIR ANYONE ELSE ON
THE LINE YEP LITTLE LINE SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE SIX
TWO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON JUROR RIGHT
LA COUNTY BUSINESS FEDERATION
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
WHAT IS IT AND NO ONE ELSE
IN HERE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT THERE IS NO -- FILE
FROM FINANCE ON THIS BILL
WITHOUT OBJECTION S.
B.
ELEVEN THIRTY WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ONTO SP
ELEVEN FORTY ONE BY MS RUBIO
ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE --
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE ROOM
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN FORTY
ONE THAT'S ONE THEN ZERO TO
PLACE YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE
ONE MOMENT WE DID
HAVE ONE JUST POP IN
FOR SOME REASON -- THERE
WE GO JUST A MOMENT I'LL
HAVE A LINE NUMBER FOR US
REGULAR LINES SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIVE SEVEN
ZERO FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
FINE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
CHECK YOUR LINE FOR SELF MUTE
APOLOGIZE OUTLINE
IS NON RESPONSIVE
THERE IS ALSO NO ONE ELSE Q.
ARE NOT POSITIONED TO ELEVEN
FORTY ONE THERE'S NOBODY
HERE ANYBODY ON THE LINE
IN ON THIS ISSUE FORTY ONE
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIX SEVEN
TWO SIX SEVEN TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN MARK SHAW SANTA MONICA
-- STOPPING YUSHIN WINDOWS --
IT CAN'T BE ENFORCED
AND THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT THERE IS NO FILE ON
THIS BILL FROM FINANCE WITHOUT
OBJECTION ELEVEN FORTY ONE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO --
INSURANCE COMMITTEE BILL TWELVE
FIFTY FIVE IS THERE ANY SUPPORT
NOBODY HEAR ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE
ONE IN ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF
IN THE QUEUE WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIX HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
SIX EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN THANK YOU TAMMY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
-- INSTRUCTED COURT ACTION ONE
THAT YOU WEREN'T SURE AND H.
A B.
ACT TO ATTRACT
WONDERING THANK YOU
NO ONE ELSE INTO IT THIS TIME
IS THERE ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
IN THIS ROOM KNOWN ANYBODY
IN MY POSITION ON THE LINE
ZERO TO PLACE YOUR LINE
IN QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION
ONE QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAS NO FILE ON TWELVE FIFTY
FIVE WITHOUT OBJECTION TWELVE
FIFTY FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING THE MYSTERY AROUND
ELEVEN SIXTY EIGHT ON STATE
AGENCY LICENSING IS THERE
ANY SUPPORT IN THIS ROOM
ANY SUPPORT ON THE PHONE IT'S
JUST LIKE ANOTHER ON BASE
THERE'S OFTEN A Q.
MY NOT PRESENTING WE'RE
ON YOUR FIRST BILL FIRST
SO ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN SIXTY
EIGHT NO ONE CARED UP SIR
ALL RIGHT ANY OPPOSITION TO
ELEVEN SIXTY EIGHT NOBODY'S
HERE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
ONE IN ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF
IN THE QUEUE IN OPPOSITION
THERE IS NO ONE SHOWING UP
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT --
WITHOUT A FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE
A FILE SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
ELEVEN SIXTY EIGHT WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MR MORALE YOU HAVE A
DO PASS BILL TWELVE SEVENTY ONE
AND YOU'RE GOING TO PRESENT TO
US BRIEFLY -- ON THE FINANCING
OF WHY THIS BILL SHOULD PASS
TAKE IT AWAY AND BRIEFLY MEANS
ANYTHING ON OUR ON OUR RIGHT
I DID EVEN IF I DIDN'T
HAVE A MASK I WOULD NOT BE
SMILING OKAY WELL THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS
THIS WILL BE PROBABLY UNDER
FORTY FIVE SECONDS WHICH I
KNOW YOU APPRECIATE IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN AB SIXTEEN
OH EIGHT ALLOWED THE BEER OF
THE BUREAU OF SECURITY AND
INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES TO
AUTHORIZE LICENSED PRIVATE
INVESTIGATORS BE ORGANIZED AS
LIMITED LIABILITY COMPANIES
THIS IS THE SECOND SUNSET
SINCE EIGHTY SIXTEEN OH EIGHT
WAS ENACTED YES SPEAK TWELVE
SEVENTY ONE JUST SIMPLY SMOOTHS
THE SUNSET DATE FROM JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IN CLOSING
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS THE BUREAU
OF SECURITY AND INVESTIGATIVE
SERVICES -- THERE'S BEEN
NO REPORTS RECEIVED AN
INSURANCE CLAIM SINCE THE
LAST SUNSET EXTENSION -- THERE
IS NO REGISTRADAS SESSION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS ALL RIGHT ANYBODY
HERE IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THE ROOM ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT
AGAIN THE OFFICE IS THERE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
AGAIN ONE ZERO READERS ARE
AND WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP
SURE I CAN HEAR WHAT HE SAID
SORRY YOUR VOICE GOT LOW ALL
OF A SUDDEN ALL RIGHT ANY
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THE ROOM AND OPPOSITION IS OR
ANYBODY ONLINE IN OPPOSITION
TO TWELVE SEVENTY ONE
N.
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE AN
OPPOSITION THE MOBILE
SUDDENLY OUR MODERATOR GOT
OFF A LOW HIS VOLUME LEVEL I
CAN'T MAKE AMOUNT SO MODERATOR
HE COULD SPEAK UP LOUDER
THAT WOULD HELP MOORE GET
CLOSER TO YOUR MICROPHONE
AND YOU SAY THERE'S NOBODY
IN THE QUEUE KNOWING
THERE'S NO ONE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT FORMER FINANCE IS
NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL MR
MORALE I ASSUME YOU'RE CLOSES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
HI YEAH WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE BILL -- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS A DO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR S.
P.
TWELVE SEVENTY ONE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
FORTINO FIVE YOU KNOW I BATES
RIGHT BATES BY BRADFORD HILL
HI BILL BY JONES HI JONES
HI LLEVA BY CASKEY HI CASKEY
FIVE BIBLES CALL SO WE'LL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN FOR MS LLEVA
-- AND MISTER BRADFORD ALL
RIGHT AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO MR STERN -- WHO HAS ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE ON THE ANIMAL A
LIVE ANIMAL MARKETS IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM AND SUPPORT
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT SIX
ONE NINE ZERO ON THE PHONE TO
QUEUE UP WE'LL GO TO LINE SIX
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE SIX
SIX THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HELLO MY SIX SIX THREE YOU ARE
MA'AM OKAY HI THIS IS JUDY MAN
CREW SO PRESIDENT OF SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION AGAIN
AND WE ARE CLEAR OF THE BELL
WE HAVE OVERWHELMING SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL AND -- ACROSS
NOT ONLY -- CALIFORNIA BUT
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES IT
IS A SHOWCASE BELL AND AND
ANSWERS A LOT OF QUESTIONS
FOR THE ANIMALS IN DANGER
TO BE SHE AND -- THAT ARE
IN CONTACT WITH HUMANS WHICH
IS WHAT CAUSED WHAT NINETEEN
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER SEVEN HUNDRED AND EIGHT
SEVEN ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS BRENDA WIKI CHI FROM THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
NONPROFIT ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATION AND -- WE THE
COSTS ESTIMATED FOR THIS BILL
ARE GREATLY OVERSTATED AND
AND THE BENEFITS ARE SIMPLY
PRICELESS SO PLEASE DO THAT
FOR THIS TO PASS THANK YOU
ONE SEVEN HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
SEVEN ONE FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN YEAH HELLO THIS IS
CHRISTINA CARON FROM ANIMAL
DEFENDERS INTERNATIONAL OUT
OF LOS ANGELES CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU
WHAT A LINE SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN SIX ONE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN MAILING KATHERINE
ANNE DALE RESIDENT AND BOARD
MEMBER OF THE EAGLE GREEN
GROUP OF COMBAT E.
SPEAKING FOR MYSELF I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
ONE SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE SEVEN TWO FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ROBYN GOOD
SPIN WITH THE REMEMBRANCE
PROJECT IN STRONG SUPPORT
AND LINE SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE SIX FIVE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN AFTERNOON
HEARING MEMBERS BOTH IN
THAT IN THAT LIGHT OF PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE
FUND IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
AND WITH THAT WE'VE EXHAUSTED
THE SUPPORT QUEUE ALL RIGHT
IS THERE OPPOSITION TO ELEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM IS THERE ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE OPPOSED TO
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE YOU LIKE
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
TWO THAT ARE JUST QUEUING
UP ALLOW US A MOMENT TO GET
PROVIDE THEIR LINE NUMBERS
I TEXTED TO YEAH
PUT A LINE FIVE HUNDRED AND
NINETY SIX FIVE NINE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS BILL GAIN SPEAKING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE ROCKY
MOUNTAIN ELK FOUNDATION THE
CALIFORNIA DEER ASSOCIATION
CONFERENCE AFTER AWHILE TO
PUNISHMENT FOR OTHER WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATION
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE
AFRICAN SPECIES PROVISIONS OF
SB ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE AND MANY
AFRICAN SPECIES PROVISIONS COST
OUR STATE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AT A TIME OUR STATE
IS FACING BUDGET SHORTFALLS
IN PROGRAMS AT MUCH GREATER
IMPORTANCE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
AND -- NATIVE WILDLIFE THANK
YOU AND BUT A LINE SIX HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SIX SIX TWO SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THANK YOU
MY NAME IS MICHAEL FINLEY I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION
WEREN'T STRONG OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL IN ADDITION TO MY
APOLOGIES DUE TO TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES EARLIER I WAS NOT
ABLE TO REGISTER MY OPPOSITION
FOR SENATE BILL NINE FOURTEEN
AND LIKE TO DO SO AT THIS TIME
WHAT A LINE NUMBER SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
SEVEN TWO THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN YES GOOD AFTERNOON
EVENING KLEIN ON BEHALF OF
THE CONGRESSIONAL SPORTSMEN'S
FOUNDATION IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THE AFRICAN SNEAKY
PROTECTION ACT PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
AND A LITTLE LINE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SIX SEVEN ZERO
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RECORDED LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF COSTLY RIFLE
PISTOL ASSOCIATION AND THE
NRA WE ARE AN OVERWHELMING
OPPOSITION HAS BUILT FOR
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WE'D LIKE
TO SEE THESE RESOURCES SPENT
ENORMOUS TIME PROTECTING OUR
CALIFORNIA PRECIOUS RESOURCES
ARE NOT NATIVE WILDLIFE
FROM OTHER CONTINENTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
I WENT THAT WE'VE EXHAUSTED
THE OPPOSITION TO ALL RIGHT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS
BILL AND WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON S.
B.
TWELVE FIFTEEN ON THE
ELECTRICITY MICRO GRIDS A IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM AND
SUPPORT KNOW ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE AND SUPPORT THAT'S ONE
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT BOOK A LINE SIX HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN SIX ONE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN MAILINGS
KATHERINE ANNE DALE RESIDENT
AND BOARD MEMBER OF THE EAGLE
GREEN GROUP OF TRAFFIC AND
BADLY SPEAKING FOR MYSELF I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN SEVEN
ONE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
FINE SEVEN FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN WHEN YOU CHECK YOUR
LINE FOR SELF MADE PLEASE
WE ARE RECEIVING NO RESPONSE
FROM LINE SEVEN FIFTEEN
DOT HAS EXHAUSTED THE KILL
ALL RIGHT IS
THEIR OPPOSITION TO S.
B.
TWELVE FIFTEEN GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BERNIE
ROSTER WITH CALIFORNIA
CABLE AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OPPOSING
UNLESS AMENDED THE PHYSICAL
FOR THE ONGOING COSTS ROUGHLY
-- PEERS TO BE REASONABLE --
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
BUT IT'S A ONE TIME COST THAT
YOU HAVE IN CREATING THIS
HUGE DATABASE OF CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THIS IS A
DEFINITION THIS BEING BARRED
FROM HOMELAND SECURITY THERE
ARE SIXTEEN DIFFERENT INDUSTRY
SECTORS AND THAT'S A LOT OF
CRITICAL INFORMATION THAT IS
CONFIDENTIAL THAT WOULD BE
COLLECTED BY THE P.
C.
AND HELP IN THE DATABASE RIGHT
NOW THE PC HAS BEEN WORKING
ON A PROJECT FOR A DATABASE
OF UTILITY POLES THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THAT PROJECT FOR
THREE YEARS AT A COST ABOUT
A MILLION TO ONE POINT THREE
MILLION A YEAR SO WE WOULD
ESTIMATE THAT THIS COST FOR
CREATING THIS ONE TIME DATABASE
OF HIGHLY CONTROVERSIAL
INFORMATION WOULD ROUGHLY
BE IN THE -- THREE TO FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS -- WE WOULD
ALSO OFFER TO THE COMMITTEE
THAT THE DATABASE IS REALLY
NOT NECESSARY FOR WHAT YOU
WANT TO ACCOMPLISH HERE THE
PURPOSE OF THE DATABASE IS
JUSTIFIED MICROGRID PROJECTS
WHICH WE SUPPORT WE STOOD
THE CABLE INDUSTRY SUPPORTS
MICRO GRIDS HOWEVER CREATE A
DATABASE TO JUSTIFY YOU KNOW
FIVE TEN FIFTEEN MICROGRID
PROJECTS A YEAR THAT WOULD
COST MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
CREATE IS PROBABLY OVERKILL
-- I THINK -- THE SUGGESTION
FROM THE COMMITTEE COULD BE
THAT APPLICANTS PROPOSING
MICROGRID PROJECTS COULD IN
FACT SHOWS IN THEIR APPLICATION
SUBMITTED WHAT ARE THE CRITICAL
FACILITIES WITHIN THE RANGE
OF THAT SERVICE TERRITORY BUT
FOR THESE REASONS EVER OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED UNLESS YOU
REMOVE THAT DATABASE THAT'S
BEING CREATED THANK YOU ANYONE
ON THE PHONE WHO IS OPPOSED
TO HELLO TWELVE FIFTEEN AND
THAT'S ONE IN ZERO TO PLACE
YOURSELF INTO THE QUEUE
AND THERE IS NO ONE SHOWING
UP AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES
NOT HAVE A FILE IN THIS BILL
WITHOUT OBJECTION S.
B.
TWELVE FIFTEEN WITH OTHER
SUSPECTS LIVING ON A TWELVE
FIFTY THREE CLIMATE CATALYST
REVOLVING FUND THEIR
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM NOW IS
YOUR SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
ONE AND ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF
IN THE QUEUE AND SUPPORT
THERE'S NO ONE COMING
OUT AT THIS TIME SIR ALL
RIGHT ANY OPPOSITION TO
TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT NOBODY'S
HERE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
IT'S ONE ZERO TO PUT YOURSELF
IN THE QUEUE OVERLYING
STICKS INTO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
MARK SHAW FROM SANTA MONICA
-- THE BILL IT IS A EARLY ON A
SEARCH BASED ON INVALID SCIENCE
IT'S
AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE
AND ONE MORE THAT JUST
QUEUED UP FOR GIVING A LINE
NUMBER USE THIS NAME FOR THE
RESERVATION FOR US MARSHALL
OKAY SURE
THE LINE IS SIX NINETY NINE SIX
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
RIGHT THERE'S CERTAIN RESOURCE
CONNECTION MY APOLOGIES I TRY
TO GET IT I AM IN FAVOR OF
SB TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE HAVE OPTIONS
FOR FINANCING CLIMATE CHANGE
PROJECTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME AND
THAT WAS THE PROBLEM YEAH
-- FORMER FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION TWELVE FIFTY
EIGHT WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE SP
THIRTEEN TWENTY THEIR SUPPORT
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY
HERE MOVING TO ON LINE IS
THERE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE CHANGE
ASSESSMENT ONE MIN ZERO TO PUT
YOURSELF IN QUEUE FOR SUPPORT
NO ONE IS COMING
UP AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY HERE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE AND
OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN TWENTY
ONE MINUTE HERE TO PLACE
YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE WE'LL
GO TWENTY SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THIS WORKSHOP SANTA MONICA
I OPPOSE THE BILL THERE
IS INSUFFICIENT SCIENTIFIC
BASIS IT'S THE WASTE OF MONEY
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME BERMAN FINANCES NOT HAVE A
FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION THIRTEEN
TWENTY WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE
SP THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT
CAL FIRE FIRE PREVENTION
IS THERE ANYONE IN SUPPORT
OF THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT
THERE'S NOBODY HERE ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE IT'S ONE THEN
ZERO TO PLACE YOURSELF
IN THE QUEUE AND SUPPORT
AND WE JUST HAD TO QUEUE
UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WITH A LINE OF SEVEN HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FOUR SEVEN TWO
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
RECYCLING THAT NONE OF
THE PENDING OKAY IN THE
LECTURE BECAUSE THE PART
PUT A LINE TO SEVEN HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SEVEN SEVEN THREE
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN NATALIE
BERGERON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE IN SUPPORT
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE INTO IT
THIS TIME THEIR OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY HERE SOMEBODY
ON THE PHONE OPPOSED TO
SB THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT
IT'S ONE ZERO SEVEN EIGHT
TWO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
EACH PARK SHORE CITY SANTA
MONICA ALSO A A LANDOWNER IN
OTHER NINE ZERO TWO SIX FIVE
FOUR AREA WHICH IS IN BETWEEN
MALIBU AND CALABASAS THIS BILL
IS AN IONIZER IMPOSITION ON
ON PROPERTY OWNERS WHO ARE
ALREADY REGULATED BY LOCAL
-- EARLY COUNTY IN DELHI
COUNTY CASE -- REGULATIONS
FOR THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT FORMER FINANCE IS NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION S.
B.
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT WE'LL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING THE
MISTER MARKETWIRE THREE BILLS
HE'S WAY PRESENTATION AND
ALL THREE FIRST UP IS ELEVEN
EIGHTY NINE ON CONTRACTING
BUSINESS AND IF THERE'S NO ONE
IN THE ROOM IS THERE ANYBODY
ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE H.
ONE MIN ZERO TO PUT
YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE
YEAH
LAST OKAY ONE RESCUE
TRUCK ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WHAT A ONE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN THREE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON
SKIP TOM ON BEHALF OF HUNDREDS
OF MERIT SHOP AND UNIONS
SUBCONTRACTOR COMPANIES IN
SUPPORT OF ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE
BECAUSE IT'S A JOB CREATOR
AND WILL GENERATE REVENUE TO
THE STATE THANK YOU SO MUCH
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION ELEVEN EIGHTY
NINE THERE'S NOBODY HEARS
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE OPPOSED
TO SB ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE
THAT'S ONE ZERO TO PLACE
YOURSELF INTO THE QUEUE
THERE'S NO ONE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT FORMER FINANCE DOES
NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL
WITHOUT OBJECTION SP ELEVEN
EIGHTY NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
AS BE ELEVEN NINETY NINE ON
COMMISSION ON HOME HARDENING
BECAUSE YOUR SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY HERE ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT ONE IN ZERO
TO ONE MIN ZERO PUT YOURSELF
IN THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT
THERE'S NO ONE SHOWING UP AT
THIS TIME OPPOSITION TO ELEVEN
NINETY NINE THERE'S NOBODY
HERE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
ONE IN ZERO TO PUT YOURSELF
IN THE QUEUE AND OPPOSITION
NINE SIX SEVEN TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PARTIALS TO SANTA MONICA
THIS BILL IN THE PREVIOUS ONE
-- WELL EIGHTY EIGHT ELEVEN
NINETY EIGHT -- I THINK SHOULD
BE RECONSIDERED -- A COSTLY
UNNECESSARY COSTS IMPOSED ON
PRIVATE BUSINESS AND HOMEOWNERS
SO NO ONE ELSE INTO IT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT FORMER FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS
BILL SO WITHOUT OBJECTION S.
B.
ELEVEN NINETY NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SP THIRTEEN TWELVE BY
MISTER MCGUIRE IS ON ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS AND THERE'S NOBODY
IN THE ROOM IS OR ANYBODY
ONLINE THAT IS IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN TWELVE IT'S ONE ZERO
TO PLACE YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE
THERE IS NO WARNING QUEUE
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION TO THE SP THIRTEEN
TWELVE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THE ROOM IS THERE ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE OPPOSED TO SP
THIRTEEN TWELVE S.
ONE AND ZERO TO PLACE
YOURSELF IN TWO Q.
WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVEN HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FOUR SEVEN TWO
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN I THINK
A LOT LONGER THAN BEING A
GAS ELECTRIC IN OPPOSITION
BUT LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE OFFICE THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE ONE MORE THAT IS
GEARING UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE
LINE NUMBER JUST TO INFORM
THE THE CHAIR UP IF CHANGE I
WILL BE REPLACED WE'RE GONNA
DO A SOUND CHECK WITH THE
MODERATOR YOU WERE UNABLE TO
HEAR HIM SUFFICIENTLY LAST
TIME WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO SEVEN
THREE TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
SEVEN THREE TO CHECK
ON HER SELF MUTE
NINE SEVEN THREE TWO IS
NOT RESPONSIVE AT THIS TIME
WITH YOUR PERMISSION I'D
LIKE TO DO A SOUND CHECK
SO THAT WE CAN SEND OFF
THERE IS HEARING I THINK THAT
IS GOING ON WHEN YOU NEED
ANYONE HEAR ME IT'S
STILL A LITTLE LOW
THEY'RE NOT TALKING TO
THE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO IS IT ADEQUATE NO
YOUR USER I.
TRONICS HANDSET PARDON ME
ARE YOU USING THE PLANTRONICS
HEADSET THAT WAS PROVIDED
I AM OKAY THERE'S A PLUS
SIGN ON THEIR HIT THAT
AS MANY TIMES AS YOU CAN
THAT DATA HELP ANYTHING A
LITTLE BETTER CAN YOU JUST MOVE
THE MICROPHONE CLOSER TO YOUR
MOUTH I'VE GOT A LIKE A INCH
BRING IT DOWN TO A HALF INCH
IT'S AN OLD SCHOOL THING
THE CLOSE YOUR HEART TO THE
MICROPHONE THE LOTTERY SO
AND THEN THERE'S YOUR VOICE
YOU COULD RAISE YOUR VOICE
WE'RE ALMOST DONE AND THE Q.
S.
ONE THEN ZERO CAN YOU KEEP
TALKING COUNT TO TEN THIRTY ONE
TWO THREE FOUR FIVE SIX SEVEN
EIGHT NINE TEN IT'S JUST NOT
AS GOOD A CONNECTION AS THE
OTHER GENTLEMAN OR AS LOUD BUT
IF THIS IS WHAT WE GOT TO LIVE
WITH JUST PLEASE WE GOT TO KEEP
GOING AND JUST SPEAK LOUDLY
AND SLOWLY OKAY ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SORRY FOR THAT OR
ACCOUNT QUALITY HERE N.
SEVEN LINE SEVEN THIRTY
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
OR ON WHAT OPPOSITION
OF THIRTEEN TWELVE RIGHT
NINE SEVEN THIRTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YOU SELF MUTE
WE'RE GETTING NO RESPONSE
ONE SEVEN THIRTY TWO
I HEARD WE CAN HEAR YOU OKAY
YEAH YES THERE ARE OTHER THAN
BY SEVEN THIRTY TWO THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT SO LAURA PARO
WITH SEVEN CALIFORNIA EDISON
OPTO IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A
FILE ON THIS BILL WITHOUT
OBJECTION THIRTEEN TWELVE
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE MISTER
BRADFORD IS GOING TO PRESENT
SP ELEVEN NINETY TWO VERY
SUCCINCTLY -- AND THIS IS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION TAKE
IT AWAY MISTER BRADFORD THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN HOUSE FOR A
VOTE -- THAT'S B.
ELEVEN NINETY TWO WILL
CREATE A CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
FOR MEMBERS OF POLICE FIRE
FIREFIGHTERS AND POLICE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATIONS ARE AFTER
OFFER LONG TERM DISABILITY
OR CARE BENEFITS US SOME OF
THOSE PROTECTIONS INCLUDE
GIVING MEMBERS ACCESS TO THEIR
BENEFIT PLANS UPON WRITTEN
REQUEST REQUIRING ASSOCIATION
DISCLOSED OUR MEMBERS THAT
THEIR PLAN CONTRACTS ARE NOT
PROTECTED AGAINST INSOLVENCY
BY INSURANCE GUARANTY
ASSOCIATION AND REQUIRING SELF
FUNDED ASSOCIATION SUBMITTED
A ACTUARIAL OPTION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE EVERY
FOUR YEARS -- THIS BILL SIMPLY
HELPS OUR MEMBERS OF THESE
ASSOCIATIONS BY INCREASING
TRANSPARENCY AND ALLOWING
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE TO
BETTER MONITOR THE ACTIONS
ALL RIGHTS ARE ESTIMATED TO
CREATE ONLY MINOR COSTS OF
INSURANCE FINE AND WITH ME
TODAY IS MICHAEL MARTINEZ
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF I ASKED FOR A VOTE ALL
RIGHT MISTER MARTINEZ SHOULD
BE QUEUED UP YES THANK YOU
MICHAEL MARTINEZ FROM THE
HOUSE OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
CONSUMER PROTECTION MEASURE
AS MISTER BRADFORD HAD STATED
THIS MEASURE WOULD CREATE
MINOR COSTS OF THE DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE REVIEW OF THE ACTUARIAL
OPINIONS ASK FOR NIGEL THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE THERE'S NO ONE HERE IS
OR ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN NINETY TWO
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SUPPORT ONE ZERO
AND WE HAVE NO ONE TO END UP
WE DO HAVE A I WANT TO ADD A
FEW JUST QUEUED UP YOUR LINE
IS OPEN THE STATE YOUR NAME
BUT IT WAS UP FOR A COURSE
IN SUPPORT OF THE SPEECH
DELIVERED NINETY TWO CALIFORNIA
STATE PARK OR SITUATION
THANK YOU
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE OPPOSITION
TO ELEVEN NINETY TWO
THERE'S NOBODY HERE IS
THERE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
TO POST ELEVEN NINETY TWO
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE POSED
IF YOU JUST QUEUED UP YOUR LINE
IS OPEN YOU ARE POSTING JUST
QUEUED UP YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HELLO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
MY NAME IS AFRIKA WORKS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE FIREFIGHTERS
ASSOCIATION'S REPORT AND LET
ME TELL YOU DID THAT TWICE
I LOVE THIS BILL
YOU'RE DONE FOR THE DAY AFTER
I GOT OFF THE GOOD NIGHT I
THINK WE'RE ON OPPOSITION
ARE WE ANYBODY OPPOSED
HEARING THE OPPOSITION RIGHT
MODERATOR IF YOU ARE POSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AND WE HAVE NO ONE TO END UP R.
I.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL
MISTER BRADFORD I ASSUME
YOU'RE CLOSES I ASKED FOR MY
VOTE ALL RIGHT -- IS THERE
A MOTION ON MR BRADFORD'S
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
HELD ABOUT RECOMMENDATION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL S.
P.
ELEVEN NINETY TWO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR FORTUNE TINO HI FIVE
FORTINO -- BATES BATES II
BRADFORD RAINFORD HIGH HILL
HILL HI JONES HI JONES OUR
LABOR BY CAL SKI ICE CASKEY
HI SIX MONTHS HI WE WILL KEEP
THAT ROLE OPEN FOR MR LAVER
-- MISTER BRADFORD THAT BILL
WILL GET OUT AND WE WILL
MOVE TO OUR FINAL FIVE BILLS
MISCAVIGE EROS THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
SHE'S WAVE PRESENTATION
ON ALL THREE OF HER BILLS
THERE'S NOBODY HERE IS THERE
ANYONE ON LINE IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE WHICH
IS A NEIGHBORHOOD HOME ACT
AGAIN ONE ZERO AND NINE TO TWO
NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN HI
THIS IS BOB NEAL REPRESENTING
FEELS DEAD AND COMPANY IN
ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF CALIFORNIA
YIMBY AND STRONGLY SUPPORT OF
SENATOR COMPANY AROSE S.
P.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND BLIND FIVE OH
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD
AFTERNOON STILL DEAL FERRERI ON
BEHALF OF FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU AND LINE SIX TWENTY
LINE SIX TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN SIX TWENTY NINE GOOD
AFTERNOON GERARD RIGHT AND
LA COUNTY DECIDED IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU HEY M.
LINE SEVEN OH THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN STRONG WITH
THE BAY AREA HOUSING ADMITS
ADVOCACY COALITION IN SUPPORT
THANKS THANK YOU AND NINE
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
IF YOU LIVE WITHIN THE AREA
COUNCIL AND ADD THAT ON THERE
WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE AND I
ALSO WANT TO REGISTER ON OUR
SUPPORT OR EARLIER AND THE NINE
NINETY FIVE WE HAD TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
OUR IS OUR OPPOSITION
TO THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE OPPOSED
TO THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
OKAY IF YOU ARE AN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AND NINE SIX SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PARTIAL OXIDATION
MARKER AS A RESIDENT I OPPOSE
THIS BILL IS NOT A NRSRO
RESTRICTION ON LOCAL CONTROLS
THIS IS CHRISTIAN SHOULD BE
LEFT TO THE ADMISSIBILITY
THANK YOU M.
LINE SIX FIVE ONE SIX
THREE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HELLO THIS IS DAVID JONES A
MAP OF PALESTINIAN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AND NINE SEVEN FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS A LOUIS
MONTANA CALIFORNIA B.
ACTUALLY AT THE CORE OF THIS
ONE SORRY I HAD A NICKEL
TROUBLE WITH THAT MY PROJECT
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT -- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL WITHOUT OBJECTION SP
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE ABOVE THE
FLOOR SP FORTINO NONFICTION ME
TO ON SUSPENSE S.
B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE OTHER
SUSPECTS SP FORTINO NINE ON
THE ITC NON FILING -- THERE'S
NO ONE HERE IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN OH NINE YOU WERE
NOT IN SUPPORT ONE NINE ZERO
AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE
AND IF YOU AREN'T SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AND LINE SEVEN FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN SEVEN FORTY
FIVE GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR THE
SUBJECT ALONG THE END CHILD
POVERTY CALIFORNIA AGAIN AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS
ALONG WITH ECONOMIC SECURITY
PROJECT AND TIPPING POINT AND
COUNTERPOINT -- WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS TO OUR -- TWO PEOPLE
GET INTO THE HANDS OF FAMILIES
SO THEY CAN PAY FOR RENT ALL
IN ALL THE NECESSARY THINGS TO
ENSURE THAT -- THEIR FAMILIES
AND MAKE ENDS MEET THANK YOU
THANK YOU NINE SEVEN FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS TERRY
ONLY WITH ECONOMIC SECURITY
PROJECT ACTION WHEN THE CO
SPONSORS OF THE SPELL ALONG
WITH -- MY FRIEND JACKIE ONE
WE JUST SPOKE AND TIPPING
POINT COMMUNITY INSTRUCT THE
PART OF THE SPELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND OUR LINE SEVEN
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
SEVEN FIVE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
IS YOUR PHONE ON MUTE
MICROPHONE ON WE HEAR YOU NOW
THANK YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY
I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH THIS BILL
I AM WAITING FOR A.
B.
EIGHT SIX ZERO ALL
RIGHT SO COME BACK WHEN
THAT'S UP THANK YOU
THANK THANK YOU WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN OH NINE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE OPPOSED TO
FOURTEEN OH NINE N.
ONE ZERO IN OPPOSITION
AND WE HAVE KNOWING QUEUING
UP ALL RIGHT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS NOT HAVE A FILE SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION S.
B.
FORTINO NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE COLLECTIVE SP
FOURTEEN TEN TWELVE EMERGENCY
RENTAL ASSISTANCE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE BUT IS THERE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE WHO IS
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN
TEN AND WE DO HAVE LINES SIX
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
DAVID JONES ON BEHALF OF CITY
OF BURBANK AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU AND NOW LINE AT SEVEN FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD SHOULD WE
RESPOND THEY WOULD CALIFORNIA
BE THE COURT THANK YOU AND ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WE HAVE SOMEONE
WITH AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT
WHAT IS THANK YOU SIR WE HAVE
ONE MORE WITH AN OPERATOR THAT
OKAY I JUST COULDN'T HEAR THE
MATTER NOW TO THE LINE AT SEVEN
FORTY FIVE SEVEN FORTY FIVE
I'M SICK IT EXCUSE ME SIX
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN LINE SIX FORTY FIVE
ANDREA HAYES I THANK
THE LANDLORD IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
R.
I.
S.
B.
FOURTEEN TEN THERE'S NOBODY
HERE IN OPPOSITION IS OR
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN TEN
AT NINE SEVEN FIVE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN I AM BORED WHEN
I'M IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU YEAH ONE ZERO
AND IF YOU JUST QUEUED UP YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THE SEPARATISTS
WERE GUN OWNERS CALIFORNIAN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE QUEUING UP ALL RIGHTS
TO THE FORMER FINANCE IS
NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL
WITHOUT OBJECTION AS P.
FOURTEEN TEN MOVES TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON TO SP FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY MISTER BORGE US --
ON STATE REGULATORY ACTION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THE ROOM
AND SUPPORTERS OR ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
AND IF YOU AREN'T SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ONE SEVEN ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
AND WE HAVE KNOWN IF YOU END UP
ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY HERE OPPOSES
ANYBODY ONLINE OPPOSED
AND IF YOU ARE OPPOSED PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ONE
NINE ZERO IF YOU ARE OPPOSED
WE HAVE NO ONE TO END UP ALL
RIGHT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS
BILL WITHOUT OBJECTION SP
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN WILL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE WHICH BRINGS US
TO OUR FINAL ITEM WHICH IS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION -- MR
BERMAN PLEASE COME UP AND TELL
US ABOUT AV EIGHT SIX ZERO
AND I KNOW WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF FOLKS THAT ARE QUEUED UP TO
BE YOUR PRIMARY WITNESSES SO
TELL US ABOUT AV EIGHT SIXTY
THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND SENATORS
AND AND I HEAR THAT SOME FOLKS
HAVE ALREADY CALLED TO WEIGH
IN IN THEIR OPPOSITION -- SO
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
THEM SOON -- NO ONE IS SHOULD
HAVE TO RISK THEIR HEALTH AND
POSSIBLY THEIR LIFE TO EXIT TO
EXERCISE THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO VOTE AND I HOPE THAT
SOMETHING WE CAN ALL AGREE ON
AND YET THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE
SAW ON APRIL SEVENTH OF THIS
YEAR WHEN WISCONSINITES WERE
FORCED TO VOTE IN PERSON IN THE
PRIMARY ELECTION STANDING FOR
HOURS IN LINES THAT STRETCHED
FOR MILES DESPITE THE BEST
EFFORTS OF ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
THOUSANDS OF VOTERS TO REQUEST
ABSENTEE BALLOTS DID NOT
RECEIVE THEM IN TIME TO VOTE
IN RETURN THEM BY ELECTION
DAY THEY WERE EFFECTIVELY
DISENFRANCHISED THIS IS WHY I
HAVE INTRODUCED A B.
EIGHT SIXTY WOULD REQUIRE
THAT EVERY ACTIVE REGISTERED
CALIFORNIA VOTERS BE MAILED
A BALLOT FOR THIS NOVEMBER'S
GENERAL ELECTION THIS WILL
ENSURE THAT EVERY CALIFORNIA
VOTER HAS THE ABILITY TO VOTE
FROM THE SAFETY OF THEIR OWN
HOME THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
INDICATES COSTS OF SEVENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO MOVE THE
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY GENERAL
ELECTION TO AN ALL MALE EVENT
WITH MUCH OF THE COSTS BEING
PAID FOR BY FEDERAL FUNDS MUCH
OF THAT SEVENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS INCLUDING APPROXIMATELY
FORTY SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR VOTER EDUCATION
OR FOR COSTS THAT ARE NOT
EXCLUSIVELY ATTRIBUTABLE TO
THIS BILL BUT BECAUSE COSTS
FOR THINGS LIKE VOTER EDUCATION
CANNOT EASILY BE ATTRIBUTED
TO ANY SINGLE CHANGE TO THE
LAW ALL COSTS THAT ARE EVEN
PARTIALLY ATTRIBUTABLE TO
VOTING BY MAIL HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED IN THIS COST ESTIMATE
PREPARED BY THE SECRETARY OF
STATE IN ANY EVENT THE SENATE
AND THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSED
BUDGET FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR INCLUDES
FUNDING TO COVER THE COSTS
OF CONDUCTING THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION IN A MANNER THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH THIS BILL AND
WITH SENATOR UMBERG'S S.
BEFORE TWENTY THREE WHICH
IS PENDING IN THE ASSEMBLY
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY SUPPORTED
BY AT LEAST TWENTY FOUR
DIFFERENT CALIFORNIA
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTING
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
AS WELL AS BY SECRETARY
OF STATE ALEX PADILLA MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT AS
OF -- A LITTLE BIT BEFORE
NOW OVER FOUR THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED MEMBERS OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE SIGNED
PETITIONS IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT THOSE FOUR THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE DO NOT ALL
CALL IN INDIVIDUALLY THIS
AFTERNOON TO VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR MY BILL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE AND TESTIFYING TODAY
IS SUSAN THE LAPSE LEAVE
FROM THE OFFICE OF SECRETARY
OF STATE ALEX PADILLA
SHE SHOULD BE QUEUED
UP AND THREE MINUTES
TOTAL FOR YOUR SPEAKERS
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
LOOKING OF THE COMMITTEE -- I'M
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THE -- AS YOU CAN REMEMBER HAS
HAS PRESENTED THERE IS THE COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BUILT IN
EIGHTEEN MILLION THESE COSTS
ARE RELATED TO YOU BOTH B.
M.
EIGHT A.
B.
EIGHT THIRTY AND AT FOUR
TWENTY THREE AM AND THEN COULD
I DIDN'T FOR PRINTING BALLOT
IN QUITMAN BALLOT DROP BOXES
YEAH I MEAN BECAUSE AND AS
WELL AS COMMUNICATIONS AND
OUTREACH AND I THINK THAT THE
STEPPING OUT THIS GOES THROUGH
THE COST OF VERY WELL AND I'M
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THERE'S NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN THIS ROOM IS THERE
ANYBODY ONLINE THAT WANTS TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
MR MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE
THEM UP AND AT THIS POINT
WILL TAKE AIM ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION AGAIN ONE ZERO
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT LINE
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
I'M
GO AHEAD PLEASE
FIVE SEVEN FIFTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
I'M AN OPPOSITION I'D MUSTER
TO THEM TOO SOON ALL RIGHT
YOU CAN JUST SAY YOUR NAME AND
THAT YOU'RE OPPOSED AND WE'LL
PUT IT DOWN I AM BOARDMAN I
HATE YOU KNOW I'D BEEN DOING
ELECTIONS FOR TWENTY YEARS
OUT HERE AND I'VE NEVER WAS
AND NEVER CONCEIVED WITH MAIL
IN BALLOTS WORKING OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND NOW TO
LINE FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETY
THREE FIVE NINETY THREE GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS CAROLINE
CENTER OF THE YELLOW COUNTY
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION WHICH
DEFINITELY OPPOSES EIGHTY EIGHT
SIXTY WE ARE VERY MUCH IN FAVOR
OF MAINTAINING THE VOTER ROLLS
SENDING OUT BALLOTS TO DECEASED
AND INACTIVE FOR MANY YEARS
VOTERS IT'S A GREAT COST TO THE
TAXPAYERS THAT COULD BE PUT TO
BETTER USE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU WE ARE ON THE SUPPORT
SIDE SO IF THE OPPOSE FOLKS CAN
HOLD UP THAT WOULD BE GREAT BUT
WE'LL TAKE SUPPORT ALL RIGHT
AND AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AND NOW TWO LINES SEVEN SIXTY
SIX SEVEN SIX SIX MY ANGER --
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN THE PORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU LINE FIVE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
FIND FIVE SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
I'M IN THE WRONG QUEUE
I AM OPPOSED TO A.
B.
EIGHT SIXTY LET'S JUST
SAY YOUR NAME WILL TAKE
IT DOWN NOW AMERICA LOCAL
BUSINESS OWNER THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE SEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
YES THIS IS ALAN CARPENTER I'M
VERY MUCH OPPOSED TO THIS ONE
OF MY NEIGHBORS HAD ACTUALLY
GOT EIGHT BALLOTS IN THE MAIL
I DON'T THINK THIS IS A GOOD
IDEA THANK YOU WE'RE STILL
LOOKING FOR SUPPORTERS NAME
ORDERS PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AND NINE SIXTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN HI MY NAME'S
CHAMELEON THE DIRECTOR DAY
RISING A COALITION OF THIRTY
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE AREA WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND NINE
SEVEN THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN SEVEN THIRTY SIX HI
MY NAME THEY WILL THANK GOD
FOR HIM I'M NOT JUST A CLIENT
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
ORGANIZATIONS TEN ORGANIZATIONS
IN RICHMOND OAKLAND TEMPTED
CALL CENTER CALL CENTER VALLEY
EACH SIDE TO GET ALL OF US AND
IT'S INTENDED -- I'M CALLING
TO LOG MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTEEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND NOW LINE
FOR SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN FOR SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU
BUT I'M OUT OF ORDER I THINK
I'M I'M OPPOSED THANK YOU THE
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND
THAT LINE IS SEVEN THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
WELL MANY OF THE NEW YORK
MONTHLY GOVERNMENT ORDERED
THE POPCORN YET IN COURT
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND NINE
SEVEN SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ROCKY BENNETT JELLY
STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU NINE SEVEN SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN HI
AMY HAMBLIN WITH NEXT GEN
POLICY CONNOR I'M IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU AND OUTLINED
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD HIS SHANNON ALLISON
THE DIRECTOR FOR NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA INSTRUCTION
PART THANK YOU AGAIN IF YOU
AREN'T SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AND NINE FIVE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
FIVE EIGHTEEN
YOUR PHONE ON MUTE
I HAVE NO RESPONSE FROM LINE
FIVE EIGHTEEN OR MOVING ON
TO SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT SEVEN
SIX EIGHT HI THIS IS VERONICA
GOT A SOLID POLICY DIRECTOR
FOR CALIFORNIA CALLED ON THE
POINT THANK YOU THANK YOU
AGAIN IF YOU AREN'T SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND
OUTLINED SEVEN SEVEN ONE SEVEN
SEVENTY ONE GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT NOW WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THE ROOM OPPOSED IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME HERE YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION
AND WE WILL GO TO THE PHONES
THANK YOU LINE SIX SEVEN
SIX SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN SIX SEVENTY TWO FORMER
RATHER THAN THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA ORIGINAL VOTER BALLOT
VOTER THIS BILL IS TOTALLY
UNNECESSARY -- FROM A CANAL
STANDPOINT NO ONE GOT SICK OR
DIED WISCONSIN A BOGUS SITE
APPLICATION -- PEOPLE CAN
BE SAFE GOING TO THE POLLS
INSTITUTIONAL MANNER PROTEIN
NEEDS TO BE OBSERVABLE CREEK
VALLEY THIS BILL IS NOT ONLY AN
INVITATION TO FRAUD IT'S IT'S
AN INCITEMENT AND A PROMOTION
TO ENABLE A BROAD SIR THANK
YOU SHOULD BE OPPOSED TO SHOULD
BE VOTED DOWN THANK YOU PLEASE
NAME AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION ONLY I KNOW THERE IS
ONE OFFICIAL SPEAKER -- WHO IS
DESIGNATED BY THE OPPOSITION
WERE TRYING TO TRACK THAT DOWN
PERSON DOWN BUT THE REST OF YOU
-- NAME ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION THANK YOU MR GEORGIA
LET ME KNOW WHO THAT IS YEAH
AT THAT ARE YOU LOOKING FOR
THE PEOPLE PERSON I HOPE
RUTH WEISS OKAY SIR ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO RUTH WEISS
SHE'S ON THE PHONE AND SHE'S
GOING TO BE AFFORDED THE THREE
MINUTES HIS WIFE YOU ON THE
PHONE YES I AM CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES I CAN YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES THANK YOU WONDERFUL
WELL THANK YOU IT'S BEEN A
VERY LONG DAY OF HARD WORK AND
I'M SURE YOU'RE GLAD TO BE AT
THE END OF -- I WOULD REMIND
YOU THAT ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT CALIFORNIA HOUSES
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY BECAUSE
WE FIND IT TO BE UNNECESSARY
BUT ALSO POTENTIALLY DAMAGING
EXPENDITURE THAT THE CENTRAL
GOVERNMENT FUND WE WERE FOUNDED
IN TWENTY TEN WHICH AS A NON
PARTISAN FIVE OH ONE P.
THREE PUBLIC BENEFIT
CORPORATION WE HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF ADVOCATING
FOR VOTERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND TWO OF OUR
MAIN GOALS IS NUMBER ONE TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
ELIGIBLE TO REGISTER TO VOTE
BE AFFORDED THOSE RIGHTS FREE
OF IMPEDIMENTS OF ANY KIND I
NEVER CHOOSE TO PROTECT THEIR
VOTES FROM THE POTENTIAL OF
BEING CANCELED OUT WERE DILUTED
BY ILLEGITIMATE OR ILLEGAL
ABOUT OUR MINDED AT SEVENTY
FIVE PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS
ARE ALREADY SLATED TO RECEIVE A
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT ANYWAY THE
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
YOU KNOW VERY WELL THAT WITH
A SIMPLE PHONE CALL THEY CAN
REQUEST THE BALLOT IF THEY'RE
UNCOMFORTABLE PUTTING THEIR
HEALTH AT RISK AND GOING OUT
TO VOTE AND SO -- WE BELIEVE
IT TO BE UNNECESSARY AS RESULT
TO PROTECT OUR HEALTH AND
SAFETY BUT IT WOULD RESULT
IN A FINANCIAL COST TO THE
STATE THAT REALLY COULD BE
PUT IN A BETTER PLACE FOR
EXPENDITURE BECAUSE OF THE
SITUATION CURRENTLY FOUND IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THERE ARE
ROUGHLY A HALF A MILLION ACTIVE
REGISTERED FROM CALIFORNIA
VOTER ROLL TO HAVE NOT BEEN
SEEN OR HEARD FROM OR AT LEAST
TWELVE YEARS THAN MOST FOR MANY
DECADES ROUGHLY HALF A MILLION
BALLOTS WOULD UNDER EIGHTY
EIGHT SIXTEEN BEING MAILED
TO THE LAST KNOWN ADDRESSES
OF THOSE REGISTRANTS WHO ARE
LIKELY TO STEVE OR RELOCATED
TO OTHER STATES THERE ARE
ALSO TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DUPLICATED REGISTRATIONS ON
THE VOTE RESULTS FROM TWO OR
MORE BALLOTS WOULD BE SENT
THE COST OF CONTRACTING FOR
AN EXTRA HALF MILLION BALLOTS
TO BE PRINTED REPAIRED AND
POSTAGE PAID WOULD REPRESENT
AN UNNECESSARY AND DETRIMENTAL
USE OF TAXPAYER MONEY IN AN
ALREADY FINANCIALLY TROUBLED
TIME THE CARD TO THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY WOULD ALSO BE
CRIPPLING THE OVERFLOWING JAILS
AND OVERWHELMED COURT SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIA ARE IRREVOCABLE
EVIDENCE THAT ONLY THERE'S
NO SHORTAGE OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO WILL TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
OPPORTUNITIES PRESENTED TO
BEHAVE ON SCRUPULOUSLY IF IT
IS TO THEIR ADVANTAGE HALF
A MILLION BALLOTS MAILED
WITH NO LEGITIMATE RECIPIENT
AT THE OTHER END IS SUCH AN
OPPORTUNITY AND THERE'S NO GOOD
SYSTEM THAT PROTECTS YOUR VOTE
OR MINE FROM BEING TRAMPLED
OR DILUTE IT BY MAIL BALLOT
THAT CAN EASILY BE ACQUIRED
VOTED BY SOMEONE OTHER THAN
THE LEGITIMATE VOTERS AND
SUBSEQUENTLY CHATTED WITH NO
TRACE OF DETECTION WE'VE BEEN
OBSERVING BALLOT PROCESSING
FOR NINE PLUS YEARS AND WE KNOW
THAT TO BE TRUE NO ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT CALIFORNIA
URGES THAT YOU DO ONE OF
TWO ACTION OUT TODAY EITHER
DON'T WELL MAYBE EIGHT WEEKS
FORWARD BECAUSE OF THE COST
IN THAT IN WHAT B.
AND COURAGE IF YOU ARE GOING
TO MOVE IT FORWARD WE WOULD
ASK THAT YOU AMEND THE BILL
TO MANDATE THAT DOES HAPPEN
MILLION ACTIVE REGISTRANTS
WHO ARE LIKELY TO FEAST OR
RELOCATED TO OTHER STATES BEING
MAILED THE REQUISITE EIGHTY
TWO CARDS AND DEACTIVATED
PRIOR TO THE BEGINNING OF
THE AUGUST DEADLINE FOR VOTER
LIST MAINTENANCE SO THAT
PUBLIC TRUST IN THE ELECTION
CAN BE BOTH DEAD AND A LOT
OF CALIFORNIA TAXPAYER MONEY
CAN BE SAVED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR
OPPOSITION AT THIS POINT THE
PRIMARY SPEAKER HAS USED THE
ALLOTTED TIME FOR SPEECHES AND
HER PRESENTATION SO WE ARE JUST
TAKING NAME AFFILIATION AND
YOUR POSITION SO WE'LL GO TO
THE TELEPHONES THANK YOU AGAIN
ONE ZERO AND NINE SIX SIXTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN SIX HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR HI YES MY NAME IS
LIZA MORGAN AND I'M SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF AND VOTER MAIL
FRAUD AS WELL AS CONCERNED
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
ABC EIGHT SIXTY THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT OUTLINE OF SEVEN
FORTY NINE SEVEN FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD PROBYN SAID
STAN WHAT THE REMEMBRANCE
PROJECT REPRESENTING
TEN THOUSAND MEMBERS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO A.
B.
EIGHT SIXTY WE NEED VOTER
ID THANK YOU AN OUTLINE OF
FIVE SIXTEEN FIVE SIXTEEN
YES MY NAME IS LAURA
OHLMEYER I AM A MEMBER OF
HIS INTEGRITY PROJECT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE H.
ZERO UNLESS IT IS AMENDED AS
REPLACING SUGGESTION THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND NOW TO THE LINE
OF SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
FINALLY CHANGE SEVEN SEVEN
SAN DIEGO AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU AND NOW
TO LINE FIVE THIRTY FIVE
FIVE THIRTY AS I HEAR ME YES
YES MY NAME IS RAUL RODRIQUEZ
JUNIOR AND I AM THE CALIBER
COORDINATOR PRIMERICA PERSONAL
CHANNELS AND AS A CANDIDATE
FOR THE SECRETARY OF STATE
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN I LIKE
THIS IDEA OF YOUR POLITICIANS
LEVI'S EIGHT SIXTY ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT THANK YOU YOU AT FIVE
FIVE OR SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YES MY NAME IS ALAN BERGMAN
I'M A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT
SIXTY THANK YOU ONE SEVEN FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN HI KAREN
GILCHRIST COUNTY AND I HAVE
HEARD THAT MEASURE THANK YOU
AND NINE SEVEN ELEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN HI MY NAME IS COLIN
BRITAIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
OUR LEADERS THAT WORK AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NINE FIVE EIGHTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN HELLO THIS
IS EUNICE MALLEY I'M WITH THE
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT OF
CALIFORNIA I LIVE IN SOLANO
COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSED THIS
BILLS THANK YOU M.
NINE FIVE NINETY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN HI THIS IS A JUNIOR
AND A CALIFORNIA CITIZEN
LIVING INSIDE A CALIFORNIA
OPPOSED FOR REASONS OF CHAIN
OF CUSTODY THANK YOU MIND
THAT SEVEN HUNDRED SEVEN
ZERO ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
AMY CHOATE MEMBER OF THE
PLASTER COUNTY REPUBLICANS
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT
SIXTY THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
MINE SEVEN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
SEVEN TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN THIS IS SPEECH KERO I'M
WITH PRE ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
A SIXTY THANK YOU MINUS SIX
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
SIX FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE SIX FORTY FIVE
WITHOUT RESPONSE WILL MOVE
ON TO LINE FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN FIVE THIRTY SEVEN IS
CHARLES CORONA CALIFORNIA
CITIZEN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY THANK
YOU AND NOW TO LINE AT SEVEN
FIFTY ONE SEVEN FIFTY ONE
TRACY REVEL IN BRITAIN ON
A SAN DIEGO RESIDENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AT SIXTY THANK
YOU AND NOW LINE SEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD HELLO MY NAME IS
GWEN MYERS I LIVE IN PLASTER
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB EIGHT SIXTEEN I AM ALSO
ASSOCIATED WITH COLLECTIVE
ACTION INTEGRITY PROJECT THANK
YOU THANK YOU IN LINE FIVE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
CAMILLE HOLD GRASS VALLEY HI
I ADAMANTLY OPPOSE IT IN LESS
AS IT AND LEFT IT WAS AMENDED
AS SUGGESTED BY RUTH WEISS
JUST -- AWHILE AGO THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE
AT SIX THIRTEEN SIX THIRTEEN
MY NAME IS KAREN LAWLEY I'M
A REGISTERED VOTER IN PLASTER
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB EIGHT SIXTY PORT THE
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
THANK YOU LINE FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO THIS IS JOHNNY MORGAN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
I AM OPPOSED TO A.
B.
EIGHT SIXTY THANK YOU SIR
AND OUTLINED SEVEN FORTY TWO
SEVEN FORTY TWO SHARES LARRY
LAMB HELLO AGAIN BUT THE TRI
VALLEY REPUBLICANS IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
SB EIGHT SIX DATE THANK YOU AND
OUTLINES SEVEN FIFTY TWO SEVEN
FIFTY TWO SUSAN KENNEDY SAN
DIEGO COUNTY I OPPOSE AB EIGHT
SIXTY THANK YOU NINE SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR SEVEN THIRTY FOUR
YES I MET JAMES HALL
I'M A VOTING RESIDENCE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY I'M IN
A POSITION OF A V.
EIGHT SIXTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND NINE SEVEN SEVEN TWO
SEVEN SEVENTY TWO HI THIS IS
MERRY MOCHI I'M A SAN DIEGO
RESIDENT AND I'M VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT ELECTION INTEGRITY AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT
SIXTY THANK YOU THANK YOU
NINE SEVEN SEVENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD SEVEN SEVENTY
HELLO THIS IS AGAIN A
KAISER I AM THE SECRETARY
OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB EIGHT
THANK YOU LINE OF FIVE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
-- HI THIS IS GEORGIA RIGHT
SHAWANO COUNTY REPUBLICAN
CENTRAL COMMITTEE AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT
SIXTY THANK YOU AND NOW TO
LINE FIVE EIGHTY THREE FIVE
EIGHTY THREE MY NAME IS
DORIS THE LEGAL CLASSICAL
COLLECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL WE WELCOME ENCOURAGEMENT
WE WANT TO SHOW I.
D.
ELIMINATE ELECTION FRAUD
THANK YOU AND THAT WAS NINE
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT SEVEN
FORTY EIGHT MY NAME IS JIM
MACER SELLECK I'M A NATIVE
CALIFORNIAN RESIDENTS LACK
SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT
SIXTY THANK YOU AND NOW TO
LINES SEVEN SIXTY THREE SEVEN
SIXTY THREE KATHLEEN COLIN
REGISTERED VOTERS PLASTER
COUNTY ABSOLUTELY OPPOSED
TO IT EIGHTY EIGHT SIX ZERO
THANK YOU THANK YOU AN OUTLINE
SEVEN THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD HEY GRACE MYERS SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AN OPPOSITION
OF EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTY THANK
YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION AND OUTLINED
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR FIFTY FOUR
YES WE CAN TALK AGAIN RIGHT I
HAVE A QUESTION HELLO -- YOU
CAN ONLY STATE YOUR POSITION
THE POSITION AS OPPOSITION
DUE TO THE HARVESTING OF
THESE BALLOTS SO ANYTIME YOU
HAVE MAIL IN BALLOTS DO NOT
EVERY ONE OF THE NEXT WEEK
OR THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE
SIX FORTY FIVE SIX FORTY FIVE
BY SIX FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN WE DON'T WANT THAT ON OKAY
HELLO ANDREA HAYES SEVEN DIEGO
RESIDENTS STRONGLY OPPOSE A.
B.
AGE SIXTY THANK YOU AND NOW
TO LINE SEVEN EIGHTEEN SEVEN
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU KAREN
KLINGER SACRAMENTO COUNTY HELLO
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT SEVENTEEN
DAYS AFTER ELECTION DAY THANK
YOU JUDGE YOUR OPPOSITION
NEXT BEAKER OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK THANK YOU WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
PLEASE CONTINUE ALL RIGHTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE THOSE WHO ADHERED
TO THE NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION -- PROCESS IT WAS
APPRECIATED -- THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE
ON THIS BILL -- MR BERMAN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECT S.
ZERO VOTE THAT'S MY
FAVORITE CLOTHES WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER BRADFORD
TO MOVE THE BILL ARE YOU
MAKING A MOTION AS WELL I WAS
GOING TO MAKE A MOTION ASKING
I DIDN'T KNOW THE PROPER UP
YOU CAN MAKE YOUR LIFE AS WELL
YES WELL I THINK OF THE ISSUE
HERE IS THAT THE B.
O.
-- CLEARLY HAS MAJOR COUGH
I THINK WE'RE TALKING TEN
MILLION DOLLARS ARE JUST FOR
OUT REACH BY THE SECRETARY OF
STATE ENOUGH STOCKS IMPORTANT
IN EDUCATION BACHELOR TENS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ARE
GOING TO BE MANDATED ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SO -- ACCORDING
TO THE STANDARDS WE USUALLY
FOLLOW HERE ON FINANCIAL COST
-- THE I BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE
SENT TO SUSPENSE TODAY SO I'D
LIKE TO MOVE THAT THE BILL BE
PLACED ON THE SUSPENSE FILE ALL
RIGHT MY UNDERSTANDING OF --
OUR PARLIAMENTARY PROCEDURES
WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE
BILL WITH THE RECOMMENDATION
TO THE FLOOR WE HAVE A MOTION
TO PLACE THE BILL ON SUSPENSE
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING FROM
STAFF THAT THE SUSPENSE EMOTION
TAKES PRECEDENCE SO WE HAVE TO
VOTE ON THAT MOTION FIRST SO
THE CHAIR WILL BE ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE ON THE MOTION -- BY
THE WAY THESE ARE ALL PROPERLY
EXECUTED MOTIONS AND SO NOTHING
OUT OF THE ORDINARY -- AND SO I
COMPLIMENT MY COLLEAGUE MY VICE
CHAIR -- AND SO WE WILL TAKE A
VOTE ON THE FIRST MOTION WHICH
WILL BE TO PLACE THE BILL ON
SUSPENSE AND THE CHAIR WILL BE
RECOMMENDING AND NO SO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL EIGHTY EIGHT
SIXTY THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE
A BILL TO SUSPENSE FORTINO NO
FOURTEEN OH NO BATES HI EIGHT
FIVE BRADFORD NO BRADFORD
NO HILL HE'LL KNOW JONES HI
JONES HI LAVER NO LABOR NO
WHITE COW SKI NO CASKEY NOW
THE BILL HAS TWO VOTES FOR THE
MOTION FAILS TO PLACE IT ON
SUSPENSE OBVIOUSLY THE CALENDAR
IS IMPORTANT TO WHAT THE SIX
DISCUSSION WHICH CREATES AN
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCE SO
I HOPE YOU ALL CAN APPRECIATE
THAT WE NOW HAVE ANOTHER MOTION
BY MISTER BRADFORD TO MOVE THE
BILL -- PASSABLE OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
THAT MOTION MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR FORTINO
I WAS THINKING OH ALL RIGHT
PASTES NO EIGHT SNOW BRADFORD
BRADFORD HILL HI BILL HI JONES
JONES NO LABOR I HAVE A HI MY
COW SKI HI BY CAL SKI FIVE FIVE
FIVE TWO TWO THAT MOTION PASSES
FIVE TWO TWO WE DO HAVE TWO
ITEMS ON CALL -- THAT ARE OPEN
-- WE HAVE TWELVE SEVENTY ONE
ELEVEN NINETY TWO MR SECRETARY
IF YOU COULD OPEN THE ROLE AND
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM -- TWELVE
SP TWELVE SEVENTY ONE IT IS S.
B.
TWELVE SEVENTY ONE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
BRADFORD BRADFORD HI LAVER
LABOUR HI AT SEVEN THOSE THAT
BILL HAS SEVEN ROADS IN OUR
SECOND OPEN ITEM IS ELEVEN
NINETY TWO -- PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE AND CALL THE ROLL ON SP
ELEVEN NINETY TWO SP ELEVEN
NINETY TWO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
LLEVA HI LAVER I HAVE SEVEN
VOTES ALL RIGHT THE BILL IS
OUT I WANT TO COMPLIMENT MY
COLLEAGUES THIS WAS A LONGER
THAN NORMAL HEARING AND WE
HAD SOME INTERRUPTIONS AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
AND WE WILL BE BACK ON THE
EIGHTEENTH AND EVERYBODY
BE SAFE THIS WEEKEND OVER
THE WEEKEND THANK EVERYBODY
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED
YES